hello everyone i'm bhabha khandelwal and
i welcome you all to simply learns
youtube channel
today we'll be having a c-sharp tutorial
for beginners but before we get started
i hope my screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine
if yes please type in yes if there is no
issue
then do let us know in the chat section
so that we can resolve
i'm seeing a lot of positive responses
that's great
let's wait for some time for others to
join us
great i think we can get started with
the c-sharp tutorial for beginners
let's look at the agenda for today's
session we will begin our session with
what is c sharp
then we will go into the installation
process for visual studio code
then we will have a discussion on the
basics surrounding c sharp then we will
be discussing the time complexity for
various problems
then we will have a brief discussion on
primitive types and variables
after that we will have a discussion on
operators and variables
then we will have a brief discussion on
c-sharp oops
following that we will look at the
c-sharp arrays
after that we will be discussing the
conditional statements in c sharp
following that we will have a brief
discussion on c sharp loops
then
we will have a look at methods in c
next we will have a discussion on c
sharp delegates
then we will be understanding the
concepts such as wheat
async can await
and dependency injection
after that we will look into various
design patterns
following that we will have a discussion
on lambda expression and link in c sharp
then we will be discussing concepts like
dictionary hash table and sets
then
we will be going into more detail with
the collection in c sharp
after that
we will be studying the c sharp
interfaces
then we will look into the streams in c
sha
after that
we will be finishing up with a basic c
sharp
with multi-threading
then we will be installing the visual
studio on windows 10.
after that we will start with more
advanced topics like c sharp and td
framework
and mvc crude where we will be applying
crude operations on a model view
controller software
after that we will be discussing the web
services
following that we will be discussing the
web api and the rest api
after that we will be
creating a basic gui of application
then we will go more in depth with c
sharp application
then we will be creating a project
calculator in c sharp
and finally we will end our session with
top c sharp interview questions and
answers
let's begin with our first topic and
attempt to comprehend what is c sharp
programming language
c sharp is a strongly typed
object-oriented programming language c
sharp is an open source programming
language that is simple modern flexible
and versatile
anders albert from microsoft created the
c programming language used to write
software programs in 2000
it was later approved as an
international standard by ekman 2002 and
iso and 2003
followed by that let us learn where
exactly c programming language is being
used
c sharp is a general purpose programming
language that can create a variety of
programs and applications while it is
heavily versatile it is mainly used for
three different fields
the first field in which c-sharp is used
is the web application development
second
is the windows applications
and the third field in which c
programming language is used is game
development
we will see all the three fields where c
sharp is being used one after the other
so the first and foremost we will
discuss the web application development
regardless of the platform you can still
use the c programming language you can
build dynamic websites and web apps
using the dotnet platform or other open
source platforms now we'll talk about
the second field where c-sharp is being
used that is windows applications
microsoft created c-sharp for microsoft
so it's no surprise that it's famous for
creating windows applications
it makes your development process run
smoothly and features like c-sharp
garbage collector performs admirably
finally we will discuss the third field
that is games where c-sharp is being
extensively used developers in the
gaming industry prefer the c-sharp
programming language this language is
beneficial for creating fan favorite
games in addition the unity game engine
one of the most popular today is written
in c plus and c sharp
after understanding the field in which c
sharp programming language is used we
will realize some c sharp
characteristics
c sharp has the following
characteristics so the first
characteristics of c sharp is that it is
modern and easy the second
characteristic is that it is fast and
open source the third distinguishing
feature of c-sharp is its cross-platform
compatibility the following feature is
security
the fifth characteristic of c
programming language is its versatility
and the last characteristic is the
evolution of c sharp programming
language it is still an evolving
condition so you can expect some major
updates in the coming near future
now we will go all over the
characteristics we have seen in detail
one by one
the first one is the modern and easy
characteristics of c sharp
c sharp is a simple modern and
object-oriented programming language
c-sharp was created to create a
programming language that is simple to
learn and supports modern functionality
of all types of software development
second we have the fast and open source
characteristics of c sharp
c sharp is an open source and managed by
the dot net foundation which is
independent of microsoft
in comparison to the other high level
programming languages c sharp is fast c
sharp version 8 has numerous performance
enhancements the third characteristic of
c sharp programming language is its
cross-platform capability
c programming language works on multiple
platforms so you can create dot-net
applications that run on windows lineups
and mac computers c-sharp apps can also
be deployed in the cloud and containers
the fourth characteristic of c-sharp
programming language is the safety
c-sharp is a type-safe programming
language c-sharp does not permit type
conversions which may result in data
loss or other issues
c-sharp allows developers to write safe
code charge also focuses on writing
efficient code
now the fifth characteristic
the fifth characteristic of seisha
programming language is its versatility
c sharp functions as a swiss army knife
unlike almost all programming languages
c sharp was created with a single goal
to do
c sharp can be used to create today's
modern software applications c-sharp can
be used to create a wide range of
applications such as windows client apps
components and libraries services and
apis web applications mobile
applications cloud applications and
video games
the last and sixth characteristic of c
programming language is its evolving
nature
c sharp version 8 is the most recent
version of c
if you look at the evolution of c
programming language you will notice it
is evolving faster than any other
programming language
c sharp is initially designed to write
windows client applications but it can
also now do almost anything including
console cloud and modern machine
learning software finally we will look
at some of the important benefits of c
programming language
the first benefit of c sharp programming
language is that all environments
plugins and library supports c sharp
the next benefit is c-sharp can run
desktop mobile and web applications and
c-sharp offers cross-platform with
dependable performance
following by that the next benefit is
2019 stack overflow survey 31.9 percent
of the professional developers prefer
the c programming language and have the
third largest community
the last and fourth benefit of c
programming language is that c sharp
received 67 percent approval as the most
popular programming language globally
there are over 5000 c-sharp jobs
available in the united states alone
so visual studio code is also known as
vs code
it is a small but powerful source code
editor that runs on your desktop and is
available for windows mac os and linux
it includes built-in support for
javascript typescript and node.js as
well as robust ecosystem of extensions
for other programming languages and
runtimes including c plus c sharp java
python php and go such as dotnet and
unity now that we have a brief
understanding of what exactly visual
studio code is
we will look into some of the important
features of visual studio code
so the first feature of visual studio
code is that it supports multiple
programming languages
next intellisense function of visual
studio code is the next feature the
third one is the visual studio code is
compatible with multiple platforms or it
is platform independent
the next important feature of visual
studio code is that it has multiple
extension and support features
the fifth feature of visual studio code
is that it has a rich repository
the sixth feature of visual studio code
is that it supports web development
next the visual studio code follows an
hierarchy structure
the eighth feature of visual studio code
is that the simple user interface helps
users to improve their code
the next feature of visual studio code
is that it helps in enabling git support
and lastly comments and visual studio
code is the last feature of visual
studio
we will go through all these features
one after the other
firstly we will discuss the multiple
programming languages support
so visual studio has support for
multiple programming languages
previously programmers required a web
support a different editor for each
language but now visual studio code
includes built-in multi-language support
this also means that if there is a flaw
or a cross-language reference it will be
able to detect easily the next feature
is intellisense visual studio code can
detect if any snippet of the code is
missing in addition common variables and
taxes or variable declarations are
generated automatically for example if a
variable is used in program but the user
forgets to declare it intellisense will
declare it for the user
the older code editors are supported
either by windows linux or mac operating
systems as they are dedicatedly built
for those operating systems only however
visual studio code is a cross-platform
application as a result it is compatible
with all the three platforms furthermore
the code runs on the three platforms
otherwise the open source and
proprietary software codes used to be
distinct
the fourth feature of visual studio code
is extension and support state that it
supports all programming languages but
if a user a programmer wants to use a
programming language that isn't
supported he can download and use an
extension in terms of performance the
extensions do not slow down the editor
the fifth feature of visual studio code
is repository this feature on repository
says that with the ever increasing
demand for code security and timely
storage is critical for pulling and
saving instances it is linked to github
and linked to any other repository
now the sixth feature is
web support
it includes all the support for web
applications as a result web
applications can be created and
supported in visual studio code
hierarchy structure is the next feature
of visual studio code which states that
the code files are organized into
folders and files some files are
included in the required code files that
may be required for other complex
projects
these files can be deleted whenever it
is convenient for you
the next feature is improving code that
states that some core snippets can be
declared in a slightly different way
which may aid the user in the code this
function prompts the user to change it
and suggested option whenever necessary
the ninth feature is the github support
git support says that the resource can
be retrieved from github repo online and
vice versa saving is also possible
cloning the code that is made available
on the internet is also referred to as
resource pulling this code can be
modified and saved later
the last feature of visual studio code
is commanding which is defined as a
common feature but not all languages
support it commenting on code allows the
user to recall or track the sequence he
desires
now these were the features of visual
studio code now we will head into the
next topic where we will understand why
should we consider visual studio code
we consider visual studio code for the
following reasons
the first reason is visual studio code
is lightweight the second reason is
visual studio code is considered to be
fast compared to its competitors
the fact that visual studio code is open
source is the next reason to choose
visual studio code
the fourth reason to use visual studio
code is that it is cross-platform
compatible or completely platform
independent the last reason to choose
visual studio code is that it is one of
the extensible ides next we will
understand how to install visual studio
code
the different steps involved to install
visual studio code are as follows so the
first step in installing visual studio
code is to download it
to download visual studio code navigate
to google and type download vs code for
windows
you will see the first official link
from visual studio
so here you can see different variety of
operating systems and their setup files
now we want to install visual studio
code in windows so we will select
download visual studio code for windows
now this will navigate us to the new
welcome page and you can see in the
bottom left corner visual studio code
setup file is getting downloaded now we
have successfully downloaded our setup
file and it looks something like this
the next step is to run this visual
studio code installer
now here you need to accept the license
agreements and select next
now select the destination of the
location
select next
next
and if you want to create a new desktop
icon on your windows desktop then you
can choose that
and here
make sure that this particular check box
is ticked as it has parts all by itself
now the visual studio code has been
successfully installed
and finished
now here you can choose the theme you
want
you can either go with dark high
contrast or light so i will choose dark
so the visual studio has been
successfully installed
now let's get back to the ppt
so first step was to download the visual
studio according to the package you
require based on your operating system
then selecting the environment remember
we take on a check box where it sets the
environment all by itself and the fourth
step is you can get started with your
first project
now
the next stage where we will discuss
some of the basic operations on visual
studio code so some of the basic
operations on visual studio code are
creating a new project running your
existing project selecting some lines of
code where you want to set breakpoints
for your code and also to execute an
existing project so all the basic
operations are similar to any other ides
that we use in our day-to-day life
in case you already have a project in
your file system and if you wanted to
run that particular file system you can
always choose the open option and you
can select that from the top left corner
using file and choose the destination
where your file is been located and try
to run it
now we will look into the next part of
our visual studio code with c-sharp that
is command-line palette
microsoft visual studio code can also be
accessed via keyboard
the most important key combination to
remember is ctrl shift plus p which
brings up the command line palette from
here you can access any of the visual
studio codes functionality as well as
keyboard shortcuts for the most common
operations such as restoring all
projects adding cursor or generating
breakpoints or many things
the command line palette user interface
gives you access to a variety of
commands you will see an equivalent
interactive window to run editor
commands as well
next we have debug command to start
debugging then we have edit command to
show all open editors by appearance then
we have edt active command to show
editor in active groups by most recently
used then we have adt mru to show all
open editors most recently used then we
have ext command to manage extension
then we have ext install command to
install and search extension then we
have an ext install command to install
following that we have command task to
run tasks termed as to-do list all open
terminals view command in open window
and many more commands followed by that
now the next part is to see file
encoding support in visual studio code
we can use files to set file encoding
either globally or a pre-workspace basis
by using file stock encoding settings in
user settings or workspace settings
visual studio codes file encoding
support will look something like this as
shown on my screen
the file encoding status is displayed in
the status bar which is highlighted in
blue on the encoding bar on status we
can see that the option to reopen or
save the active file with a different
encoding has been displayed on screen
which is comparable to the visual studio
code
following that we can select our
encoding type such as utf-8 utf-16 and
many more in this case we may have
selected utf-8 which is the default file
encoding support in visual studio code
we will now understand the additional
line arguments in visual studio code
after understanding the file encoding
support in visual studio code in c sharp
a few extra command line arguments are
listed below the go to command is the
first command line argument and it
states that when used in conjunction
with file line column question mark it
opens a file with specific line and
optional column position
a new line command is added which states
that rather than restoring the previous
session this command states a new vs
code session
then there is our command line which is
defined as forces the opening of a file
or folder in the most recently active
window following that in the additional
command line argument we have the file
command which states that the name of a
file can be opened if the file does not
exist it creates a new file you can
specifically create several files
the file command in the fifth and the
last command line is
line command that declares
you can specify multiple files in this
manner but
the hyphen g argument must be used
before the file
next we have the folder command to open
type the name of the folder and you can
specify multiple folders
now we will discuss the shortcuts in
visual studio code
so following are the shortcuts in visual
studio code you might want to take a
screenshot of this as this might be
helpful in your future
so the first shortcut is alt plus enter
which will show you the action list next
we have control shift v for pasting ctrl
alt enter to code reformat control space
for code completion control art space
for smart code completion ctrl enter for
force completion complete statement we
can use ctrl shift enter next we have
ctrl shift plus space or ctrl shift plus
r plus space to go to the next or
previous signature ctrl shift alt plus
number five to toggle parameter next we
have control plus shift plus f1 for
quick documentation next we have control
plus e or control plus l for insert live
template and then we have control plus e
or control plus u to surround with
template
few other commands here another
screenshot might be helpful for future
reference
now we have few other commands here
control plus shift plus alt plus the
arrow keys for the first one to move
code up you can use upper arrow key to
move the code down you can follow the
lower arrow key and similarly left and
right
next control plus w for extend selection
control plus shift plus w to shrink
selection control shift open square
brackets select contain declaration and
control plus d for duplicate current
line
and control plus shift plus j for join
lines and few more now with all those
points discussed we will dive into a use
case based on c sharp in visual studio
code
the use case will be creating a simple
calculator using c-sharp programming
language in visual studio code now let's
quickly start visual studio code and try
to execute that program so you can see
that we have already started visual
studio and we have the code exported
into the visual studio coding terminal
now we will go through the program for
better learning experience we have added
all the necessary namespaces to this
program initially we are utilizing the
system library in our project as
indicated as using system statement then
includes classes and functions such as
console class and writeline function
following that we added
system.collections.generic
which contains interfaces and classes
that define generic collections which
allows the users to create strongly
typed collections with higher type
safety and performance than non-generic
strongly typed collections
then there's the system that enables
link queries by providing various types
of classes and methods
following that we have incorporated the
system
text that contains ascii and unicode
character encodings abstract based
classes for converting blocks of
characters to form blocks of bytes and
the helper class for manipulating
and formatting string objects without
generating intermediate instance of
string and finally we have included a
system.threading.task that provides
types that simplify the work of writing
concurrent and asynchronous code after
which we have entered main class and a
print message as we are creating use
case based on the calculator
as a result we will display all the
functions that we will do in this use
case such as displaying select one for
addition two for subtraction then
multiplication and lastly division after
that we invite the user to select an
option which they execute any operation
as they desire
then using end 32 pass to convert string
to number we create a choice in variable
we have also declared three new
variables x y and z
following that we utilize switch case
and expression in case in case one we
have asked the user to enter values as x
and second as y
and then perform the addition operation
adding those two variables x and y and
the result will be stored in z
in the second case we have subtraction
and in the third case we have
multiplication and lastly we have
division
and lastly we have a default case where
if the user enters any other choice
other than the one two three four then
the message will be displayed as invalid
choice now that we have understood the
code let's quickly execute the code and
see the output
to execute the code you can choose the
run option over here
now you can see the code has been
successfully executed and now it's
asking for a choice let's provide the
option as 2 and let's enter our first
value
and now let's enter the second value
and the difference is 76
now let's close the vendor
press any key to close window and that's
done so the first topic history of c
sharp c sharp is a microsoft provided
object oriented programming language
that runs on a framework for internet
and anders eilsberg was the first person
to create it
after learning how the c programming
language was created we will look at the
introduction of c programming language
where it is used and why we should use
it
so c sharp is a microsoft provided
object-oriented language that runs on
the dotnet framework
c sharp has its roots in the c family
and is related to other popular
programming languages like java and c
plus plus
in the year 2002 the first version was
released c sharp version 8 is the most
recent version which was released in
september of the year 2019.
seycha programming language is used in
various fields including mobile
applications desktop applications web
applications web services websites games
database applications and virtual
reality now we will look at why we
should use c-sharp programming language
c is one of the most widely used
programming languages in the world it is
simple to learn and use and it has lot
of community support
c-sharp is an object-oriented
programming language that gives programs
a clean structure and reuses code
lowering development costs
because c sharp is like c c plus plus
and java it is simple for the
programmers to switch to c sharp or vice
versa
moving ahead with the fundamentals of c
sharp we will now look into the data
types in c sharp data types can be
classified based on the memory location
the first data type in sesha programming
language is value types followed by that
we have the reference data types and
finally we have the pointer data types
we will go through all these three types
in detail first we will look at the
value data types in c sharp a data type
is a value type if it can be stored as
values in its own memory space
that means this type of data types
directly store their data or value in a
variable for example you can see on my
screen we have integer variable i is
storing the value 200
so these type of data types are called
as value data types
so a few examples of value data types
are boolean byte character decimal
double enum float integer long short and
structure
next we will see the reference data
types in c sharp so a reference data
type unlike a value type does not store
its value directly instead it saves the
address where the value is kept in other
words a reference type contains a
pointer to another memory location where
the data is stored an example of
reference data type as string anime is
equal to simply learn where the string
is reference data type the following
data types are a few examples for
reference types that is strings arrays
class and delegate
last we have the pointed data type in c
sharp programming language
a simplest data type is the pointed data
type its functionality is identical to
that of a pointer in c programming
language and it is intended to store the
address of another pointer an example of
pointer which is shown on my screen is
int pointer p
we will look at the variables in c sharp
after we understood the data types in c
sharp
variables are storage containers of data
values in c sharp there are various
types of variables defined with
different keywords such as first the
integer data type or integers that store
values such as one two three or minus
one two three
next data type is the double which
stores floating point numbers with
decimal places such as 19.99 or minus
19.99 followed by that we have the
character data type which stores single
characters such as a or b
to surround character values single
quotes are used the next data type is
the string data type the string data
type stores string values such as hello
world double quotes are used to surround
the string values finally there is
boolean type data type which stores
values such as true or false now we will
look at how to declare variables in c
sharp programming language
to make variable you must first specify
its type and assign its value the syntax
for declaring variables is as follows we
have the data type which is data types
here in this case we are using integer
then we have a variable name in my case
we are having a variable with name that
is name 1 and the value we are storing
inside is x y z
so this is how exactly you try to
declare variables in c programming
language
so followed by the variables in c
programming language we will learn about
the operators in c programming language
operators are used to manipulate
variables and values there are four
types of operators in c programming
language the first one is the automatic
operators next we have the assignment
operators followed by that we have the
comparison operators and lastly we have
the logical operators
we will go through each one of these in
detail beginning with the automatic
operators
first we have the additional automatic
operator which adds values together then
there is subtraction operator takes one
value and subtracts it from another
following that we have the
multiplication operator which multiplies
two values following that we have the
division operator which divides one
value with another
next we have the modulus operator which
returns a reminder of the division
following that we have the increment and
decrement operators where increment
increases the value by 1 and decrement
decreases of value by 1. next we have
the assignment operators in the list
variables are assigned with values using
the assignment operators following are
some of the assignment operators to use
in c sharp
first we have equal to operator then we
have not equal to operator later we have
greater than next we have less than
following to the assignment operators we
have greater than or equal to finally we
have less than or equal to operators
last but not least we have logical
operators which is used to explain
operators in c programming language to
determine logic between variables or
values logical operators are being used
the first logical operator in c
programming language is an operator and
operator provides a result as true if
only both the values are true if one of
them is false then it returns false
next after and operator we have or
operator it returns a true value if
either of the values is true if both the
values are false then the result will be
false
finally we have not logical operator not
basically is the negation of whatever
the number you provide to it if you
provide a true value it gives you a
false value and if you provide a false
value it returns a true value now that
we know the fundamentals in c
programming language that is the data
types variables and operators we will
now look into the basic structure of a c
programming language
so the basic structure of a c
programming language looks something
like this
so basic structure of a sesha
programming language includes a class so
in here we have a class named by simply
learn you can also have a class name
based on your decision
next we have the main function followed
by the class later we have the void and
static data types and align string
argument and finally a print message now
that we have understood the basic
structure of a c programming language
let us see the first c programming
language so on my screen you can see a
basic c sharp programming language that
is used to print a message hello first
we'll use the system name space in c
sharp and we'll do so because we have
name spaces that we use to organize
classes and the system in a namespace
using the system imports the namespace
and you can now access the classes in
the system namespace next as the first
program we have the class keyword and
class name and then we will enter the
main function and print the message
hello
now we will see how to write commands in
c programming language commands can be
used to explain and improve the
readability of c sharp code it can also
be used to prevent the execution when
experimenting with the different codes
in c sharp there are two types of
comments the first one is the single
line command and single line commands
are
preceded by two forward slashes c sharp
ignores any text between two forward
slashes and the end of the line does not
execute it you can see this is a command
as the command and this command has been
preceded by two forward slashes this
particular statement will be ignored by
c sharp followed by single line command
we have double line or multi-line
commands in c sharp so the commands that
span multiple lines begin with forward
slash star and end with star forward
slash can be considered as multi-line
commands c will ignore any text between
these type of commands
in this example you can see this is a
multi-line command and this statement
will print hello simply learn is a
command hidden between forward slash
star and star forward slash so this is a
multi-line command
with that we have finished the
multi-line command since asia
programming language moving ahead we
will try to install the best ide for c
programming language and the tutorial
for that is linked in the description
box below please feel free to check it
out and without further ado let's get
started with the next topic that is
conditional statements in c programming
language
the programmer must specify one or more
conditions to be evaluated or tested by
the program a statement or statements to
be executed in the form of a condition
is determined to be true or optionally
or other statements to be executed if
the condition is determined to be false
the types of conditional statements in c
programming language are as follows in c
sha we start with if statement then we
have if else statement following that we
have an if else if ladder and a nested
if condition statement and finally a
switch statement we will go through all
of these conditional statements in c
sharp one after the other
we will begin with if condition
statement
in c programming language an if
statement is defined as a programming
conditional statement that is if true
performs an operation or displays
information within the statement block
and the statement for if statement is as
follows
if the condition is true only then a
block of code will be executed the flow
diagram of if statement in the
conditional statements is as shown below
first we will begin at the start and
there is a condition if the condition is
true the following statement will be
executed next
we have if else condition statement
in c sharp the if else statement is used
to perform the operations based on a
specific condition if the condition is
true the operation specified and the
block is executed otherwise the else
block is executed the syntax of if else
statement is as follows if the condition
is true the block of code is to be
executed as true otherwise if the
condition is forced the block of code to
be executed as false the flow diagram of
fl statement illustrates as follows
next after the fl statement we have the
if else if ladder
in c sharp fl statement is used to
perform operations based on specific
condition if the condition is true the
operation specified in the if block or
executed or else the else block will be
executed the following is the syntax for
f else if statement or if else if ladder
if the condition 1 is true the if block
of code will be executed otherwise if
condition 1 is false and condition 2 is
true
the else if block will be executed and
if both the conditions are false then
the else block will be executed the flow
diagram for flc statements is as follows
the next type of condition statement we
will look as the nested if statement in
c programming language a nested if
statement is defined as a conditional
programming statement that includes
another if statement inside the previous
if statement
the following is the syntax of nested if
statement if condition 1 is true the
first block of code will be executed if
condition 2 is true the second f of the
block will be executed and if both the
conditions are false then the else block
of statements will be executed the flow
diagram for the nested if statement is
as follows
finally there is switch condition
statement in c sharp programming
language the switch is defined as
programming selection statement that
checks for a possible match to provided
condition against the available cases if
none of the cases match the control will
run the default statement of the block
the syntax of switch statement is as
follows first we have an expression
after the switch keyword then we have
the following cases if a case matches
expression the code will be executed if
case b matches the expression case b's
code will be executed and so on if none
of the cases match the expression then
the default block code will be executed
here is a flow diagram of switch
conditional statement that shows how it
works in detail so followed by the
conditional statements in c sharp we
have the loops in c sharp in c sharp the
loop control statement performs a
looping operation until the given
condition is met when the condition is
false the controls are removed from the
loop statements there are three
different types of loops in c
programming language as listed below the
first loop is for loop next we have
while loop and lastly we have do while
loop
the syntax for for loop is as follows
three statements in parenthesis after
the keyword for
statement 1 is executed once before the
code block is executed statement 2
specifies the condition under which the
code block will be executed
after code block has been executed
statement 3 is executed every time the
flow diagram for the for loop is as
shown below first we will begin then we
will initialize and then there is a
condition if the condition is true we
will increment our decrement accordingly
and if the condition is false we will
end the process following that we will
learn about the while loop while loop is
a repeat statement or group statements
if a given condition is true before
executing the loop body it checks the
condition the syntax for while loop is
simple because there is only one
condition which will be run until the
condition becomes false the flow diagram
for while loop is shown as below first
we will start the loop then if the
condition is true the statement will be
executed until the condition is false
now we have do while loop at the end
do while loop is an alternative to while
loop this loop will execute the code
block once before checking the condition
is true and then it will loop along with
the condition is true if the condition
is false then the loop will stop
the flow diagram for do while loop is as
follows
following that we will learn about
arrays in c programming language
a fixed size sequential collection of
elements of the same data type are
stored in an array an array
stores a collection of data but it is
often more useful to think of an array
as a collection of variables of the same
type stored in continuous memory
locations instead of declaring
individual variables like array array 1
array 2 3 4 and 99 you declare one array
variable like array and use memory
locations array of 0 array of 1 until
array of 99 to represent individual
variables an index is used to ask
specific element in an array
here we have an array array 0 is the
first element and array 99 is the last
element of the array following that we
will look into how to declare an array
in c sharp in c sharp you can declare an
array using the following syntax we
start with data type then we have square
brackets where we specify the size of
the array and finally we have the array
name
an array example is shown in the screen
where data type is integer and the array
name is array next we will look into how
to initialize array declaring an array
does not cause the array to be
initialized in memory after the array
variable has been initialized you can
assign values to it the syntax is as
follows because the array is a reference
data type you must see the new keyword
to create an array instance in the
following example we have an array
called numbers with the data type end
which we initialize with the keyword new
we will understand strings in c sharp
after seeing arrays in c sharp
so the string in c sharp is a string
object with the value text the text is
internally stored as a sequential
read-only collection
of character objects because there is no
null terminating character in the end of
c-sharp string it can contain any number
of embedded null characters
the syntax of string is given below
where first we have a character string
followed by a string's name
as a b c
an example of string that is simply
learn there are string functions listed
below
first we have the clone function which
returns a string reference next we have
a compare function that compares two
specific strings after that we have a
concat function that joins two strings
and stores the results in the first
string following that we have that
contains
return the value of the specified string
after that we have a copy to which the
character from the specified position
the following equals function that
determines the two string objects we
have the same value lastly we have a
trim function that trims the string
following these c sharp basics we will
learn about c sharp methods or functions
in this tutorial
a method is a collection of statements
that work together to complete a task
every c sharp the program contains at
least one class with the main method to
use methods in c sharp we must perform
first to define the method and secondly
to call the method first we will define
the methods when you define a method you
are essentially declaring the elements
that make up its structure
the syntax for defining a method is as
follows
first we have an access specifier then
we have a return type then we have a
method name lastly we have a parameter
list and finally we have the block of
code in the following example we have a
specific public access specifier and
returns types of int
we have a method with name find minimum
which finds out minimum number between
the variables a and b
following that we will learn how to call
a method you can call a method using the
name of the method the following
examples
exemplifies it we have used the same
example in defining the method so in the
main function we have called the find
min function which is assigned to the
result variable and prints minimum value
following that we will understand the
collections in c sharp
collection classes are specialized data
storage and retrieval classes stack skus
lists and hash tables are all supported
by these classes the interfaces of most
collection classes are the same
collection classes serve various
functions such as dynamically allocating
memory to elements and accessing a list
of items via an index among others
these classes construct collections of
objects which serve as foundation for
all the data types in seisha the
following are some c-sharp collection
classes
the system dot collection namespaces
most used classes are listed below to
learn more about them the link is in the
description box below
first we have arraylist classes it
represents an ordered collection of
objects that can be individually indexed
the next class is hash table it makes
use of key to gain access to the
elements in the collection following
that we have sorted list to access the
items in a list it employs both a key
and an index after that we have a stack
class it represents a collection of
objects arranged in a last in first out
order next we have q classes it
represents a collection of objects
arranged in a first in first out order
last but not the least
bit array it represents a binary
representation array with values 1 and
0. after we understand collections in c
sharp we will see e nums in c sharp an
enum is a type of class representing a
collection of constraints variables that
cannot be changed or read
use the enum keyword rather than class
or interface to create an enum and
separate the enum items with a comma in
the following example the name of enum
is direction and all four directions
which are east west north and south are
separated by comma we will now look into
the object oriented programming in
seisha oh is an abbreviation for object
oriented programming writing procedures
or methods that perform operations on
data is what procedural programming is
all about in contrast an object-oriented
programming is all about creating
objects that contain both data and
methods object oriented programming has
several advantages over procedural
programming including the following
object-oriented programming is faster
and easier to implement object oriented
programming gives the programs a clear
structure
object oriented programming aids in
keeping c sharp code dry do not repeat
yourself and makes it easier to maintain
modify and debug object oriented
programming allows for the creation of
fully reusable applications with less
code and shorter development time after
learning about oops we will learn about
the object-oriented programming
paradigms in c programming language
first we must comprehend classes and
objects
in c
everything is associated with classes
and objects and their attributes and
methods a car for example is an object
in real life the car has attributes like
size color as well as methods like start
and stop the class functions similarly
to an object function is a blueprint for
creating objects
the following is an example an object is
a car and its attributes are its size
and color and starting and stopping are
its methods
following that we will go through the
four fundamental object-oriented
programming concepts and oops in c sharp
the first concept of oops is abstraction
followed by that we have encapsulation
inheritance and finally we have
polymorphism we will learn all these
four concepts in depth
first c-sharp abstraction
abstraction processes hiding of internal
details and displaying only the main
functionality
next we have encapsulation encapsulation
in c sharp is a process of combining
data members and member functions into a
single unit after that we have c-sharp
inheritance it is a process by which one
object automatically inherits all the
properties and behaviors of its parent
object and lastly polymorphism it is
defined as
one name many forms polymorphism allows
a class to have multiple implementations
with same name
next we have access modifiers or access
specifiers in c sharp in c sharp access
modifiers specify the scope of
accessibility
of a class member or a type of class
itself the first access specifier is
public indicating that the code is
accessible to all classes the following
access specifier is private meaning the
code can be only accessed within the
same class following that the protected
access specifier the code is accessible
within the same class or a class
inherited from that class finally there
is an internal access specifier which
means that the code is only accessible
within its assembly and cannot be
accessed from another assembly following
that we will learn about the file
operations in c
the file mode enumerator defines various
file opening methods the following
members of file mode and numerations are
described first there is append function
text is appended to an end of an already
existing file the following functions is
the copy function where duplicates the
file the third function is the creation
function which is used to create or
replace a file following that we have
the delete function which deletes a file
the fifth function is the exist function
which determines whether or not a file
exists
following that we have read all text
function this function reads the file
contents after that we have replace
function it replaces one file's contents
with contents of another finally write
alt text creates a file and writes its
contents into it so following the file
handling in c sharp we have the
exception handling in c sharp
exception handling is a phrase that
deals with handling errors and
exceptions that occur during runtime due
to coding errors or invalid user input
in c programming language we use four
keywords in exception handling we'll
start with try exception handling the
try statement lets you define a section
of code that will be checked for errors
as it runs the cache statement is used
for exception handling if an error
occurs in the try block it allows you to
define a block of code that will be
executed following that we have finally
exception handling the final statement
allows you to run code after the try
statement regardless of the outcome of
catch finally there is throw exception
handling you can define your error using
the throw statement finally in this
video we will learn about the new
features of c sharp programming language
so some of the important new features of
c programming language includes the
following interface methods by default
types of nullable references
enhancements to pattern matching
asynchronous streams making use of
declarations
interpolated verbant team string
enhancement assignment of null coalition
local static functions indices and their
ranges types of unmanaged construction
in nested expressions use the read-only
member stackable
now let's get started with what is
complexity
complexity is a measure of how the
resources
in this example time fluctuate
as the problem grows in size
an algorithm may run quickly and show no
time difference but when the input size
rises the program
may take longer to execute it may become
sluggish and perform poorly
next up let's discuss the big o notation
in theoretical terms bigger notation is
used to examine performance or
complexity of an algorithm
bigger notations examine an algorithm's
upper bound of performance that is its
worst case behavior
bigger notation also considers algorithm
asymptotic behavior
which refers to the
methods performance when the amount of
the input declines to extreme big
computational complexity asymptote
big o of f measures
the order of employed resources based on
the magnitude of the input data that is
cpu time ram etc
as you can see in the graph here is line
graph to represent various complexities
we started with constant complexity to
logarithmic
linear
square
and analog in complexities
now let's have a look at the various
complexities
first of
constant time complexity
if the method time does not vary and
remain
constant as the input size increases the
algorithm is said to have bigger of one
complexity
the algorithm is not affected by the
size of the input
it takes a fixed number of steps to
complete a particular operation and this
number is independent of the quantity of
the input data
as you can see in this code each
statement represents one
so when you count all of them it gives
us constant amount of four or one
let's go to code editor and try this
very good
let's make a
function static
void
constit
complexity
in this i will have and
a is equals to
100
and
d is equals to
50
then i will have another end
sum
is equals to
a
plus
b
then i will have
write
console
dot
write line
and then i will print out sub
now let's go to the main program
and call this function
so
turns complex
this is
let's save it and run it
as you can see it is printing 150 which
is sum of a and b
now let's get back to our slides
next up log n complexity
a method with complexity of big o of for
input size n where n is really big
divides the issue into little bits for
each iteration login
it takes login steps to execute a
particular operation on n items
where the base of the logarithm is
usually 2
because the base of the logarithm is not
critical
to the order of the operation count it
is frequently ignored
to explain this further
typically a binary search function has a
figure of login complexity
we can try this
function in a code editor
let's start with function creation
so static
and
research
its argument as end
it braces
space
ar
comma
and
x
then in the definition i will have
end
l is equals to 0
and r is equals to
length of the array
minus
one
now
we will write a while loop
l
is less than equals to r
we will have end
m
is equals to
l
plus
in braces r minus 1
r minus l
divided by 2.
this amp is a pivot
now we will check if x is present at the
mid
so to do that we will have
f
embraces
arr embraces m
is equals to
x
we have returned
m
this will only return m
if it is at mid
now let's say if x is greater than then
we should ignore the left half
so if
ar
record
m
is less than x
then
l
will be equals to m plus
1
now
here we have we have increased our lower
bound to mid plus 1
so that it the scope will shift from the
left hand side of the mid to the right
hand side
now let's say if x is smaller then we
should ignore the right half
so we can write it as
else
because that's the only other
possibility of the left
counter side
so now we will have
r
equals to m minus 1
now we have decreased our upper bound
from
whole air array length
minus 1 to mid minus 1.
now let's say if we reach here then the
element was not present
then
we will be returning
-1
this while loop will
loop around this code until it finds the
element if it doesn't find it then this
will return -1
now let's write the main block
let's define an array
and
arr
is equals to
2 comma 3 comma 5 comma 7 comma 11
comma 30
let's have another variable and n
which will store
the length of the array
then
end x
is equals to
7
this will be the number which we have to
find
so now
ent
res
is equals to
b search
a
rr comma
x
now
if
res
is equals to
minus 1
that is we didn't form
the element
so it will print
console
dot
write line
element
not
now let's say we found it
then else
we will have console
dot write line
element
found
at
plus
index
plus
res
let's save it and run it
as you can see it found the element at
index 3
since our element was 7 so it should be
at 0 1 2 and the 3.
now let's get back to our slides
next up is linear complexity
when an algorithm executes n steps for
an input of size n
where n is a very large number
then the time consumed by the process
changes linearly as the input size rises
the algorithm is set to have a bigger
off and complexity
to execute an operation on n items it
takes about the same number of steps as
the number of elements
linear complexity denotes a relationship
between the number of components and the
number of steps
here is a simple program
where we are using a simple forage
for each to represent a loop
a typical loop will have an end
complexity or a linear time complexity
let's try it in a coordinator
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's start
with the string
places
which is equals to
ingress
and calorie raises
first element
as
i
comma
soup
come up
sandwich
pizza
hold on
now
let's write before each
code
where in argument i will write trend
i
in food
and then we will write console
dot
right
line
then
i
let's save it
and run it
it should print out each and every
element and as you can see it is renting
out by soup sandwich pizza
and juice
let's get back to ourselves
next up we have n log n complexity
an algorithm with a complexity of big o
of input size n where n is a really big
number
it divides the problem into little
chunks for each invocation
then takes each of the smallest bit and
stitches them back together for n log n
complexity
to execute a given operation on n items
it takes and login steps
typically a quick sort algorithm shows
the
properties of big o of n login
complexity
let's write up a code to explain
quicksort
let's start with a simple
function static
public
and
partition
where arguments will be
end
arr
comma
and
left
comma
and
write
then we will define
a variable and
pivot
then this pivot
will have
array
at left
then while
it's true
i will have another while loop
array
at left
is less than
pivot
then we will have
left
plus plus
in case
while
arr
at right
is greater than pivot
and we will have right
minus minus
now if
left
is less than right
then
end
temp
will have
arr
at right
arr
right
will have value
of
arr at left
and
arr
left
will have the value
tap
basically we are only switching these
values
else
we will return
[Music]
right
then we will have
another function
static
public
void
that is quick sort
with the argument as
and places
arr
[Music]
comma
and
left
comma
and
right
i will have and pivot
then f
left
less than right
then
we will have
pivot
is equals to
partition
with
err
comma left
comma
right as argument
now if
[Music]
pivot
is greater than one
then
we will call quick sort
with
arr comma
left
comma
pivot
minus 1.
or
if
pivot
plus one
is less than right
then
we will call quick sort
where the argument has
the same array
comma
pivot
plus one
comma
right
now let's come back to our main block
let's start
with writing
and
an array
equals to
let's take values as 56
hundred
thirty-two
six
and 9.
then let's have another variables as n n
equals to 10
comma
i
then we will have console
dot write line
and print
quick sort
then a console line
dot write lines
let's print the initial error
initial
array
[Music]
so for that we will write a whole loop
i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
so console
dot guidelines
arr
at ith location
plus
a space
then
let's use quick sort
for
array
zeroth location
to
ninth
this will sort the array
so now console
dot right line
sorted error
another holder
with
i is equals to 0
to i less than n
to
i
plus plus
then we have our console
dot right
array
at i
plus
space
let's save it
and run it
as you can see it is first printing the
initial array then it is sorting the
array
now let's get back to our slides
next up is quadratic complexity
a method for input size n where n is a
very large number
executes almost double
r n squared the steps
and the algorithms time changes
the complexity of method is stated to
rise quadratically as the input size
increases from n square
for a particular operation it takes the
order of n square steps where n is the
size of the input
when the number of steps is proportional
to the amount of input data then we get
a quadratic complexity
here is a simple program of a nested
loops
which in turns gives us the n square
complexity
let's try this in a code editor
let's start with the nested loops
so for loop
and
i is equals to zero
i less than four
[Music]
i plus plus
then we have another nested for loop
order
and
j
is equals to 1
then j
is less than
i
the j plus plus
basically this is letting us to run this
loop only three times
so
let's have a console
write line
let's write subscribe
to
simply
let's save it and run it
let me clear the logs
as you can see it is printing it three
times
let's get back to our slides with a
variable is
a variable is simply the name provided
to a storage location that our programs
can access
in c programming each variable has a
type that governs the size and layout of
the variable's memory the range of
values that can be stored inside that
memory and a set of operations that can
be applied to that variable
each variable data type must match the
data type of the value stored in that
variable
when we declare a variable the system
reserves a piece of memory equal to the
variable size
now let's have a look at the type of
variables
there are two types of variables in c
sharp
first primitive type variables and
reference or object variables
in this session we will focus on
primitive variables and we will only
discuss strings from the object-based
variables
now let's discuss them in detail
first up primitive types
the data types which are built in the
main function are called primitive data
type
limited data types can be further
divided into numbers and truth values
the numbers are then divided into signed
and unsigned data type
let's have a look at them in detail
first up signed data type
we have tabulated the characteristics to
differentiate them we will start with
signed byte its value range tangles
between -128 to 127
then we have short
this one has a lot of memory space
and its value range is from minus 32 k
to positive 32 k
after this we have an int or integer
data type it is the most utilized data
type in any programming language
its value goes from -2 billion to
positive 2 billion
at last we have long data type
this can store an incredibly large value
variable
now let's have a look at unsigned data
type unsigned data type can only store
positive values
we will start with a byte its value
range tangled between 0 to 255
then we have unsigned
short or u short this one has a lot of
memory space then byte
and its value range is from 0 to 65
grand
after this we have u end or unsigned
integer data type
its value goes from 0 to 4 billion
at last we have u long or unside long
data type
this can store an incredibly large value
variable
and these were the integer base private
data types
now let's take a look at floating point
types
there are three types of floating point
type variables
float double and decimal
now floating points type are
after a point just an approximate value
now they are differentiated based on the
precision digits
now these switching points may differ
based on how big or small a value is now
let's discuss a few more types of data
type
first up care
this one store characteristics which are
in theory unicodes essentially a number
next up boolean this variable stores
truth
and false values
these are usually used in conditional
statements
next up is an honorary primitive type
which is string usually a string is not
considered a permitted type but in c
sharp it is not the case
string can contain a word or a sentence
now let's try these variables in a code
editor
let's start with signed integer types
first up s byte
let this variable be sb
and equals to negative 120.
next up short
as
is equals to
30 000.
and
i
should be equals to
let's take a big number so
around
2 billion
next up
we have
long
l
equals to let's take
a bigger number than the two billion
now let's try to print them
so we can use console
dot
write line
sb
and then
s
then we have i
then we have l
let's save them
and
print it
as you can see it is printing -120 for
the s byte
and 30 000 for short 2 billion for
integer and a big number for long
now
let's try some different types of
integers
let's use unsigned integers
inside integer
types
now we will have
byte a
b
is equals to
122
then we will have
u short
us
is equals to
let's say
60123
next we have cue it
ui is equals to
since we can go
up to 4 billion
so
let's take 400 million
then we have
u long
url
is equals to
we can give it
a big number
now let's try and print them
we can copy these
and change the variable names
this is b
this is us
this is ui
this is your
and let's save them
let's comment them as well
to avoid confusion
now let's save and run them again
as you can see now they are printing the
byte
u short un
and u long
now
let's comment everything
now let's discuss the floating point
types
let's start with the float
let's take value as 12.7
now you have to remember when defining a
float we need to give f as its
at last character in its value
then we have double
d
is equals to
let's say 23.67
then we have decimal
dm is equals to
99.1079
now this also should end with an m
now let's try to print them
this one should be f
the next one should be d
then dn
let's save them and run them again
now as you can see it is printing the
float value without enough
then a double value then a decimal value
without them
now
let's try
the boolean character and string values
let's start within care
care c
is equals to
t
another a boolean
flag
let's give it value as true
let's also have a string
str is equals to
welcome
to
simply load
now let's try to print them
this time
let's change the variable to c
then
flag
then we have sdr
now let's save them
and run them again
now as you can notice that for the
character it is printing the same as it
is character
then the flag is it is printing true
and for the string it is printing
welcome to simpler
we can also change the flag
from true to false by just adding an
exclamation point behind the number so
let's save
and run it
and now you can see it is toggling
between false
types of operators
there are five types of operators
in c sharp
first assignment operator then
arithmetic operator
relational operators
logical operators and currently
operators
now let's discuss them in detail
first up assignment operator
when assigning values to variables the
assignment operator that is equal
is used
and here is the syntax for that
next arithmetic operator
arithmetic operators are used to carry
out the arithmetic operations like
addition subtraction multiplication and
division
and here's the syntax for that
next relational operators
when comparing two operands the
relational operators are used
if the relationship is true then the
result will be true otherwise it will be
false
and here is the syntax for that
then logical operators
to perform logical operations logical
operators such as and and or are used
based on boolean expression
the logical operator returns boolean
values true and false
logical operators are used in decision
making and loops
and here is the syntax for that
at last urinary operator
the urinary operator unlike other
operators have only one operand and
here's the syntax for that
now let's discuss the operator
precedence
in an expression
with multiple operators the operators
with the highest precedence are
evaluated first
when an operand is between operators of
the same precedence then the order of
operation is determined by associativity
with the operator
now
let's try these operations
in a code editor
let's start by creating some variables
so in
x
comma y
let's try the assignment operators first
so we can
assign an operator by using equal sign
so we will assign
the 10 value to
x let's try
to print it
x equals 2
then we will
do plus
x
simultaneously we can also assign the
value of x to y by the same method
try to print y as well so console
dot write line
y is equals to
plus
y
let's run
this first save
then execute
as you can see it's getting x is equal
to 10 and when we define y is equals to
x then it is showing y is equals to 10.
now let's try to do arithmetic
operations
for that we will need another variable
called res
we will delete these operations
or rather
we will comment them out
and we will give
y equals to
5
let's try the addition operator
so res will be equals to
x
plus y
we will now try to print it
console dot right
line
so x
x
plus
y
here plus
andres
let's do the same thing
let's delete this comment to make the
make it easy
let's copy
the last two statement
and paste it
now we will change plus to minus
and multiplication
and division
now let's try to print it
first save it
and then we will print it
here
as you can see the x is equals to 10 and
y is equals to 5 so x plus 5 it is
printing 15
and x minus y is representing 5
then x multiplied by 5 that is 5 x 10 is
50 and then x divided by y that is 10
divided by 5 is 2.
now let's try relational operators
so first
we will define
a boolean variable
that will be value
1. now we will store
the value
1
is equals to
embraces
x
double equals to
y
now this text if the x is equals to y
since x and y are two different numbers
that is 10 and 5 so it will show us
false
so to print that
console
dot write line
x
greater than
x equals to
y
will return
plus
value
1.
let's try the same operation
for the cases of
greater than
and less than
let's save this
and
run it
as you can see the x is equal to equals
to 5 is returning false because 10 is
not equals to 5.
for the x greater than y
that is 10 is greater than 5 so it
returns true
and vice versa it will return false for
the less center
now
let's comment these out as well
now let's try logical operators
so we'll again define the x equals to
30
and
y is equals to
10
first we will try the or operator
let's clip this out
paste it here so that we can use this
value1 operation again
so for the or operator we will use value
1
is equals to
f x is equal to equals to y
and the or or is a vertical dash
or x
is greater than
5.
so in case of x either one of the
condition must be true then it will
return true so since x is equal to
equals to y is false which we have
already done that here
so now the x if x is greater than 5 then
it will also return true
so
to check that we will print
console dot
right line
value
1.
let's do it for the end operator as well
so
the value
let's copy paste it
this time we will remove these vertical
dashes
to
end and operator
let's save it and run it
as you can see in the first case we are
using an our operator
in which either one of them is required
to be true to get a true answer since x
is greater than 5 is a true answer so it
is giving us a true answer
but in case of the end operator
both of them needs to be true for it to
give true since x equals to equals to y
was false which we have checked in our
relational operation experiment so now
this will give us the false answer
now
let's try
and do urinary operators
let's take a different variable so end
z
equals to 10
comma
a value 2
and a boolean
that is flag
which is equals to
[Music]
true
now first try
so value
2 is equals to
plus z
now we will print this
dot
right line
plus z
is equals to
comma
plus
value
2.
let's copy paste them
and change
these values
now we will use minus
z here also
minus sand
another operation where we will use
double plus
now we will use minus
and for the last one we will use
console
dot
writeline
and we will print
the negation of flag
since flash is defined as true so this
one should show
flag as false
let's run this
as you can see it is showing the plus z
equals to 10 and minus that is equals to
negative 10
the plus z increments the value by one
the minus one and z decrement the value
by one so since plus plus z was already
11 so minus minus z just decreased it to
10.
now the flag is showing true because i
haven't used the negation symbol here so
now let's add the negation symbol and
save it and then run it back
that is understanding the concept of
procedural programming so what exactly
is procedural programming procedural
programming entails writing procedures
or methods that perform operations on
data whereas object-oriented programming
entails creating objects that contain
both data and methods and encapsulated
together in one single object or a class
now a best example for procedural
programming would be c program in
language
now let us understand what is object
oriented programming
object oriented programming is a
programming paradigm that organize
software design around classes and
objects now let's take a look at what
classes and objects mean in
object-oriented programming in c sharp
classes are blueprints used to determine
an object's properties and behaviors
and objects are real-world entities with
their fundamental properties and
behaviors now let's look at a real-world
example of classes and objects
so on my screen we have a car so this
particular car happens to be an object
so how can you define classes and
objects in c sharp using a car so here
you can see that i have a blueprint of
the same car
now blueprint is one single entity
and using this blueprint i can create n
number of cars which happens to be
objects
so here the blueprint of this car is
considered as a class and the cars
actual cars which are constructed or
built using the blueprint is called as
the object
so a class is the foundation of any
modern object-oriented programming
language in c sharp in oops languages it
is required to create a class to
represent data a class is a blueprint
for an object that contains variables
for storing data and methods or
functions for performing methods or
functions on that particular data
now that we have discussed the
fundamentals of a class and object let's
move ahead into the next concept
so each and every object that you create
will have its own variables and methods
that are used to manipulate the values
stored in the variables so here in this
particular example of car you can
consider the start drive and stop
methods which are involved in the object
functions
now let's move ahead into the next topic
that is understanding the four
fundamental principles of object
oriented programming concepts in c sharp
so basically object-oriented programming
in repeat so basically object-oriented
programming in c sharp is categorized
into four fundamental principles the
first one being encapsulation followed
by that we have inheritance next we have
abstraction and finally we have
polymorphism now let us understand each
one of these concepts in detail
so first let's get started with
encapsulation in c sharp
so at first we have encapsulation
encapsulation is the process of
combining a data member and the method
into one single unit or class
encapsulation is the process of
enclosing something in a capsule that is
having an object-related operations and
data within that particular object
now let us have an example so one of the
most tangible examples of encapsulation
is a school back our books pen and other
belongings can be stored in our school
bag
now to understand encapsulation in a
much better way let's go through a
practical example
so on my screen you can see an example
for encapsulation in this particular
example we are going to encapsulate the
methods for finding the area of the
given shape so here we are considering
the rectangle shape so in this
particular rectangle application class
you will have all the get area functions
which calculate the area of a rectangle
and also the variables length and width
so now let's execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the code has been
successfully executed and as you can see
we have provided the length and width of
this particular rectangle as 4.5 and 3.5
respectively and the area has been
calculated as 15.75
now let us go through a simple exercise
now i have calculated the area of
rectangle how about you guys calculate
the area of square
maybe a circle as well
and a triangle
please try these exercises on your own
and let us know in the comment sections
below
now let's move ahead into the next
concept of object oriented programming
with c sharp so the next topic in object
oriented programming in c sharp is
inheritance
so inheritance is a crucial concept in
c-sharp object-oriented programming
inheritance is a concept in which parent
and child classes are defined the child
class inherits the parent class methods
and properties but they can also change
the behavior of the methods if necessary
if required the child class can define
its own methods
here is a pictorial representation of
inheritance that shows a child class is
inheriting the properties from the
parent class or a derived class is
inheriting the properties of its base
class
now let's look at another example
inheritance is a mechanism by which a
child object acquires all the properties
of the parent class here you can see
that children are inheriting the
properties and behaviors of their
parents
now there are four different types of
inheritances available in sesia that is
single inheritance
multi-level inheritance
hierarchial inheritance and lastly
multiple inheritance as you can see in
single inheritance we have one base
class or the parent class and one child
class or the derived class the
properties and methods of a are been
inherited by b
in one single stage and similarly when
you come across multi-level inheritance
you have
three classes a being the parent class
and b being the child of a class and c
being the child class of both a and b
here c can inherit the properties of
both a and b classes in the third type
which is the hierarchical inheritance
multiple child classes acquire the
properties and behavior of one single
parent in the last inheritance type that
is the multiple inheritance
one child class can derive or inherit
the properties of multiple parents here
the child class d is inheriting the
properties of a b and c pairing classes
now with that let's go ahead and
understand each one of them in detail
so as discussed single inheritance is
defined as
having one base class and one derived
class
and similarly multi-level inheritance is
when one class inherits another and that
particular class is also inherited by
another parent class you can see c is
inheriting properties from b and b is
inheriting properties from a c can also
inherit properties from a as well via b
now let's understand the third one that
is the hierarchical inheritance
this is the type of inheritance in which
multiple classes are derived from single
base class when a single class feature
is required by multiple classes this
type of inheritance is used
now at last we have the multiple
inheritance
multiple inheritance occurs when one
derived class or child class accesses a
property of its multiple parent or base
classes now to understand inheritance in
a much better way let's try to execute
an example based on inheritance
now on my screen you can see an example
for inheritance
here we have a parent class that is the
vehicle so this particular class has one
method that is honking function
now the child class happens to be a
program called car and this particular
program will execute the methods which
are being derived from its parent class
that is honking
here you can see the object created
using the child class is executing the
method honked from its parent class now
let's try to execute this simple program
and see how it works
now you can see that the program got
successfully executed and it is
executing the tooth function that is
honking function
now that you have understood the
fundamentals of inheritance
this is one simple exercise for you
where you try to execute the single
inheritance
multi-level inheritance
multiple inheritance
and hierarchical inheritance
don't worry if you run into some issues
while executing the code feel free to
write us down in the comment section
below and our team of experts will be
happy to resolve all your queries if
required for learning purposes we will
also send the code we have for all these
examples and also exercises
now with that we have finished the
second part of object oriented
programming in c
now let's continue with the next one
that is the process of abstraction
so data abstraction is a process of
displaying the necessary information
abstraction is the process of showing
only essential features of an object to
the outside world while hiding the other
irrelevant information according to a
proper definition
in a nutshell abstraction is a process
of representing the essential feature
without representing the background
details
abstraction allows you to concentrate
only on what the object does rather than
how it does by providing relevant
information abstraction offers a
generalized view of your classes or
objects
now abstraction is a process of
concealing an object's working style
while understandingly displaying its
information
now to understand abstraction in a much
better way let's go through this example
where we have a coffee machine
an example of abstraction is making
coffee with a coffee machine to make
coffee you must learn how to use coffee
machine you must simply supply water and
coffee beans and turn it on and choose
the type of coffee you want you are
least bothered about how the coffee
machine is functioning to prepare your
coffee all you care about is your coffee
so that's how abstraction works in real
time now let's go through a practical
demonstration of abstraction in visual
studio using c sharp
so in this particular example on my
screen you can see abstraction method
for animal
and in this particular class you can see
that the animal sound function and
animal sleep function are defined
now in the main class you can see that
we're just calling the animal sound
function and animal sleep function
now we are least spoiled about how the
function operates we are just worried
about the operationality of these
functions
now let's try to execute the simple
program and see an output
now you can see the code got
successfully executed and here we have
called the sleep function and sound
function of an animal called
pig now with this let's go ahead into
the next and last type of object
oriented concepts in c sharp that
happens to be polymorphism
now the term polymorphism refers to the
presence of multiple forms
polymorphism is frequently expressed in
the object-oriented programming paradigm
as one interface multiple functions
polymorphism can be static or dynamic
the response to a function is determined
at compile time and static polymorphism
in dynamic polymorphism it is decided at
runtime now let us look at one real life
example of polymorphism
here you can see one single person who
performs multiple tasks at one stage he
works as an employee for a company and
another stage he is a successful parent
and at the last stage he is also
performing some shopping so here one
person acts as an employee at work
father at home and a customer at
shopping malls this can be considered as
a decent example for polymorphism
now there are two different types of
polymorphisms the first one being static
or compile time polymorphism and the
second one being dynamic or runtime
polymorphism
now let's look at these in detail
so static polymorphism is exemplified by
method overloading method or function
has the same name but different
signatures while overloading
it is also known as compile-time
polymorphism because the decision to
call which method is made at compile
time
and the second type is the runtime
polymorphism late binding is another
term for dynamic or runtime polymorphism
the method name and signature are used
as number of parameters and parameter
type must be same and may have a
different implementation
dynamic polymorphism is demonstrated by
method overloading
now let's understand polymorphism in
detail using a practical example
so on my screen you can see an example
for method overloading or compile time
polymorphism in seycha so you can see
here we have edition function
right we have addition function written
two times with the same name as well but
there is one simple difference it is in
the signature so in the first add method
we have two parameters and in the
secondary method we have three
parameters
now c will decide which add method to be
called based on the number of parameters
you pass so here in the main function
you can see we are calling the first add
method by giving only two parameters so
c sharp will decide this particular add
method to be called based on the number
of parameters passed similarly the
second one
it will decide i mean c sharp will
decide that the second add method will
be called based on three parameters that
you have passed now let's try to execute
this and see the output
now you can see the program got
successfully executed and the output of
the numbers is also displayed here
now with that let's try to execute
another example based on polymorphism
but this time let us try to execute an
example for runtime polymorphism so on
my screen you have an example for
runtime polymorphism so we have one
function for drawing and calculating the
area of all the shapes
we have three different shapes that is
circle square and rectangle
now in the main function we are calling
the drawing function and also declining
the area function
so here c sharp decides which particular
function to be called or which
particular function that belongs to a
particular shape to be called based on
the runtime data it receives so all the
three different shapes have three
different formulae and three different
datas so according to the data provided
c sharp will decide which particular
function to be called in runtime now
let's try to execute this program and
see the output
now there you go the program got
successfully executed and all the areas
of three different shapes has been
calculated here
now with that we have come to the last
part of this c-sharp oops tutorial that
is benefits of object oriented
programming in c sharp
so the first benefit of object oriented
programming in c sharp is
abstraction
so by using abstraction you can improve
the problem solving in an effective way
now the next one is inheritance so using
inheritance you have one major advantage
where you can reuse your code
followed by that you have encapsulation
so by using encapsulation you can find
troubleshooting to be easier
now the last one is polymorphism
so by using polymorphism you can add
flexibility to your code not just these
there are also much more benefits of
using object oriented programming using
c sharp so without any further ado let's
get started with what is c sharp errors
an array in c sharp is a collection of
elements of the same data type stored in
the consecutive memory location
in an object of the base type
system.array in c sharp
in c sharp the error index begins at 0
and we can only hold a fixed number of
elements in an array
now let's discuss the types of c sharp
arrays
in c sharp arrays are categorized in
three types
single dimensional array
multi-dimensional array and checked
array
let's discuss them all in detail
first up single dimensional array
much like other programming languages in
c sharp
single dimensional array is like a row
of elements
to create a single dimensional array we
use new keyword and square brackets
after a type
let's try to implement a program in the
code editor let's begin with the basic
syntax using
system
now we will create a public class
public class 1 the array
and we will initialize a main block as
public
static
hold
main
with argument as string
args
now we will create an array so end
arr
equals
new and
now we will declare the size for this
array so it will be 5.
now
let's start filling up the array spaces
so
arr
at
0th index
is equals to 10
arr
at first index
will be equals to
15
but we can also initialize the same
array using a different method
where we will initialize and declare the
array at the same time
let's try that one
so
we will start with end
with a close bracket
arr
which is equals to new
and
with size 5
and in curly braces we will add
the element so 10 comma 15
comma 13
comma 9
comma 21
we can also
write it where we can remove this size
to make it a little bit of dynamic
we can also remove the new keyword to
make it more simpler syntax
let's keep it that way
now
let's write a for loop to traverse this
array so for
and
i is equals to zero
i
less than
ar dot length
i plus plus
to print the elements of array we will
write console
dot
write line
[Music]
and in argument arr
at index i
now let's execute this program
let's save this program
and run it
as you can see it is
printing the error values
as we have written in this array
let's get back to our slides
next let's discuss multi-dimensional
array
a multi-dimensional array is again
divided into two more parts
2d array and 3d array
the data is kept in stabler form that is
row versus column
which is also known as matrix to create
a multi-dimensional array we need to use
the commas inside the square bracket
let's try and implement a program in the
correlator let's start by creating
using
system
then we will create a class public
class
has
multi d
array
then we will create a main block
so public
static
world
main
string
rose breaker
args
now we will declare this array
to end
braces and places will have comma one
comma for the 2d array
then arr
equals to
new
and
bracket 3 comma 3.
this is a mere declaration now we can
initialize this array and insert the
elements one by one using the simple
method like arr zero comma zero
or
we can write
here in curly braces
in small curly braces
one comma two comma
three
then we'll close it
and insert another curly brace
for four comma five comma six
then outside then comma
then
another call devices which will have the
value as seven comma
comma 9
or we can also remove
the size
3 comma 3 from this
or
the new keyword entirely
now let's keep it with new keyword
now let's write a program to traverse
this array
we will be needing a nested loop
so for
end
i is equals to zero
comma
i less than three
i plus plus
then nested loop
with argument as
and j is equals to zero
j less than three
and j plus plus
we will write console
start
right
line
arr
at i comma j
plus
we will add an inverted comma with a
space in it
then we will come out with the internal
for loop
and we will call
console dot write line
and we will not add anything in the
argument
so that it will just change the line
to make a new row
now execute this
as you can see
this function is showing each and every
element
of this array
now let's get back to our slides
next let's discuss jagged array
c sharps a jagged array is referred to
as an array of arrays
since each of its elements is an
individual array exact arrays element
might be of various sizes
now let's try to implement a program in
the code editor to get to know it more
better
let's start with a standard syntax
using system
then we will create a public class
public
class
chat
array
then
we will create a main block so public
static
void
main
with argument as string
close braces
arcs
now here
we will declare the array
as end
braces
turn another braces
space
arr
equals to
new
and
two
and then empty braces here this two
defines as the row
which means how many arrays will there
be as an element
and the second one is left empty so that
the arrays can vary
now let's initialize these arrays
so arr
at zeroth index
is equals to
new
and
6
then we will insert the elements as 42
comma
61
comma 37
comma
41
comma 59
comma 63
next we will write the array
at
first position
is equals to
new
int
practice array d of size 4.
so 11
comma 21
comma 56
comma 78
now
let's traverse these error elements
so we will be using a nested for loop
so for loop
and i is equals to zero
comma
i less than
arr dot
length
and i plus plus
and another for loop
with argument as end
j is equals to zero
j less than
ars length
j plus plus
now we will write system
dot console
dot right
as ar
at i
and j
plus
an empty inverted comma
then we will go out of this for folder
and write system
dot
console
dot right line
to insert an empty line
now let's save this
and run this program
we have to add
array length of the first
array arr
size i
and then we will save and run it again
now it is showing the complete arrays
let's get back to our slides
we have now discussed what are arrays
and types of errors in detail
now let's look at the advantages of c
sharp array
first up
it is used to represent a large number
of data objects of the same type with a
single name
next arrays are used to implement data
structures such as linked lists trees
graphs stacks and queues
also matrices are
represented by two dimensional arrays in
c sharp
finally since arrays are highly typed
and there is no boxing and unboxing
so it improves the application's
performance
and these were the advantages of c-sharp
arrays
now let's discuss the disadvantages of
c-sharp array
first up
the arrays has fixed size as a result we
must declare the array size ahead of
time
next up if we allocate more memory than
it is required then the additional
memory will be wasted
next up an array element can never be
inserted in the middle
and it is also not possible to delete or
remove elements from aries middle
during the course of this video we have
discussed c sharp arrays and its type
along with its advantages and
disadvantages
now let's conclude this video with a
brief summary on c-sharp arrays
first up in c-sharp arrays
code optimization is an easy task
next up using c-sharp arrays you can
easily traverse data
next up c-sharp arrays can make it
simpler to manipulate data
next sorting data with c-sharp arrays is
as simple as breeze
finally declaring an array may result in
memory wastage or a case of insufficient
memory because arrays have a fixed size
our conditional statements
conditional statements in c sharp are
used when we wish to perform certain
actions based on a given condition
decision making statements necessitate
a few conditions that the program may
assess
and a set of statement that can be
performed
if the condition evaluates as true
or another statement that can be run if
the statement evaluates as false
conditional refers to a program capacity
to infer and do various actions based on
the conditions of the codes written in
that program
next up let's discuss the types of
conditional statement
conditional statements are categorized
into two types
conditional branching and conditional
looping
let's have a in-depth discussion on
conditional branching
there are two ways to accommodate
conditional branching
if-else statement and switch case
statements
let's discuss if-else statements first
the if statement is made up of a boolean
expression followed by a statement
the statement inside the if condition is
executed only if the boolean expression
returns true
if it returns false then the program
will simply execute the else statement
if it is available
as you can see in this flowchart
let's try a code to demonstrate if else
statement
let's start with degree layering
and
x comma y
then
console
dot write line
in this we will print
enter
to
number
now
let's get a user input
so x
is equal to end
dot
parse
and we will have console
dot redline
this will request the x
input
let's copy paste
repeat
let's copy paste the same
function
but this time for y
now let's write an fl statement so if
x
is greater than y
then in that case
we will print
console.writeline that x
is
greater
than
y
let's go for another condition else
then if
we have x
is less than y
now in this case
we will be printing
that y is
greater than
x
now let's say
they are equal
since we have already covered
the greater than part and the less than
part so only condition left is equals so
we don't have to mention another if
statement for x equals to y so we will
just write else
and print
console
dot write line
both
are equal
let's save it
and execute
let's enter value as
7
and
5
here it is printing x is greater than y
let's try equal
function as well
let's give it value as three
and three
and it is printing both are equal
let's get back to our slides
next let's discuss switch case statement
in this scenario we have been given
number of cases and a default case
in each case
is numbered starting from 1 to the n
except for the default case
in the beginning we are prompted to
choose a number
whatever number we pick then program
will execute the same numbered case
in case if there is no case with the
chosen number it will execute the
default case
let's try this statement in a code
editor
let's start with defining integer x
then we will define a function
that is public
void
get data
here
we will
write a console.write writeline
and we will choose
as
choose
the
following
color then we will have x
is equals to
end
dot parse
console
dot
red
line
now
let's have a switch
statement
so we have switch
with argument as x
we will have first case
console
dot
write line
and we will print
you
choose
red
break
then we can have another case
two
and we will have
same kind of statements
so console
dot write line
you choose
blue
then a break statement
these break statements basically
will loop you out of this switch case
so
let's say case three
and we have another console case
right line
and this time
you choose
yellow
and
break statement
to get them out of here
now there can be a case where
we have to define a default case
when we choose a number other than one
two three
so
the default
will have
console
dot
right line
and it will by default choose
fight
and then
we will also use break for this one as
well
now let's write the function for the
main block
here
we will define an object
for the switch
case
so for program
obj
is equals to
new
program
then
we can have obj
dot
get data
and
we can have
last line as console
dot
read line
let's save it
and execute it
as you can see it's asking us to enter a
number
let's enter one
and it's printing you choose red
let's enter
let's execute again
this time let's answer
a number which is not in the our cases
let's say use 5
and it will automatically choose us
white
let's get back to our slides
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now we have successfully defined the
conditional branching statements
now let's discuss conditional looping
there are four methods to accommodate
conditional looping first up
for loop
while loop
do while loop
and four each loop
let's discuss them in detail
first up for loop
the condition of the for loop includes
the condition setup and change inside
the syntax as well
we will first check the condition like
if we are at the last item
if it is deemed false then we will keep
this loop going otherwise we will end
the loop
let's try a code
let's start
with an console right line
here we will print
a statement as square
of
1 2
10
let's write a for loop to do that
we can have end
i is equals to 1
then i less than equals to
10
then
i
plus plus
then we will have console
dot right line
and then we will have i star i
as its argument
let's try
as you can see it is printing
the squares from 1
to
100
let's get back to our slides next we
have is a while loop
in this scenario the while loop will
validate a condition
then it will execute the code block as
long as that while condition is true
and the loop will keep executing unless
the condition becomes false
let's try a code
to understand this thoroughly
let's start
we'll first have
an integer x
then
we will
write function
which is public
void
while
demo
then
we will have
a while loop inside
with an argument condition as x less
than equals to
50
let's decrease that to 10.
then console
dot
write line
and this will print x
it will keep on printing x
until
x becomes
greater than 10.
to do that the x plus plus will
increment its value after each loop
then let's go to our main block
here
we will
call by
loop
then obj
equals to
while
loop
new keyboard
now let's use this newly created object
to call
wild demon
let's save it
and execute it
and here you can see it is printing with
value from 0 to all the way up to 10
then the while loop
was
dismissed because it existed the while
condition
let's get back to our slides
next we have do while loop
in this scenario it will first run the
do code block
then the while loop will validate a
condition
and then if that condition is true it
will execute the do block as long as the
while condition remains true this loop
will keep executing unless the while
condition becomes false
let's go to a code editor and try a code
let's start with an end
x
then we will have
a function
that is public
world
too while
demo
here
we will write
a do command
and the trend
console
dot write line
x
and x
plus plus
then we have a while condition
within condition as x
should be less than equals to
10.
let's say in a case the x was 11
then also the do function will first
execute it
basically in this do while loop
if
our x was already greater than 10 since
our condition that x should be remain
less than 10.
this do block will still run
for the first time
because it did not encounter this while
condition yet
so after running it once it will print
11
then it will encounter this while
condition
and since the while condition will come
out to be false this dual loop will be
terminated
let's write the main block
so do i know
object is equals to
new
do i loop
then we will use object
dual demo
call it
let's save this and run it
as you can see it is again printing from
0
to 10.
let's get back to our slides
finally we have four each loop
when a program wants to iterate through
a contents of a list
it uses a for each loop
it can be applied to a collection such
as array list or arrays
let's write a code to understand it
better
let's start with the main block
and write
string
bracket
closed
which is equals to
let's have arguments
as die
comma
we can have shirt
we can have code
we can have bands
we can have
shorts
now let's write a 4 each loop
so
for each loop
we will have
string
i
in
clothes
then we will have a console
dot right line
and it will print i
let's save it
so according to the for each loop it
will run this i in this cloth
which is a string so basically it will
print these all elements one by one
through this loop
and here as you can see it is printing
tie shirt coat pens and shorts
one by one programming frequently
necessitates the repeated execution of a
sequence of operations a loop is a basic
programming construct that allows the
execution of a piece of software code to
be repeated depending on the loop's type
its code is repeated a set of number of
times or until a certain time is reached
the condition is correct
next we will look at the various types
of loops in c sharp
first we will look at while loop then we
will have do while loop after that we
have for loop following that we have for
each loop in c sharp then we have nested
loops after that then break and continue
and finally we will have switch
statements in c sharp
we will look at these different types of
c sharp loops in depth including an
introduction syntax flowchart diagram
and code example first we will look at
the while loop while the condition is
any expression that returns a boolean
result true or false and one is the
simplest and most used loops is known as
the loop condition because it determines
how long the loop body will be repeated
the loop body in this example is the
programming code executed at each
iteration of the loop that is whenever
the input is true here is the syntax of
a while loop we have the keyword while
we have the condition we have the code
body inside the brackets
the while loop flow diagram is shown
below now let's look at how a while loop
works
in the while loop the boolean expression
is first calculated and if it's true the
sequence of operations in the loop body
are executed the input condition is then
checked again and if it's true the loop
body is executed once more all of this
is repeated until the conditional
expression returns false at some point
at this point the loop is terminated and
the program proceeds to the next line
immediately following the loop's body
if the cycle condition returns false at
start the body of the while loop may not
be executed even once if the cycle's
condition is never broken the loop will
continue indefinitely
let's look at a simple example of why
loop in action the loop's purpose is to
print the numbers 1 through 15 in
ascending order on the console
let's put the program to test and see
how it performs
in this program we have a constructor
variable called i and we initialize it
to 1 and execute the loop body while the
loop condition is true after that we run
our while loop up to 15 times
and then we print that counter variable
and increment by one at the same time
now let's quickly execute the program
and save the output
there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
the output right on my screen
next we will look at the do while loop
and try to understand it the do while
loop is like a while loop but it checks
the condition after each loop body
execution
this loop type is also known as loop
with the condition at the end or post
test loop
a do while loop appears as follows here
is the syntax
in the do while syntax we have the
keyword do first then the code body to
execute and finally the condition
following the while keyword
here is the flow diagram of do while
loop let us see how do while flow
diagram works the loop body is executed
first and its condition is evaluated
later if it is true the loop's body is
repeated otherwise it is terminated this
logic is repeated until the loop's
condition is broken
the loop's body is executed at least
once if the loop's condition is always
true the loop will never end
let's look at an example of do while
loop
in this example we will calculate the
factorial of given number x again but
instead of an infinite while loop we
will use a do while loop
let's put this program to test and see
how it performs
in this program we have a number x we
have to find the factorial of this
number we initialize the factorial
number as 1 and then a loop to perform
the factorial of the given number and
decrease the number by 1 simultaneously
after we have determined the variable x
must be greater than 0 we will compare
the factorial to the given number of the
value x
now let's execute this program and say
the output there you go the program got
successfully executed and now it is
asking for the value of x let us provide
5 instead of 1.
the factorial of 5 is 120 so that's how
the factorial and the do-while loop
executes
now let's look at the next type of loop
the next type of loop is the for loop
while the functionality of a for loop is
like that of a while loop the syntax is
a little different when loop statements
are to be executed are known ahead of
the time for loops are preferred the
loop variable initialization condition
to be tested and increment or decrement
of the loop variable are all done in one
line in the for loop resulting in a
shorter easier to debug looping
structure
the following is the scheme that
describes for loops the syntax is given
below in this loop syntax we have the
loop initialization test condition
increment or decrement and statements to
be executed
let's go over the syntax of for loops
the variable controlling the loop is
initialized here which defines variable
loop execution it's the starting point
of a for loop a previously declared
variable can be used or a new variable
that is only local to the loop can be
declared
and then we have a testing loop the
testing condition asserts the
circumstance in which loop statements
are executed it is used to test the exit
condition of the loop it must either
return true or false when the condition
is false the control is removed from the
loop and program is terminated and
finally we have increments or decrements
as well as the loop variable is
incremented or decremented as needed and
the control is returned to the testing
condition let us look at how the flow
diagram of for loop works
first the initialization statement is
executed typically the variable is
declared and initialized here this
variable is a count of lag because it
controls the number of iterations the
for loop will perform
the following steps in evaluating the
for condition the condition is a boolean
expression which returns true or false
the statements or programs within the
for loop are executed if the condition
is true these iterations are repeated
until the condition is determined to be
false
when the condition evaluates to be false
the flow shifts from the inside to the
outside of the loop
let's look at the example let's look at
an example we will write a program that
raises the number a to power of b and we
will use a for loop to accomplish this
in this example we have two variables a
and b with a base number and b as
exponent next we ask the user to enter
the value for a and b and we run the
loop for 0 to exponent b then we perform
how can we calculate the power of a rise
to b and finally we will display the
power of given numbers
let's execute the program and see the
output
there you go the program was
successfully executed now it's asking to
enter a number let's enter 2
let's enter another number that is power
let's enter it as 2 to the power 3 there
you go the answer is eight
that's how the for loop works
now following that we have for each loop
let's try to figure out what is for each
loop
for each loop and c sharp iterates
through a collection of items an array
or a list when each loop is executed it
executes a block of code on a collection
of items passing through the items in
the collection and finally displaying
them one by one the syntax for for each
loop is as follows we have the for each
keyword then we have type of variable in
collection then we have a code for
execution that resides inside the braces
the flow diagram of forage loop is shown
below let's look at how the flow diagram
of for each loop works the forage loop
iterates through the elements in a
collection when using a for each loop it
is mandatory to enclose statements in
curly places
when declaring a lower counter variable
we can use same type of as array based
type let's look at an example for for
each loop
in this example we create an array of
numbers which is then looped through and
elements are printed on the console then
the array of town names strings is
created and proceeds in the same way
with elements printed in the console as
a result of the example let's get back
to the practical mode and execute a
practical one in this program we have an
array as the number we have numbered as
2 4 6 8 10 12 14 and 16 then we have for
each loop while we run for an array of
numbers with counter variable i then we
have the town name as london paris usa
and new york again we have for each loop
we have while for running town names and
finally we will print both arrays and
string let's quickly execute the program
and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have our
outputs on our screens
following that we have our next c-sharp
loop that is nested loop let's try and
understand nested loops in c sharp
nested loops are programming constructs
made up of several nested loops within
each other the innermost loop is
executed more frequently while the auto
most is executed less frequently let's
look at two nested loops the syntax of a
nested for loop is same as that of a for
loop with two for loops with the same
variable initialization testing
condition and increment or decrement
here is the flow diagram of nested for
loops and we will now see how it works
following the initialization of first
follow the execution of its body which
contains the second nested loop we will
begin
its variable will be initialized its
condition will be checked and the code
execution within the body is executed
following by the variable being updated
and execution containing until the
condition is false following that the
second iteration of the first for loop
will continue its variable will be
updated and the entire second loop will
be repeated the inner loop will be
executed as many times as the outer loop
body is true here is an example of
printing the triangle shape of a given
number x to triangle with x lines on the
console app using for each loop
now let's get back to the practical mode
in this program we attempted to create a
right angle triangle with an asterisk
and height of 5. we have value 5 because
we will make a triangle
up to 5. we have two variables that will
handle row and column and finally we
will have k for height so the first for
loop is running for row and the second
for loop is running for column then we
have another loop that will run up to 5
that is the height of the triangle
finally we will print the hash trick to
create a right angle shaped triangle
now let's quickly execute the program
and see the output
so there you go we have a right angle
triangle made up of hash tricks
after the nested loop we have the
continue and break statements we will
see what the continued statement is
continue as one of many conditional
statements in c programming language
that can be used inside a conditional
loop block to function as a clause to
continue the loop execution after the
iterative condition is executed to move
on to the next execution of the next
iteration in the conditional loop it is
commonly used with iterative conditional
loops such as four while loop or do
while loop and for each loop let's look
at the flow diagram of the continue
statement and to see how it works
when the loop begins if there is a
continue statement it will stop at the
current iteration and pass control to
the next iteration by returning to the
loop beginning we will look at
using the continue operator in the
following example using the for loop we
will compute the sum of all odd integers
in the range 1 to x that is not
divisible by 9.
now let's execute the example for
continue followed by that we will go
ahead with break
so there you go the program has executed
and you have the output on my screen now
let's continue with the break
first we set the variable of loop to 1
because it is the first odd integer in
the range 1 to x after each loop
iteration we check to see if we have yet
exceeded n i is equals to x
in the expression for updating the
variable we multiply it by 2 to ensure
that it only passes through odd numbers
we check whether the current number is
divisible by 9 within the loop body if
this is the case we use the continue
operator which escapes the rest of the
loop's body adding the current number to
the sum if the number is not divisible
by 9 the sum is updated to the current
number after that we will have a break
statement let's go over what it is the
break statement is used at the end of
the for loop and that is present in if
it is present the control will be passed
to the statements that flow the big
statement if the break statement is
present in the nested loop it only
terminates the loop that contains the
break statement the syntax is as follows
it is very simple because we only need
to write break keyword following that we
have the flow diagram of the break
keyword and we will try to understand
how it works it checks for the specific
condition at the start of the flow if it
is satisfied the loop is continued at
the point where the loop gets break
statement or the condition where it gets
out of the loop with break statement
let's see an example of using break
statement first we initialize the
variable factorial with 1 and rate x
from the console we construct an endless
while loop by using true as condition of
the loop we use the break operator to
terminate the loop when x reaches a
value less than or equal to 1. otherwise
we multiply the current result by x and
reduce x with one unit practically the
first iteration of the loop the variable
factorial has a value n in the second
that is x into x minus 1 and so on in
the last iteration of the loop the
factorial value is the product of x into
x minus 1 into x minus 2 and so on which
is the desired result of factorial x
let's quickly execute the program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have 5 into
4 into 3 into 1 which is equals to 120
finally we have the switch statement the
switch statement in c sharp is a
multi-way branch statement it provides
an efficient method for transferring
execution to different parts of a code
based on the expression value the switch
expression is an integer type end care
byte short enumeration or string type
the expression is checked for various
causes and only one which matches is
executed here the syntax of switch
statement where the switch keyword
follows an expression then we have
different cases starting with case 1 and
go on up to case n then we have break
keyword and finally with the default
case which generally has default set of
sequences here in this statement flow
diagram and let us try to understand how
it works
with a switch statement and expression
is passed equally to one of the case
values if the value is not equal the
default case is used this expression
value is then compared to the case
identifier or the first case if the
first case matches the code associated
with that case is executed when you
reach break the execution will halt and
exit the switch statement if the case
does not match the execution moves on to
the next case if the case matches the
second code block is executed otherwise
the flow proceeds to the next case in
the same manner finally the default code
block is executed if no case matches
let's see an example of switch case the
user is asked to enter an alphabet in
this example if the alphabet is in
uppercase it is converted to lowercase
using the to lower method now we are on
the practical mode and that's the code
on my screen the switch statement checks
to see if the alphabet entered by you as
any of the given that is a eiou
if you have the cases matched then the
given character is a vowel then it is
printed as output otherwise the control
returns the default block and the given
character is not available and that
message will be printed on your screen
now let's quickly execute the statement
and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed now let's enter
a e i o u any of the one of those so
i'll enter a
and there you go the given character is
a vowel and if i had entered any other
than eiou the
default message would have been printed
that is the alphabet entered as started
with what methods are
methods in program a block of code or
statements that allow the user to reuse
code conserving memory time and most
importantly increasing code readability
this is the basic syntax we first
mentioned the access modifier then
return type method name with some
parameters in the open braces and then
add the method body in the curly braces
now let's have a look at the components
or elements of methods
there are five components of methods in
c-sharp
first up access modifier
return types method name parameter list
and method body
let's discuss them in detail
we will start with the access modifier
it specifies the method success type
that is how it can be accessed in your
application
in c sharp there are three types of
access modifiers
first up public
all methods have access to the code
next private in this only the current
method will have access to this code
next up is protected
in this it is only available within the
same class or the hierarchy of that
class next step return type
the data type of a value returned by the
method is specified by the return type
the return type is void if method
returns null
in c-sharp the return type can be int
void double string
and so forth next up method name
it indicates the name of the user
defined method that the user invokes for
example factorial which is preceded by
open braces then method body it refers
to the line of code that describes the
duties that will be executed by the
method during its execution
it is kept in curly braces at last
parameter list
within the open parenthesis a comma
separated list of inputs
parameter is defined preceded by the
data type if there are no parameters
then empty parenthesis must be used
there are three types of parameters
value parameter reference parameter and
output parameter
now let's see how we can pass parameters
in methods in c sharp
c-sharp methods can be classified based
on the return type
and input argument first up method
without parameter and without return
type for example this print function
prints
the string void parameters
next up without parameters and with the
return type for example since there are
no parameter in this product function
then we will define variables inside the
method body and return the product value
then we have with parameters and no
return type for example this
circumference function
is using r parameters which then helps
us to calculate the circumference and we
will print it in that method body itself
at last the width parameters and with
return type for instance in this
factorial function we pass the integer
parameter n
then we calculate the factorial n and
then return that value
now let's implement these in the code
editor
let's get started with defining some
variables
so
we will be using
and rad
which we will give the value as 7
and
n
which we can give value as 4
and a variable get rest
now we will start with our first
function that is print function
this will be a void function that is
without any return type and without any
arguments so static void
print
and in the curly braces we will call
console
dot write line
in braces
we can type in
like
welcome
to simply
learn
now
let's try
to execute this one so
we will call the print function
now save it and let's run it
as we can see it is printing the welcome
to simply learn
ignore this
warning
it will be resolved when we will use
these variables
now let's get started with the next type
that is without return type and with
parameters so we will have
static
void circumference
and
r
here we will directly print
console
dot writeline
so circumference
plus
2
multiplied by
in closed braces we have 22
divided by 7 that is 5
then
star
r
we will close it then
we will write a function
so we will call
circumference
with the argument as drag
let's run this
as we can see it is now printing the
circumference is equals to 42.
now let's write up another function
which will have
a return type without parameters
so
we have
static
end
product
here we will define
and
as x is equals to 7
comma y is equals to
22
and rest
then res
will equal to
x
multiplied by y
then we will return
rest
now
let's store the res value in get dress
to get
res
is equals to product
then we will write up
console
dot write line
and then
get rest
let's save this and run it again
as you can see it is giving us 154 which
is 22 multiplied by 7 which the product
function should do
now
let's write up another method to
demonstrate with return type and with
parameters
so this time we will be writing up
static
and
factorial
and end
n
so end
f1
is equals to one
for
and
i
is equals to 1
i less than equals to
n
then i plus plus
f1
is equals to
f1
multiplied by
i
can return
f1
now
let's have
get res
and we will store
factorial
and
then we will call
console
dot write line
and we will print
get press let's save it
and run it
as you can see it is now printing 24 as
well which is a 4 factorial
now let's wind up this session with some
advantages of the method
the method ensures that the program is
well structured
the use of methods improves the
readability of the code
it is also an efficient approach for the
users to reuse the existing code
it also reduces the amount of time it
takes to execute
and the amount of memory it uses
of
delegates so what exactly are delegates
a delegate is an object that refers to a
method or it is a variable of the
reference type that can hold a reference
to the methods for example delegates in
c sharp are analogous to function points
in c or c plus plus it provides a method
for specifying which method should be
called when an event occurs
delegates are commonly used to implement
events and callback methods all
delegates are derived implicitly from
system.delegate class
here is a diagram that shows how
delegates work which is completely
similar to a pointer to the function for
example the caller invokes a delegate an
object that refers to a method or a
reference type variable that can hold a
reference to the methods for example if
you click a button on a form the program
will invoke a specific method in a
nutshell it is a type that represents
references to methods with a particular
parameter list and return type and then
calls the method in a program for
execution when needed for a better
learning experience here is a pictorial
representation of the given example
now we will look at some essential
aspects of delegates in c sharp
firstly delegates are a good way to
encapsulate the methods
next delegates is a library class found
in the system namespace after that
delegates can also be used to invoke
anonymous methods
following that delegates are primarily
used to implement call back methods and
events
next as two or more methods can be
called on a single event delegates can
be chained together
following that it is unconcerned about
the class of the object it refers to
finally in certain contexts anonymous
methods of c-sharp 2.0 and lambda
expressions of c-sharp 3.0 are compiled
to delegate types these features are
sometimes referred to collectively as
anonymous functions
after defining delegates we will look at
why and when to use them
programmers are frequently required to
pass a method as a parameter to other
methods delegates are created and used
for this purpose for example a delegate
is a class that contains the signature
of a method although it can be used in
any context it is frequently used as the
foundation of the c-sharp event handling
model delegates can be thought of as
giving a name to a method signature here
is an example of the delegate on my
screen namely the delegate function
the delegate can be assigned to any
method that matches the delegate's
signature including the return type and
parameters now let's look at why we need
delegates in c sharp
delegates in a nutshell are object
oriented type safe and very secure
because they ensure the signature of the
method being called is correct delegates
make event management simple and easy
after determining when and why we
require delegates in c sharp we will now
try to figure out how to declare
delegates in c sharp
there are three steps in defining and
using delegates delegate keyword is used
to create a delegate first we add the
attribute the modifier the delegate
keyword the written data type the
delegate name and finally the formal
parameter as an argument
the modifier can be any following
keywords or a suitable combination of
new public private protected or internal
any of the data types we have seen can
be used as the written type it could
also be a void data type or the same
name of the class
name parameter must be a valid c sharp
name because a delegate is a method
definition you must use the parenthesis
required for all methods leave the
parameters empty if this method will not
accept any arguments
here's an example with an access
modifier set to public and the
delegate's name is example delegate
with the int data type and
string s as a formal argument
the preceding delegate can refer to any
method that accepts a single string
parameter and returns an int variable
after we understand how to declare
delegates in c sharp now we will try to
know how to initialize and invoke
delegates in c sharp
we use the same example while declaring
the delegate to initialize and the
delegate with the keyword new as shown
on my screen we can create two objects
ex1 and ex2 that is example one and
example two next we will look at how to
invoke or call objects in delegates
we call the objects by using the
object's name followed by parenthesis
and finally a colon to end the calling
procedure let's look at a practical
demonstration of declaring and
initializing
and invoking delegates in c
sharp now we are on the practical mode
and we have started our visual studio
so you can see on my screen we have an
example this program declares a delegate
namely a calculator
this program declares a delegate namely
a calculator with a formal argument x
using system we created a delegate
example class with the access modifier
public and the static keyword the
keyword static denotes that a class has
only one instance of the member
we then declare a static variable named
value with the value 10 assigned to it
we then define a static function
addition with the same formal argument x
we calculate addition as the value equal
to the value of plus x
finally we return the result of adding
value
we then define a static function
subtraction with the same formal
argument x
then we calculate subtraction as the
value equal to value minus x then we
finally return the result of subtraction
value
similarly we define a static function
multiplication with the same formal
argument x
then we calculate the multiplication as
the value equal to value multiplied by x
and finally return the result of
multiplication value
lastly we declare another static
function by the name division with the
same formal argument x then we calculate
division as the value equal to value
divided by x and then we return the
result of the division value
later we define another function called
getvalue which displays the results of
all operations performed in the
calculator
finally we enter the main function where
we see how we initialize and invoke the
objects and delegates in practice for
example we created 4 objects
calculator 1 calculator 2 calculator 3
calculator 4 and used new keyword to
perform the 4 operations which are
addition subtraction multiplication and
division next we call all four objects
by assigning values to x such as here we
assign 20 to x to perform addition
because the value was initially assigned
with 10. so the sum will be 30 after
that we divide addition as 30. next to
perform subtraction we assign x to 3
because the value was previously
calculated as 30 so 30 minus 3 equals
27. similarly we assign 5 to perform
multiplication and finally we assign phi
to x which now has a value equal to 135
we divide 135 by 5 and get 27
so now i hope i made myself clear with
the code let's quickly try to run this
and see the output
there you go the program got
successfully executed and the results
are on the output terminal
now in this delegates in c sharp
tutorial we will look at some different
types of delegates in c sharp
in seisha there are three types of
delegates first type of delegate is a
single delegate followed by that we have
a multi-delegate
and finally we have a generic delegate
let's look at all these type of
different delegates in detail
so first let's try to figure out what a
single cast delegate is
this delegate can only refer to one
method at one time for example single
cast delegates refer to a single method
with a matching signature
the system generates single cast
delegates dot delegate let's see a code
demonstration for a single cast delegate
for better understanding
this single cast delegate program
includes the single delegate namespace
then declares delegate1 with formal
arguments a and b of integer data type
and public access modifier then we make
a class program
in which we define an addition function
calculate the addition of a and b and
display the result of the addition
function similarly we make a subtraction
function in which we calculate the
subtraction of two variables a and b and
show the resultant difference finally
where is the main function where we
rename the object of class program to
obj using the new keyword then we
created two more objects d1 and d2 d1
for addition with two values of 100 and
200 and d2 for subtraction with the same
100 and 200.
now let's quickly run the code and see
the output
now the next type of delegate is the
multicast delegate so let us attempt to
comprehend multicast delegates
this kind of delicate can refer to
multiple methods that have the same
signature at one time let us see a code
demonstration of the multicast delegate
for a better understanding this program
uses the namespace delegate and then
declares delegate as a multi-delegate
with formal arguments a and b we define
the addition and subtraction functions
in the class program which we declare
and calculate as plus p and a minus b
respectively then the main function we
create the class program object p1 then
we declare md1 and md2 objects for
addition and subtraction operations then
we assign md1 to md1 and md2
giving a value of 100 to a and a value
of 200 to b
let's try to quickly run this program
and see the output
let us now look at the third and final
type of delicate generate cache delegate
and try to understand it
generate delegate was introduced in
dotnet 3.5 and did not require the
delegate instance to be defined to
invoke the methods
there are three types of generic cache
delegate which are function delegate
action delegate and predicate delegate
now for a better understanding let us
look at the three generic delegate types
in greater detail complete with code
examples let us look at the first type
of generic delegate the function
delegate
in c sharp the function generate
delegate is found in the system
namespace this delegate accepts one or
more input parameters and returns a
single output parameter the final
parameter is regarded as the written
value in c sharp the function
genericdelegate can accept up to 16
different input parameters it must only
have one type of return
the return type is required but the
input parameter is optional
one thing to keep in mind about function
generic delegate is in c sharp you must
use the function generic delegate
whenever your delegate returns a value
whether it takes any input parameters or
not
let's look at the second type of generic
delegate that is the action generic
delegate and try to understand it
in c sharp the action generate delegate
can also be found in system namespace it
accepts one or more parameters and
returns null this delegate can accept up
to 16 input parameters of different or
the same type
one note to remember about action
generic delegate is when your delegate
does not return any value regardless of
whether it takes any input parameters or
not you must use the action generate
delegate in c sharp the last and final
generic delegate type is the predicate
generic delegate which should be
understood
in c sharp predicate generate delegate
can also be found in system namespace
this delegate is used to validate the
methods criteria and returns the result
as a boolean either true or false it
only accepts one input parameter and
always returns a boolean value which is
required this delegate can accept a
maximum of one input and always returns
the boolean types value
one note to remember about predicate
generic delegate is you must use
predicate generic delegate in c sharp
whenever your delegate returns a boolean
value by taking one input parameter
now let's get back to the practical mode
and take a look at the code
demonstration that will provide a clear
picture of generic delegates including
function action and predicate generic
delegates now this is an example for
generic delegates first we have a main
method followed by the main method we
have our sum number the sum number one
method accepts three arguments and
returns a double value in this example
we'll use the function generic delegate
to accomplish the same thing we did
first similarly number two that is sum
number two method this method accepts
three parameters but returns null in
this example we'll use the action
generate delegate to accomplish the same
thing just what we did
followed by that the length methods
check accepts one string argument and
returns a boolean value in this example
we will use the predicate generate
delegate to accomplish the same
as shown in the preceding code the
function generic delegate accepts four
parameters the first three of which are
input parameters and the fourth one is
the return value then we pass the sum
number one method to the function
generic delegate function object which
will be executed when the function
delegate is invoked the preceding code
shows that the action generate delegate
accepts three input parameters first we
pass the sum number two method to the
action generic delegate function object
which will be executed when the action
delegate is invoked the preceding code
shows that the predicate generate
delegate accepts one string input
parameter name one we pass the check and
the length repeat
we pass the check the length method to
the predicate generic delegate function
object which will be executed when the
predicate generic delegate is invoked
this delegate can only accept one input
parameter and zero return values instead
it returns boolean value by default this
program's output shows the sum of all
the three numbers one two three of the
function sum number one which gives 10
plus 12.15 plus 14.78 which gives a
double value of 65.
similarly the sum number two function
returns the sum of all the three numbers
1 2 and 3 as 20 plus
25.45 plus 12.45 which is 57.90
and the length check function returns a
boolean value if true the length string
hello is less than 10.
the final topic will go over is
delegates using the name and anonymous
methods
a name method can be associated with a
delegate when you use a name method to
instantiate a delegate the method is
passed as a parameter for example first
we declare a delegate with the formal
argument x then we define a named method
and finally we instantiate the delegate
with the method as a parameter
this is accomplished through the use of
a named method let's go over some
delegates with named methods
delegates built with named methods can
encapsulate either a static or an
instance method in the older versions of
c sharp name methods were the only way
to instantiate a delegate however if
creating a new method is unnecessary
overhead c-sharp allows you to
instantiate a delegate and immediately
specify a code block that the delegate
will process when called a lambda
expression or an anonymous method can be
included in the block let's go over some
delegates with anonymous methods as the
name implies an anonymous method does
not have a name for example in c sharp
anonymous methods can be defined with a
delegate keyword and assigned to a
variable of delegate type here is an
example for a delegate with an anonymous
method on my screen anonymous methods
can access variables defined in outer
function here's an example of anonymous
method being passed to a method that
accepts the delegate as a parameter let
us now discuss lambda expressions a
lambda expression is an anonymous method
for creating delegates or expression
tree types in 2007 microsoft introduced
lambda expressions in c sharp 3.0 many
developers frequently confused anonymous
methods with lambda expressions let's
compare the anonymous method and the
lambda expressions with code example
this example will provide at least two
concepts the first thing about working
of the parameterized delegates and the
second about comparing anonymous methods
to a lambda expression you will notice
that you have passed parameter number
value 100 but anonymous method can omit
it and the program will still run it let
us execute this code and see the output
there you go the program got
successfully executed and the message
inside the function has been displayed
this is the function
you will notice that you have passed
parameter number value 100 but anonymous
method can omit it and the program will
still run and similarly the function
is also displaying the message inside it
that is this is the function
now let us see some limitations of using
an anonymous method
the first one is it can include jump
statements such as go to break or
continue it can access an auto methods
reference or out parameter it can
contain or access dangerous code it
cannot be used on the operator's left
side the time it takes to complete
execution is defined as c-sharp weight
the namespace or library used to declare
c-sharp weight is system dot threading
task and the assembly used to declare
weight and c-sharp as system.runtime.pll
we'll look at some
c sharp weight overloads in our next
topic so five types of c sharp weight
overloads are disabled
first we have a wait time span second we
have a weight cancellation token third
we have c sharp weight in 32 fourth we
have weight in 32 cancellation token and
finally we have a weight int 32
cancellation token
let's try to define all five c sharp
bait overloads so the first overload is
the wait time span defined as waiting
for the task to finish execution within
a given time interval the second
overload we have is a weight
cancellation token defined as waiting
for the task to finish its execution if
a cancellation token is cancelled before
the task is completed the weight is
terminated
the third overload is weight in 32 which
states that wait for the task to finish
execution in each number of milliseconds
the next overload c-sharp wait function
is defined as waiting for the task to
finish execution the wait is terminated
if a timeout interval expires or a
cancellation token is cancelled before
the task is completed the fifth and the
final overload of c sharp weight is
weight
the wait for the task to finish
execution
now in this tutorial we'll go through
all the five of these overloads in a
great detail complete with the code
examples
so first as shown on my screen
we have the wait time span
the parameters we use for the wait time
span are time off and time span
representing the number of milliseconds
to wait or minus 1 milliseconds to wait
indefinitely
the return type for this wait time span
is boolean
which will be true if the task has
completed within the time limit
otherwise false
next i will talk about exceptions used
in the wait time span so we use the
three exceptions in wait time span first
we have an object disposed exception
which indicates that the task has been
disposed of
the second exception is the argument out
of fringe exception used when the
timeout is less than -1 milliseconds
representing an infinite timeout or the
timeout exceeds maximum value
the third exception is an aggregate
exception used when the assignment was
cancelled a task cancelled exception
object or an exception thrown during
task execution can be found in the inner
exceptions collection
the information about the exception or
exceptions is contained in an inner
exceptions collection
now we will have some information about
wait time span
weight time span is a synchronization
method that causes the calling thread to
wait for the current task instance to
finish until one of the following
condition is met that is task is met
successfully
task is cancelled or an exception is
thrown you handle an aggregation
exception exception
in this case
timeout interval has expired the current
thread resumes execution and the
method returns false in this case
next examine the wait time span code now
on my screen we have an example for the
wait
the following example begins with a task
that generates 2 million random integers
ranging from 0 to 100 and computes their
mean
the wait time span method is used in
this particular example to wait for the
application to finish within 120
milliseconds
if the application finishes normally the
task displays the sum and the mean of
the random numbers generated if the
timeout interval expires the example
displays a message before exiting
now let's execute this code and see the
output
so there you go the code got
successfully executed and the total sum
of the numbers has been displayed here
and the mean value of the numbers is
been displayed here now with that let's
get back to the presentation next as
shown on my screen we have weight
cancellation token with the parameter
cancellation token defined as while
waiting for the task to finish keep an
eye out for cancellation token next we
have written type which is void use
written type word to indicate that
method or a local function does not have
a written value
finally we have exception handling
finally we have exception handling the
first exception is operation cancelled
exception the cancellation token was
deactivated
the second exception is the object
disposed exception used when the task
has disposed of the final exception
handling is aggregation exception which
is used for cancelled assignments
now we have some important information
about a weight cancellation token weight
cancellation token generates a cancelled
weight which causes the current threat
to wait until the following events occur
one the task has completed and next the
cancellation token has been revoked in
this case
the call to the weight cancellation
token method throws the operation
cancelled exception now let's try to
execute an example based on weight
cancellation token
the following example shows how to use a
cancellation token to cancel waiting for
a task to finish the cancellation token
source is called when a task is launched
the cancel method is used to cancel any
of the tokens source cancellation tokens
followed by two second delay it should
be noted that the task has not been
passed the cancellation token and thus
not cancelable
the application thread calls the task
the wait method is used to wait for the
task to finish but it is cancelled once
the cancellation token is cancelled and
an operation cancelled exception is
thrown the exception handler locks the
exception and then sleeps for three
seconds as the example output
demonstrates the delay allows the task
to complete in a run to complete state
now let's execute the example
so there you go you can see the wait has
been cancelled task is running and task
ended delay
and you can see the rand 2 completion
exception has been thrown
now let's look at the third overload of
c sharp weight which is int 32 as shown
on my screen
we have a parameter called milliseconds
timeout in 32 defined as the amount of
time to wait in milliseconds or in
finite that is -1 to wait indefinitely
the next written type is boolean which
returns true if the task was completed
within the time limit otherwise it
returns false
following that we have exception
handling so we use three exception
handlers here first we have object
disposed exception the task has been
completed the second exception handling
is argument out of range exception which
is defined in milliseconds the timeout
in a negative number other than minus
one representing an infinite timeout
third we have an aggregate exception
defined as the task was cancelled the
task cancelled exception object is found
in the inner exceptions collection an
exception was thrown during the task
execution the inner exceptions
collections contain information about
the exception or exceptions
critical considerations for weighting
int 32 token
weight in 32 is a synchronization method
that causes the calling thread to wait
for the current task instance to finish
until one of the following conditions is
met the task is completed the task is
cancelled or an exception is thrown you
handle an aggregate exception in this
case
the milliseconds timer interval has
expired the current thread resumes
exception and the method returns false
in this case
now let's execute an example based on
weight end 32 the following example
begins a task that generates 2 million
random integers ranging from 0 to 100
and computes their mean the weight in 32
method is used in this example to wait
for the application to finish within 120
milliseconds if the application finishes
normally the task displays the sum and
mean of the random numbers generated if
the timeout interval expires the example
displays a message before exiting
now let's execute the program and see
the output
so there you go the total of random
numbers generated between 0 200 s here
which is the split over here which is 10
lakhs 11 454 and the mean is 50. now the
timeout expires and it is 20 lakhs
now let's discuss the next one
which is
the fourth overload int 32 cancellation
token
the parameters for this overload are
cancellation token and n32 which are
already defined
the next we have a boolean value
that returns true if the task is
completed within the time limit
otherwise returns false following that
we have exception handling the first
exception to be handled is the operation
cancelled exception which is thrown when
the cancellation token is cancelled
when the task is disposed of the second
exception is object disposed exception
the third exception is the argument out
of range exception which is thrown when
the milliseconds timeout is a negative
number other than minus 1 which
represents an infinite timeout finally
when the task is cancelled we got an
aggregate exception the task cancelled
exception object can be found in the
inner exceptions collection an exception
was thrown while the task was being
carried out the information about the
exception or exceptions is contained in
the inner exceptions collection
let's look at some key points
about the weight cancellation token in
32
weight in 32 cancellation token is a
synchronization method that causes the
calling thread to wait for the current
task instance to finish until one of the
following conditions is met the task is
completed the task is canceled or
exception is thrown you handle an
aggregate exception in this case the
cancellation token has been deactivated
the call to the wait in 32 cancellation
token method throws an operation cancel
exception in this case the milliseconds
timeout interval has expired and the
current thread resumes execution and the
method returns false in this case now
let's look at an example based on int 32
cancellation token
the weight in 32 cancellation token
method is used in the following example
to provide both a timeout value and a
cancellation token that can be used to
end the wait for a task completion a new
thread is started and the cancellation
token method is executed which was us
before calling the cancellation token
source to cancel the cancellation tokens
we use the cancel method the task is
then launched after a two second delay
the wait method is then called to wait
for the task completion and is provided
with both a brief timeout value and
cancellation token
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and about to wait
completion of task three cancel the
cancellation token from thread seven
weight completed normally false and the
task time is still running
now finally we have the fifth and final
overload which is the wait function as
shown on my screen there are no
parameters for this overload and the
return type
is set to boolean use the return type to
void to indicate that the method or
local function does not return any value
finally we have exception handling for
the wait function which is object
disposed exception
and surround when the task is disposed
of
the second exception is an aggregate
exception thrown when the task is
cancelled a cancelled exception object
can be found in the inner exceptions
collection or an exception was thrown
while the task was being carried out the
information about the exception or
exceptions is contained in the inner
exceptions collection
now let's look at some points about the
wait function
the wait function is a synchronization
method that tells the calling thread to
wait until the current execution is
finished
if the current task hasn't started yet
the wait method removes it from the
scheduler and executes it in line on the
current thread
if it is unable to do so or if the
current task has already begun execution
it blocks the calling thread until the
task is finished for a better learning
experience let's go and execute a code
demonstration of the wait function
the following example begins a task that
generates 2 million random integers
ranging from 0 to 100 and computes their
mean the wait method is used in this
example to ensure that the task is
completed before the application is
terminated now let's execute the code
and see the output
so there you go the code got
successfully executed and the output is
displayed on the screen
so without any further ado let's get
started with what is asynchronous
programming
the application can work on other tasks
while waiting for the task to be
completed using asynchronous programming
asynchronous programming is very popular
in c-sharp thanks to the async and await
keyword
when dealing with the ui we use a
long-running method like reading a large
file or something similar
if any synchronous process is blocked
the entire application will be blocked
and our application will stop responding
until the task is completed
and if there is no await operator in the
async method then the method will
execute synchronously
now
let's discuss the need for asynchronous
programming
in synchronous programming compilers run
one statement and wait for it to
complete and then move to the next one
whereas in asynchronous programming
compilers run one statement and while it
gets completed we will also work on the
next one
now
we will discuss async and await
keyboards
first up async keyword
asynchronous methods are created by
using async modifier on a method
an async method runs synchronously until
it reaches its first await operator
at which point it suspends
an async method runs synchronously until
it reaches its first await operator at
which point it suspend
next up
await while the asynchronous operation
is running
thus await operator suspend the async
method
when the asynchronous operation
completes the await operator returns the
result
and if there is no await operator in the
async method then the method will be
executed synchronously
next let's try it in the code editor
let's start by creating a class
class
program
we will create
a main function which will be static
void
main
string
args
then we will declare method
one
and method
two
these will be the two method which we
will be calling simultaneously
then console
dot
read
key
now
let's create a asynctask method1 so
public
static
async
task
and method1
then we will call the await keyword
with task
dot
run
and we will include another
small bracket
and go out of it and equals to with
greater than
in this we will declare a for loop
and
i equals to
0
and we will run it 100 times
until
i plus plus
then we will print
console
dot
right line
method
one
is running
now we will add a delay
for this task
so
it will queue up
different tasks
we will give it 100 milliseconds of task
delay
so it will be finished in 100
milliseconds
and dot
weight
we will close this with the
semicolon
now
let's write
a
public method or two
repeat
now let's write
definition for method two
it will be a simple function
definition so public static
void
method
2
a for loop
and
i
is equals to 0
i less than 25
i plus plus
console
dot write line
and we will print
method
2 is running
and we will give it the task delay
of 100
dot weight
here the code will start with the
method1
when it will come to await task then it
will run this for loop and print
method1 is running
and then it will trigger this delay
operation when this delay operation will
be triggered it will stop for 100
millisecond
while that time the method 2 will be
executed because of the async property
now while this method 2 is working when
it will hit the update method it will
again come back to the method1
now this method 2 is only running 25
times so after a point the method 2 will
stop running and then the method one
will work as normally let's try and run
this
let's save first
as you can see
these methods are starting working
you can see the method 2 is running not
that simultaneously as method one is
running
that's because the method two is low in
number
now let's get back to our slides
we have now discussed asynchronous
programming async and await keywords in
detail
now let's look at the differences
between asynchronous and synchronous
programming
first up
using asynchronous programming the
application can work on other tasks
without waiting for the task to be
completed
whereas the synchronous programming
allows us to run one task at a time
also the async modifier is used on a
method to create an asynchronous method
finally while the asynchronous operation
is running the await operator suspends
the async method evaluation
let's get started with what is
dependency injection
dependency injection is a software
design pattern that enables the creation
of loosely coupled softwares
di is an excellent method for reducing
tight coupling between software
components
di also allows us to more effectively
handle future updates and other
complexities in our product
the goal of dependency injection is to
make code more manageable now let's
discuss
what are the other ways to implement
dependency injection
we can implement dependency injection in
three ways
constructor dependency injection
property dependency injection and method
dependency injection
let's start with constructor dependency
injection
the constructor dependence injection
usually has only one parameterized
constructor
there is no default constructor in
constructor dependency
we need to pass the specified value
during object creation
we can use the injection component
anywhere within this class
let's try to implement it in the
correlator
we have already included some system
libraries which will be needed in this
code
now let's start this code with the name
space
property
injection
we will introduce an
interface text
here we will be declaring
a function void
print
then
we will be creating a class
format
which will answer to text
now we will write a definition
for the print function
so
public
void
print
console
dot
right line
and we will type in
subscribe
to
simply learn
now
let's write a constructor
so
public
class
constructor injection
then we will create a private interface
text
for the text interface
then public
constructor
injection
and we will pass on
text as t1
we will store t1
in this dot underscore text
and then
we will call
print function
underscore text
dot
print
basically whenever this function will be
run it will call its constructor
then that constructor will automatically
take the text as its input and then
print the same text
now
let's write
the class
constructor
and we will write
the main function so static
void
main
string
args
then
we will call constructor injection
and make an object cs
new
instructor injection in brackets new
format
then
we will use this object to call print
function
and then the console
dot
read key
this will close the function when
whenever we press any key
let's save it ctrl s
and then run it
as you can see
when this function is run the
constructor was called and that
constructor has initiated
the text t1 then this t1 is caused to
print this this t1 was
the subscribe to simply learn
now let's get back to our slide next up
the property dependency injection
the property is typically used when we
need parameter less constructor
it could even work without changing the
object's state
let's try it in the code editor
let's start with creating a interface
so public
interface
i
notification
action
void
act
on
notification
and we will give it the parameter as
string
message
next we will
have a class
simple
then we will call
the interface
i notification action
task
equals to
null
then public
void
notify
function
then i notification action
this will be 80
comma
string
messages
and then
we will store this 80 in task so this
dot task
equals
80
and then
[Music]
task
will call
act
on notification
messages
now
we will start a class
event
log
writer
i
notification action
then
public
void
at
notification
and string
messages
here we can write anything which we want
to print out
so console
dot
write line
and we will like
click
on
the bell icon
to get
notifications
next we will write a class
program
now we will call the main function so
static
void
main
string
ar gs
we will call
event
logwriter
and
make
an object elw
equals to
new
event
logwriter
now
simple
at
is equals to
new
simple
and then this will call the notify
function
with elw
comma
to
log
now we will write
console
dot
read key
this function helps to terminate the
code with a single key press
let's run this code
as you can see it is printing click on
the bell icon to get notification
now let's go back to our slides
at last
its method dependency injection
we only need to pass the dependency in
the method when using method injection
we do not use constructor injection
because it would create a dependent
object every time the class is initiated
let's try this in the code editor
let's start with the namespace
property
injection
we will write up an interface
public
interface
i
set
void
print
then
we will call a class
so public
class
service
i set
then we will write the definition
for the print function
so
public void
print
and console
dot write line
and then we will print
now
we will call public
class
client
we will call private
i set
and underscore
i set
public
void
run
i set
serve
and we will store this serve in
underscore i set
so this
dot
underscore i set
is equals to
serve
then we will write
console
dot
write line
and we will print
start
and then
this
dot
i set
dot print
so first it will print start
and then
it will run the print function which
will print
the above text which is print dot dot
dot dot
we will write up a class
method
now we will write up the main function
so public
static
void
main
then client
cn
equals to
new
client
then we will run
cn
dot run
in brackets
new
cervix
then we will call
console
dot
read key
to terminate the code
when it reads the key
now let's save it
and run this code
as you can see it's first
writing this command start and then it
is calling the sprint function which
then prints this print
statement
let's get back to our slides
finally
let's conclude this tutorial with some
advantages of dependency injection
first up
dependency injection helps in reducing
the class coupling
next up
it increases
the reusability of the
code next the dependency injection helps
to improve code maintainability
at last the dependency injection makes
it feasible to conduct unit testing
let's get started with what is design
pattern
design patterns are reusable solution to
typical software design issues that
arise frequently in real world
application development
patterns are employed by developers to
tackle challenges in their individual
designs
understanding design patterns is more
important than memorizing their classes
methods and attributes
individual needs and difficulties
influence pattern selection and uses
among
numerous design patterns
now let's discuss types of design
pattern
there are three types of design patterns
available
creational design pattern structural
design pattern and behavioral design
pattern
let's start up with creational design
pattern
the creational design patterns deal with
object creation and initialization
the creational design pattern gives the
programmer more flexibility in deciding
which objects need to be created for
give for a given case
we have five types of design patterns in
this
abstract factory builder factory method
prototype and singleton
let's discuss each of them in detail
first up abstract factory
the abstract factory design pattern
allows you to create families of linked
items without having to declare their
classes
next up builder pattern
builder is a design pattern that allows
you to build complicated objects in
stages
this patterns enables you to create many
types of representations of an object
while using the same creation code
next up factory method
a factory method is a creational design
pattern that provides an interface for
creating
objects in superclass while allowing
subclasses to choose the type of object
created
next up prototype
prototype pattern is a design pattern
that allows you to imitate existing
objects without making your code land on
their classes
the prototype patterns provides a basic
interface for working with all objects
that permits cloning to the client code
at last singleton
the singleton pattern ensures that a
class has only one instance while also
giving a global access point to that
instance
next up
let's discuss the structural design
pattern
the structural design pattern is
basically used to manage the structure
of classes and interfaces
as well as manage the relationship
between the classes
we have seven types of design patterns
in this
adapter
bridge composite pattern decorator
pattern for cat pattern
fly weight pattern and proxy pattern
let's discuss each of them in detail
first up adapter
the adapter design pattern is a
structural design pattern that allows
items with conflicting interfaces to
work with one another
we use this pattern to reuse many
existing subclasses that lacks common
functionality that cannot be added to
the superclass
next up bridge
this pattern is a structural design
pattern that allows you to split large
class or a collection of related classes
into two independent hierarchies
abstraction and implementation
next composite pattern
composite is a structural design pattern
that enables you to organize parts into
three structures
and manipulate them independently of one
another the composite pattern provides
two basic element kinds with a shared
interface
simple leaves and complex containers
after that decorator
decorator is a structural design pattern
that allows objects by wrapping them in
special wrapper object
this pattern uses the decorative
technique to add extra behaviors to
objects without disrupting the code that
utilizes them
next up facade
forget is a structural design pattern
that simplifies complex libraries
frameworks and class interfaces
when you require a simple but limited
interface to a complicated subsystem we
use the focat pattern
at last proxy pattern
proxy is a structural design pattern
that enables you to substitute an item
a proxy control access to a source
object allowing you to do actions before
or after the request
next up is a behavioral design pattern
the behavioral design pattern deals with
communication between classes and
objects that means if you want to change
the behavior of a class and again you
want it to affect other classes of the
project as well
we have 10 types of design patterns
available in this
chain of responsibility iterator memento
state template method command
mediator
observer strategy
and visitor
let's discuss them in detail
first up the chain of responsibility
a behavioral design pattern called the
chain of responsibility allows you to
pass requests along the chain of
handlers
when a request is received each handler
determines whether to process it or send
it to the next handler in the chain
next up iterator
iterator is a behavioral design pattern
that allows you to traverse components
of a collection without revealing the
representation below that is list stack
tree etc
iterators can be used to traverse
composite trees
next up is memento
memento is a behavioral design pattern
that saves and restores an object prior
straight
without revealing its implementation
when you need to take pictures of an
object's state in order to store it to a
previous state we use memento pattern
next up state pattern
state is a behavioral design pattern
that allows an entity to change its
behavior in response to the changes in
its internal state
it appears that the object's class has
changed
then the template pattern
template method is a behavioral design
that lets subclasses
alter steps of an algorithm without
changing its structure
we use the template method to allow
customers to extend specific types of an
algorithm
not the entire method or its structure
then we have command pattern
command is a behavioral design pattern
that turns a request into a standalone
object
this transformation supports
unachievable operations and passing
request as method argument
after that mediator
mediator is a behavioral design pattern
that reduces object dependency to
collaborate the objects must first
communicate to a mediator object
next up is observer pattern
observer is a behavioral design pattern
that allows you to establish a
subscription mechanism to allow alert
numerous objects about an event that
occur to the item being observed
when some objects in your app must
monitor others for a limited time or in
specific circumstances we use this
pattern
next up strategy pattern
strategy is the behavioral design
pattern that allows you to construct a
family of algorithms
classify them and make them object
interchangeable
when you have a bunch of similar classes
that just differ in how they perform
some behavior then we use the strategy
pattern
at last visitor the visitor pattern is a
behavioral design pattern that allows
you to decouple algorithms from the
objects they act on
when you need to perform an operation on
all elements of a complicated object
structure we use the visitor
finally let's conclude this tutorial
with some advantages of design patterns
first up abstract factory classes are
frequently based on set of factory
methods although the method on these
classes can also be composed using
prototype
next up to reduce ram we can use
flyweights to construct shared composite
tree leaf nodes
finally you can treat a visitor as a
powerful version of the command pattern
its objects can execute operation over
various objects of different classes
let's get started with link
link is an abbreviation for language
integrated query
microsoft query language is completely
integrated and allows for simple data
access from in-memory objects databases
xml documents and many other sources
link unifies queries in c-sharp and
visual basics through series of
extensions
next up let's discuss lambda expression
lambda expressions are the executable
components of length equations that
translate logic to sent to the data
source at runtime
here is the basic schema for lambda
expression
next async lambda a lambda expression
that use the async keyword to integrate
asynchronous processing
use the syntax to print simply learn
using asynchronous programming
now let's implement this in the code
editor
let's get started so using
system
then
using system
dot
collection
dot generics
we will also use using
system
dot
link
and
using
system
dot
text
now
namespace
lambda
x
then curly braces
and inside that we will have a class
program
curly braces
then i will declare a delegate
and
the lag
and
i
then we will have
static
world
main
strength
args
again curly braces
and in this
we will have deluxe
that my delay
is equals to
a
equals to greater than to make an arrow
a star
hey
then
and
x
is equals to
my deluxe
with the value
let's say
7
now
let's use console
dot
write line
and print out x
then console
dot
read
line
basically this function will be printing
out the square for the 7 so basically it
should print out 49
let's save it
and run
as you can see it is printing 49.
let's get back to our slides
now let's discuss lambda in standard
query operators
a lambda expression with a query
operator is evaluated on demand and
operates on each element in the input
sequence rather than the entire sequence
a lambda expression allows developers to
insert their own logic into the usual
query operator
let's take a look at an example in a
correlator where the developer utilized
the where operator to recover the or
items from a provided list using a
lambda expression
let's go to the code editor let's write
a code to get an average of the odd
fibonacci numbers in the series
so we will start with introducing using
system
then using
system
dot collection
dot
generics
then we have using
system
dot
link
then we are using
system
dot text
another name space
let's have lambda
x
then we have a class
program
then curly braces
in this we will have static
void
main
string
here's yes
now we will have end
braces
web
is equals to
in curly braces let's have numbers 1
1
comma 2
comma 3
comma 5
comma 8
comma 13
comma 21
comma 34
these are some fibonacci numbers
now let's declare another variable
double
average
well
equals to
fib
dot
where
and braces
n
is equals to equals to greater than
n
modulo two
equals to equals to
1
dot
average
then
let's have a console
dot write line
to print
average file
and another console line
to read line
read
line
let's save it
and run it
as you can see it is printing 7.333
which is basically the average of these
numbers
now let's get back to our slides
now let's discuss the topic type
inference
type inference is useful in a number of
circumstances in c sharp
and it may be used without explicitly
stating the types
in the case of a lambda expression
however time inference will only
function if each type has been provided
as the compiler must be satisfied
the compiler uses type inference to
deduce that x is an
integer which it does by inspecting the
transformer arguments given below
now let's discuss the variable scope in
detail
variables launched within a lambda
expression are not supposed to be
visible in an outer method according to
the several regulations when employing
variable scope in a lambda expression
there is also a requirement that a
captured variable is not to be a garbage
collected unless the delegate addressing
it becomes garbage collection eligible
furthermore it is against the rule to
utilize a written statement within
lambda expression to force the return of
an enclosing method
now let's try a code to understand this
in detail
let's start with using
system
then
using
system
dot collection
dot generic
then
using
system
dot link
then again using
system
dot
text then i will have a namespace
as
lambda
x
in curly braces i will have a class
program
then i will declare some delegates
for
d1
and
delegate
boolean
d2
this d2 will have
end i as argument
next
let's have a class
test
where i will have
my d1 delegate
as del 1
and d2 delegate
as
do
now let's have
public
void
test method function
with an argument as end
input
in curly braces
let's initialize the delegates with
lambda expression so first end
p is equals to zero
then we will have del 1
is equals to
empty braces
equals to greater than
p is equals to 10
then return
be greater than
input
then we will invoke del2 after test
method goes out to the score
so del 2
equals to
in pressure this time we will have x
equals to greater than to make an arrow
curly braces we will have return
x
is equal to is equals to
e
then we will close this delegate
now we will demonstrate the value of p
this time the delegate has not been
revoked yet
so
we will have
console
dot
right line
here we'll write p
is equals to
i will have a placement 0 here
for the variable
j
then
we will have full
result
is equals to
del 1
then
we will write
console
dot
write line
here you will have
p
is equals to in curly braces
we will have placement 0
and comma then we have b
is equals to in curly braces placement
for one
where the 0 and 1 represent
p
and
will result
now let's write static
world
mind
strength
now let's have
test
small test
is equals to
new
test
with small breasts
here now
i will call
test dot
test
method
for value 5.
now we will prove that the del 2 still
has copy of local variable p
from the test method
so now
bull
res
will be equals to
test
dot delta
for the value 10
then we will print out this with console
dot
write line
rest
then i will have
a console
dot feed key
let's save it and run it
as you can see it is first printing p is
equal to 0 then when we replace it it
with 10 the p is equal to n and it is
printing b is true and then again result
as true
let's get back to our slides
now let's have a look at the expression
tree
lambda expressions are often utilized in
expression tree development
an expression tree distributes the code
in data structures like a tree
with each node being an expression such
as method call or a binary operation
such as x less than y statement lambdas
which consist of two or three statement
are also available
but are not employed in the creation of
expression tree
a return statement must be expressed in
a lambda statement
now
let's implement this in a code editor
let's start
using
system
then i will use
using
system
dot collection
dot generic
then we will use
system
dot link
then using
system
dot
text
this time we will also use
using
system
dot link
dot
expressions
now let's have a namespace
lambda x as usual
here you will have a class
program
and this we will have a static
world
main
where in main we will have string
arcgis
then we will have and
src
equals to
new
3 comma
8
comma
4
comma 6
comma
2
comma
10
comma
19 comma
2 comma 4 comma
8
now let's have a 4h
statement
where we will have end
j
in
src
dot
where
x
is equals to greater than
if
x
is less than equals to three
then we will return
true
else
f
x
is greater than equals to
7
then also we will return
true
else
we will return
false
then
we will have console
dot write line
and we will print j
then we will have another console line
dot
shade
line
basically what we are doing is we have
this set and we are only returning the
value which are either less than 3 less
than equals to 3 or greater than equals
to 7. so the 4 6
8
sorry 4 6 and 4 will be removed and
others will be printed
let's save it
and run it
as you can see it is printing every
value except for 4 6 and 4.
now let's get back to our slides
let's have a look at the conclusion
a lambda expression can have parameters
and return a value
a lambda expression may be used to
declare parameters in a variety of ways
there is no need for curly braces in a
lambda expression if there is only one
statement but a curly braces and the
return value must be returned if there
are several statements
a feature calls closure
allows lambda expression to access
variables that are available outside of
lambda expression block the closure
should be used with caution to avoid
problems
any hazardous code cannot be executed
within a lambda expression
lambda expressions should not be
utilized on the left side of the
operator
let's get started with what dictionaries
are
in c sharp the dictionary class
represents a generic collection of key
value pairs
dictionary is a class defined in the
system.collection package
a generic namespace is a sort of a class
that can include any kind of data in the
form of keys and values
each key in collection must be one of a
kind
here's the syntax
for declaring a dictionary
next up let's discuss methods in the
dictionary
there are basically four methods we can
apply
in a dictionary
we can add an element
remove an element
find an element
or replace an element
now let's implement this in the code
data
choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
let's start
we will start with namespace
dictionary
class
program
static
void
main
with argument as
string
args
here we will create a dictionary with
the string key and in 16 value pair
so
dictionary
string
comma
and
16.
depth
is equals to
new
dictionary
string
and
16
now we will add elements to this
so
detect
dot
add
then let's add a word
cart
and give it a value as 32
then
we can have
another element
in this dictionary
predict add
and name it
talk
with number as
25
next check
dot
add
3
comma
29
that
dot
add
row
comma
21
that
start
add
allow
comma
34
now let's write a statement to count the
words in the dictionary
so console
start
writeline
count
in curly braces
zero
comma
object
dot count
now
let's try to set a new item value
so
let's see text
i want to change the value
for element 3
and let's change it
to let's say 9.
now if
not that dot
contain
contains key
as
dog
then
we will change the value
for this
torque
as
20.
now let's say if
we want to get
an element using values
so we will not direct
contain
value
as
nine
and we will
have it as
console
dot
writeline
as
item
found
now let's try to read all the items
so
console
dot right line
words
hall
item
now for each
key value pair
string
comma
and
16
word
in
text
so we will write
console
dot right
line
key
zero
comma
value
as one
comma
word
dot
key
comma
word
dot value
now
let's try to remove
subject
dot remove
and let's remove
tree
let's copy double
lines
after
deleting
tree
here we are printed again
now
let's remove all the element so
text
dot
clear
let's save this
and run it
as you can see
here
we are getting the count as 5
since we first
tried to find the count of the elements
then
we have printed all the elements
then we remove the tree
so now
then we print it again so it is removed
again
let's get back to our slides
now let's discuss the hash table
a hash table in c sharp stores
keys values pair
where keys can find the storage
since it is immutable a hash table
cannot have duplicate entries
the collections dictionary entry objects
have two properties a key and a value
the values of table can only be accessed
by defining a key object
here's the syntax for defining a hash
table
now
let's have a look at the properties of
hash table
first up
comparer
it returns or sets the icomparer to be
used
next count
this returns the number of key value
pairs in the hash table
then
is ready only will return a value
indicating whether the hash table is
read only or not
after that item
it returns or sets the value associated
with the supplied key
then keys
this will return the i collection
containing
the keys of the hash table
at last values
this returns an i collection containing
the value for the hash table
now let's discuss the method in hash
tables
a hash table contains the following
methods
add
which inserts a hash table elements with
the specified key and value
then clear
this will remove all elements from the
hash table
contains key will indicate whether or
not the specified key is present in the
hash table
then contains value this will indicate
whether or not the supplied value is
present in the hash table
now let's try these methods in the hash
table in the code editor
let's start with namespace
as
hash
table
class
as program
static
void
main
with argument as string
args
now let's define the hash table so hash
table
h
table
equals to
new
hash
table
now let's add element in the hash table
so as table dot
add
1
comma
let's add element as c
then
hash table
dot
add
at number three
let's add a
then
hash table
dot
add
let's set
s
at number 4
then
hashtable dot add
at number two
let's add
r
hash table dot
add
then at number five
we will add
h
basically what i wanted to do was
from key 1 to 5 we will be spelling
crash
so
now for each
for each
object
i
in
h table
dot keys
console
dot
write line
i
and for
each
object
j
in
h table
dot
values
console
dot
right line
j
basically these two statements will be
printing out the first the keys and then
the objects
now
let's print them together so for
each
dictionary
entry
tick
n
h table
we will write console
dot right line
keys
is equals to
0
and
values
is equals to
1
in curly braces
comma
so this will be tick
dot
key
comma dic dot
value
and then
we will pass on console
dot
sheet key
let's save this
and run it
as you can see we have first printed out
the keys
from 5 to 1 in
opposite angle and then crash as hsarc
then we have printed these
together
now
let's get back to our slides
now let's have a look at sets
in c sharp sets are referred to as hash
sets
in c sharp hashtag
ensures that there are no duplicate
strings or elements in an array
here is the syntax to declare the sets
now let's implement this in the code
editor so we will start with class
program
static
void
main
here we will be declaring a string
arr
1
equals to
paper
comma
pencil
comma
eraser
comma
pen
comma
paper
now
let's print this so console
dot
write
string
dot
join
comma
comma
ar1
now let's declare a headset so var
h
is equals to new
hash
set
string
area 1
now
since we have converted this error
into a hashtag it will eliminate the
duplicate words
so now string
arr
2
will equals to
h
dot
2 array
now we have stored
that ar1 array into ar2
so now we will print this
so console
dot
write line
then string
dot
join
comma
comma
arr
2.
let's save it
and run this
as you can see
first time it is printing the
string array as it is like paper pencil
eraser pen paper but when we have
converted it into hash set it has
eliminated the duplicate value paper
which was coming at the first and the
last position
started with the discussion on what are
collections
first collection classes are specialized
data storage and retrieval classes
stacks queues list and hash tables are
all supported by these classes then
collection classes performs a variety of
functions such as dynamically allocating
memory to components
and retrieving a list by objects by an
index among others
at last these classes construct
collections
of object objects
which serves as a foundation for all
data types in c sharp
next let's go over the types of
collections
they are majorly two types of
collections defined
first the generic collection
and the non-generic collection
let's discuss them in detail
first we have our generic collections
a generic collection is a class that
provides type safety without requiring
derivation from basic collection type
and the implementation of type specific
members the collection classes
are found
in the namespace system.collections.com
internally generic collection store
elements in arrays of their respective
types that is it can only have
if if the collection is of n type then
it can only have elements of in type
now there are several generic
collections available
first list
then we have dictionary
next sorted list
then we have stack
and finally q
now let's go over the codes on each of
them
now
let's go over some general
functions first start with a generic
list here to declare a list we use list
end
and then the name for the list
then we use new
identifier
to start a new list
this is the basic syntax to create a
list
now to add a list we use an add function
so we are using gen list dot add to add
30 in this list and 60 then 90 then 120
after that we are using this for each
loop to print out this list
now let's print it
as you can see it has printed 30 60 90
and 120 just in the order we printed in
this list
let's close this
now
let's see dictionary
here we have this basic code for the
dictionary
to initialize the dictionary we use
keyword dictionary then in angular
brackets we define the type
of both the parts of the dictionary one
is key and one is value
then we have dictionary name then we
again use new keyword
to finally start this dictionary
this is the basic syntax to create a
dictionary
then we have this function add to add
the data in the list
note that we are giving two values
one is
end which is given here as key
then we have here a string
now
we are using a fourier function where we
are
asking a key value pair
and naming it key y kyp
in this dictionary
key value pair means key and value pair
that is we are basically accessing both
the values together
we can simply write key here
key
kyp in dictionary and we can get the
same thing
then we are using the right line command
basically printing out the key and the
value separated by this
space
let's save it
and run it
here you can see we are reprinting first
the key one
then the value soda
same goes for the burger fries and onion
rings
now
let's go over
our
sorted list
now for the sorted list
we also have a key and value pair
now to make it a little different
i used string here
instead of end
now
to create a sorted list we use a sorted
list
name
then
we give 2l
then we can give two
different data types for the two
different values
then we have sorted list
as list as the name
then we have new keyword
then we basically create this
then
we use add function to add the
value key and value
to this list
then we use key value pair in a for each
to print out the values
let's save it
let's close this so that we can get new
data
let's save it
and run it
and here as you can see we are printing
out american fry omega burgers french
fries lime soda onion ring in the same
order as they are added
now
let's go over a stack
now for a stack
we are using stack then we are only
giving one value since stack has only
one value one type of data in one time
so we are giving a string values to the
stack
i name this stack
just to make the pun
then we are using new keyword
and this is the basic syntax for a stack
now for stack
to enter the values in the stack we use
push command now if you remember stack
we basically push a value above another
so basically if we have
given rear first
that means it will be at the bottom
because first we are entering rare then
medium layer will go up above rare then
medium will go up
up mid medium there then weldon will be
on top so when we will print this out
it will basically print
well done first then medium then medium
rare then rare last
and we are using this four each loop to
print out this
stack
let's run it
and sure enough as you can see we are
first printing out the weldon
then medium the medium rare than rare
now
let's go and try out cues
here queues is also using only one type
of
variable so we are using string here
i have named it genqueue
then we are using new keyword
to create a new queue
and this is a complete syntax to create
a queue
here to add new data in a queue we use
enqueue
so we are entering mark bill xavier
michael
now
and we are also using a four-ish loop
to print out the values for this queue
let's run it
and here it is printing mark bill savior
michael just in the way it was skewed
now we have discussed all of these
generic lists
so now let's get back to our slides
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
next let's discuss a non-generic
collections
non-generic collections are specialized
data storage and retrieval classes that
handle stacks queues list and hash
tables
the
system.collections name space contains
the non-generic collection classes
non-generic collection classes store
elements in object areas internally
allowing them to hold any type of data
so basically
same
collection can have different type of
databases now there are various types of
non-generated correction such as
arraylist
table
then we have sorted list
then stack
then finally we have q
now let's now go over few of these codes
to explain each of these collections
and here we have
a non-generic list
so let us go over error list first
now here
to declare an error list we use
arraylist
keyword
then we gave it the name al
then we have
new keyword then arraylist
if you notice here clearly
unlike generic list
we are not giving any kind of data type
so basically allowing us to use
different types of data types
next in the next line we are declaring a
string
which tells us
like share and subscribe so you also
don't forget to like share and subscribe
to this video
next x equals to 11
this is an integer type of variable then
we have a datetime variable
d
which basically is telling us to parse
in a daytime format this 3 december 1998
then we are using add command to add all
three of these
in this error list
then we are using 4 each to print out
the serial list
now let's run it
now here as you can see just printed out
this string like share and subscribe
then it has printed out this integer
type
then for the date time
since we asked us to pass this in the
datetime format so it gave us 0-3 it
replaced the december by 12
and then given us the year 90 dead after
that it is also giving given us the time
it has given us a default time of 12 a.m
since we didn't provide any date any
time from our side
now
let's check out hash tables
now in hash table
we use hash table command
then we gave it a name
then
we are having the new keyword to
finally create a complete hack level
this is the basic syntax to create a
hash table
now we are using add command to add
these values and hash table has two
layers
a key
and a value
just like dictionary
now i use the same
data set for the dictionary which i use
for the hash table to make a comparison
then
we have for each dictionary entry
to basically print out these h key and h
value
let's run it
let's close it first for better clarity
now let's run it
here
as if you look closely it is printing
out four onion rings first then three
fries then two burgers then one soda and
why is that because in hash table
basically insert
the data
on one above the other just like a stack
now that's a bigger difference between a
dictionary and a hash table
now
let's go over a sorted list
now in a sorted list
we are using sorted list command
now if you are noticing something very
simple
we are not giving them any kind of
idea on what could be our
keys and what could be our values data
types of these so basically we can have
different types of data types here as
well
now i'm using the same data set
which i used here
in generic sorted list
to make a simple comparison
if you look closely we are using so that
you can understand here in general we
were using
these data types
to create a sorter list
whereas
in non-generic we are not giving any
data types but we are using the same
data
now let's try and print this we are also
using dictionary entry to get access
each of these values if you had noticed
in sorted list we used key value pair
but in non-generic we are using a
dictionary entry
let's run it
and it has printed american burger
french fry lime soda onion ring
then next in our list is stack
here we are also using stack but we are
not giving any kind of idea on what kind
of
values it will be
to make the pun i again use that
then give out the values as rare medium
rare medium and well done
now let's try and print it
here as you can see it is printing out
weld and medium medium rare because it's
a stack so it will always have the last
value added as its first
now let's discuss queues
and here q
we are using q keyword to define a queue
then a name then a new keyword
and this is a complete
syntax for a queue in a non-generic
collection here we are using npu
to print out to add the data in the
queue
then we are using
object
to
get the values from this queue
now let's run it
and here as you can see
we are printing mark bill savior and
michael
now this is all for these quotes let's
get back to our slides and finish up
this session
finally let's conclude this session with
some pointers on collections
first in most circumstances it is
preferable to utilize generic
collections
since they operate quicker than
non-generic collections and help reduce
exemptions by displaying a compile time
error
then a non-generated collection type of
found in system dot collection string
source while generic type collections
are found in the
system.collections.generate namespace
net c sharp
also has
several specialized collections that are
teamed to deal with a specific sort of
data type which may be found in the
system.collection.specialized
namespace at large the collection class
support a null as a valid reference type
value and enables redundant
element
like some duplicate elements
with what is interfaces in c sharp
interfaces in c sharp is like a
blueprint of a class
it is like an abstract class because all
the methods which are declared inside
the interface are abstract methods
it cannot have a methods body and can
not be instantiated
we name an interface with a capital
letter i in the syntax as you can see
here
next
let's discuss why do we need interfaces
in c sharp
since in c shaft we can use inheritance
using classes
so to overcome that issue we use
interfaces
interfaces are basically used to build
loosely coupled application
this means that components are not
dependent on each other and any
altercation will not impact that
application
itself let's say for example there are
two classes drawable in shape
now this drawable class is dependent on
shape class since it can only draw
shapes if there are set shape defined in
the class
this dependency is due to them being
tightly coupled
now let's say we have an interface
drawable
now this interface can easily
communicate with different classes and
it will not affect the main goal to draw
the shape
finally let's implement this interface
in c sharp
let's start with using
system
let's start with creating an interface
for public
interface
drawable
we always use capital i in front of the
name
as in common nomenclature
for interface
these interfaces don't have access
specifier like in classes like
public private or protected so we will
simply define void
a function draw
now we don't define any
methods in the interface itself
so we will now create a class
so public
class
rectangle
driver
now we will call the function draw so
public
void
duh
now to draw
we will write console
dot
write line
and we will print
drawing
rectangle
to give the proof that we are accessing
this
drawing function for that from rectangle
now let's write another class circle
so public
class
circle
color i drawable
and we will call public
void draw
and we will print using console
dot
write line
and we will print
drawing
circle
now
let's make another class
public
class
test
now we will declare our main here so
public
static
void
main
now we will declare an object for the
interface
now this object
we'll use
to create
an object for the rectangle
and then we will call draw
d dot row
to access rectangle
now let's define this d
for the circle so d is equals to
new
circle
and then we will again call draw
to draw this circle
now let's save this
and run it
as you can see here
we are able to call rectangle in circle
classes using draw function with the
help of interfaces now let's get back to
our slides with the discussion on what
are streams
first a screen is an organized sequence
of pipes
that is transmitted from one application
to input device to another
these bytes are transmitted and read
sequentially and always arrive in the
same sequence they were sent
next streams are the main way of
transmitting information in the computer
world streams enable various programs to
access computer data and create network
connections with remote systems
then in the world of computers many
operations can be interpreted as either
reading or writing to a stream
for example printing sends a sequence of
bytes to a
screen associated with the corresponding
port to which the printer is connected
at last
when you read or write from or to a file
you must first open the screen to the
matching file then we will execute the
reading and the writing and then we have
to close the screen
next let's go over the type of stream
there are two types of stream defined
first we have binary string
then we have text strings
let's discuss them in detail
first let's have a look at binary
streams
a binary stream comprises
one or more bytes of unique data
users may write the value contained in
an abstract object
to a bi-correlator or a binary stream
and read back the identical value that
was recorded in the object when the user
wrote it
next
the library function do not change
the byte sent between the program and
the binary stream
they can however append an arbitrary
amount of null bytes
to the file that you write with the
binary string
the application must deal with the
additional null right at the conclusion
of the binary strings
then
except for positioning relative to the
end of the binary stream location within
a binary string
well defined
the current file position indication can
be obtained and changed the same way as
a text stream can
finally
the file is viewed as a series of bytes
in a byte string
except for the potential changes
discussed previously
the string appears to the application as
the same sequence of files
next
let's discuss text streams
a text stream comprises one or more
lines of text that may be written to a
text oriented display and viewed
next a software reads a nl or
new line at the end of each line
while reading from the text range
after that the software prints an anal
to signify the end of the line when
writing to a text string
the library functions can change the
amount and representation of characters
transferred between the application
and a text stream to meet different
conventions for encoding text in files
among target environments
[Music]
the last
positioning is constrained inside a text
string
calling f get pose or f10 will
return the current file position
indication
by using f's and pull or fc command you
will place a text stream at a location
found in this manner as well as at the
start and end of the stream
finally let's conclude this session with
a demo to read or write on a text file
now we will start with creating a new
project
we will be creating a console app so
console
then we have
now we have these many options
note that we will be using a dotted
framework one as well as which uses c
sharp
so let's use this
then we will go to next
let's name this
text file
demo
we will use the framework.net framework
4.7.2
then we will hit create
now let's get started
so first
we will define
string
and name it
file
dir
then we will hit enter
now here we will be entering the file
path to which a text
text document will be stored
so
we will use accurate
then we will use semicolon now we have
to give an address here
so let's first go over and create a new
folder
i've already created a folder so let's
right click over there
here this is my folder x12 demo
now we will create a new
text document
we will name this
as demo file
let's name this this
now we will go over
[Music]
properties
and we will copy its location
ctrl c
we can close this
now
we will go back here
[Music]
we'll paste this we will add one back
arrow
and write the name so name was term of
file
let's make sure
that we are using the slide name
demo file app should be capital
demo file
dot txt
[Music]
now we will create a list
so we will have a list
[Music]
this list will have string
[Music]
[Music]
we will name this
text
lines
equal to
new
[Music]
list
string
and close
[Music]
then we will write a file
function
file dot
read
we are using file
[Music]
now it may happen that it's not working
so
what we will use is this using system.io
this will give us the correct
directories to use these
so
let's try it again so these all text
so we have options like read all tags
read all bytes
let's suppose if we are using binary
string or we are using text string but
let's go and you
read all lines so that
it's easier to drop in both of these
cases
so we will use read all lines
[Music]
then we will give
[Music]
the file path as file dir
dot
but now
[Music]
by default
this file only uses a string error so we
will need to convert this whole thing
into a list so we will use
two lists
now you guys must be asking we haven't
added anything in that file
so list how is it going to read all
these all lines from that so
first let's go over to the text file
and add some data to it
so here we'll open this
[Music]
let's write some data
let's see
superhero names so
superman
is from dceo
then we have
batman
or let's use spiderman
he's from mcu
[Music]
then we can use help
again i'll see you
let's use someone from dc so let's use
flash
cc
[Music]
let's have one more
uh wonder woman
[Music]
pvc
let's save this
and close this
now we have added some data in these
so let's go back to our code
now
according to our code till now it should
have read all the data from the file but
now we have added this the data to file
how what would check if it actually got
added or not
so let's have and for each
loop
so for each
line
for its
frame
[Music]
line
and
[Music]
text
life
[Music]
let's close this
okay
now we have better look at our code
so
then we will have control
dot
bright line
here we will have nine
[Music]
now this will print out all the lines
[Music]
now let's also add
a console
dot
read line
this command will make sure that
the window the console window which will
open when we will run this code will not
close it will only close after we have
hit enter
now let's run this
and as we can see it has finally read
the data from the text file
now how about we can write something on
this
so we refuse this
then
after this forage
let's add some data to this list
so
we will use
text
lines
dot
add
[Music]
and curly braces
let's add another superhero
rms
and
its universe as mcc
now this will
add the data
to the list
but how do we write this data to the
file
so we will use
file
dot write all lines
then
for the file path
we will give
our file dir
and
what we want to
write all these lines here will be from
the list text lines
now we'll save this and let's run it
[Music]
but why is it not printing the new line
which we just added
that's because
this program
where this file uh this printing
function rain before then we were adding
but it still did add these lines so to
check that we can go
and check that file
let's open it
and here you can see we have iron mcu
now
let's comment these lines so that we
don't add double values
now run this again
now
as you can see the iron man is added to
this list
this is how you read and write to a file
now let's get back to our slides
let's get started
with the discussion on what a thread
class is
first
a thread is defined as a program
operating root
that is every thread creates its own
distinct control flow
next a threading reduces cpu cycle waste
and it also improves a program's
efficiency
threads are created using a thread class
which is
lets you specify a thread's precedence
and it also displays a current status of
the thread
next let's go over a few pointers on
multi-threading
but first let's understand what a single
threaded model is
every program has a one thread that
performs the logic of a program by
default
and this thread is known as a main
thread
hence every program or application is a
single threaded by default
but there is a disadvantage to these
single threaded architectures
the single thread executes all of the
processes in a program synchronously
that is one after the other as a result
the second process needs to wait until
the first process completes its
execution
so the second process will take longer
to process
but to overcome this disadvantage we
have multi-threading
multi-threading refers to the use of
many threads
inside a single process
each thread here serves a separate
function
so the main advantage of multi-threading
is
that it operates concurrently meaning
numerous jobs may be executed
simultaneously
finally a multi-threading also maximizes
the cpu's resource consumption
next
let's discuss threads life cycle
typically a threats lifecycle begins
with the creation of an instance
of the system dot threading
and a thread class
and it terminates when the thread is
stopped or it finished its execution
now a threat's life cycle has four
states
the unstarted state
a ready state
the not renewable state and the dead
state
let's go over them
one by one
first is an unstarted state
it occurs when a thread object is
created but the threat method is not
invoked
next we have a ready state
in this state
the thread is ready to execute but it's
still awaiting cpu cycle
then we have a not runnable state
when a thread is not executable
because
either the sleep method has been invoked
or the weight method as has been
involved
or the input activities
are causing a bottleneck
then
at last we have the dead state
it is the state in which threats
execution is
either completed or aborted
in now that we have thoroughly discussed
the thread and their life cycles
we have also discussed a single threaded
model and a multi-threaded model
so now let's implement these models in a
visual studio course
let me move to my visual studio course
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so let's start
with some basic using commands so using
system
then we will have using
system
[Music]
dot
threading
then we will have our namespace
with the name as
thread
demo
now
let's have a class
as public
class
main thread
1
now in this thread we will have a static
method
so
public
static
void
th
rd1 this will be our thread name
let's write code in this
function
so we will have a for loop
and
t is equals to 0
then
t is less than equals to
10
then we will have p plus plus
then we will have a console
dot
write line
thread
one
is
then we will
place
a specifier
input
so what these
curly braces
zero will do is it will replace the zero
curly braces zero with the t
but
when the value of
this t is equals to 5 then this method
must go sleep for six seconds and after
six seconds it should resume its working
so to do that we will have a if
statement
and we will have t is equals to equal to
5
then for the curry basis we will have
a thread
dot
sleep
and we will have six thousand
now let's create another thread
so we will have another function as
public static
void
phrd2
this will also print numbers from 0 to
10
so for loop
and
p
is equals to 0
p
less than equals to 10
and p
plus plus
i will have
console
dot
write line
thread
2
is
comma
e
now let's write
our main class
so
for that we will go for the public
class
and
main thread
two
then
in this
we will have
static
public
void
main
then
we will call our static methods
so
main
thread
1
dot
thread
one
then
we will again call main third one dot
thread
two
now let's save this
and run this program
but first let me explain what this code
does so that so here what will happen is
first this thread one will be executed
now
when t
this folder will cycle t so from zero to
it will go to 9
but when t reaches 5 this if statement
will relaunch and this will let
let go this thread to sleep for 6
seconds the 6 000 represents 6 seconds
now
while these six seconds are over this
thread two is still in the waiting
process
so this whole for loop will be on sleep
for six seconds after the six second
this thread will again run so then it
will start printing out
6 7 8 9
and so on and 10.
then this thread 2 will be
started and then this will go from 0 to
10
straight up it will not go to slip
because this thread doesn't have this
sleep function
now this is what a good example of
single threaded
process now let's run this
now as you can see it has already
printed from zero to five now it's on
weight
then
after six seconds it printed out the
rest of this thread one then thread two
now
let's write the code for the multi
threading
let's kill this
statement
and let's delete
everything
now
let's create
let's kill this as well
let's have a public
class
main
thread
then we will have a static method one
so public
static
void
thread
1.
then in this we will print numbers from
0 to 10
so 4
and
x is equals to 0
then x
less than equals to 10
then x plus plus
we will write
console
dot
write
line
thread
one
is
zero
comma
x
now when the value of r
x is not equal is equals to 5 then this
method should go to sleep for 6 seconds
so
we will have again if
x
is equal to equals to 5
then at that point this if statement
will send the thread
dot
sleep
for six thousand
now
let's write another set static function
i forgot to add space here
yeah
so now we will have
public
static
void
thread two
then we will have
a for loop
which will again print numbers from 0 to
10
so end
y is equals to 0
y less than equals to 10
and y
this will also have
console
dot
right
line
then we will have
thread 2
is
0
comma y
now
let's write a main method
so we will have static
public
void
main
now we will be creating and initializing
these threads
so first we will have thread
as
t1
equals to
new
then thread
for phrd1
then we will have another thread
t2
equals to
new
thread
for th rd
thread two
now we will start each of these threads
so t1 dot start
and
t2 dot
start
here what we are doing is we are
creating and initializing two threads t1
and t2
now using this thread class now using t1
and t2 start
we are basically starting the execution
of both of the sets now the both of the
threads are running simultaneously
what it will do is the processing of t2
will not depend on the processing of t1
like in a single threaded model
let's see how it will work
let's run this
now as you can see it has run thread one
from zero to five then it holded and
then it goes to zero
thread two
then it finished and after six seconds
this thread one is finished
this is the prime example for a
multi-threading function where
a thread one was started
when it went to sleep after this six
five sec x equals to five
it went for asleep for six seconds after
since it went to sleep a thread two
which was already running it started
printing out its result so it went out
its result
up to ten
by the time it finished this third one
was also back
so now it was starting running then it
finished its process and then the whole
both of the threads stopped running
so let's get started
let's open up google and search vs code
so vs code
we will pull up our first website
here we can choose which build we want
for our pc
you can decide it according to your
platform since i am using windows i will
be downloading windows installer
i will save it on desktop let it
download
let's open
we will run it
now it will ask for the permission
we will agree to the agreement
then next
we will leave the default destination
location as it is
then next
next we will create a desktop icon
we will add these board as well
and next
and then we will install it will take
some time to install
let's launch this visual studio code
it will take some time for it to open
we will start by going to extension
here we can use what languages we want
to code in
since i like to code in c sharp so i
will be using that so i will search for
c sharp
i will go for the first option and click
install
and we will also install
code runner
this helps in running the code much
faster
c-sharp is still installing
we will set the color theme
dark
let's close this
now to get started
we will create a folder
let's write it hello world
we'll open it and in the search bar we
will type in cmd
this will open command prompt in this
folder
now we will be using dotnet for the
c-sharp codes
so you have to install.net cores sdk
you can check the version
like this
latest visual code studio only support
dotnet framework 5 so you need to
install dotnet framework 5 since it is
the only version which is supported by
latest visual studio code
now
we will create a project
in this folder
so.net
new
console
this will create a project in this
folder
now since you can see in this folder
there are several files which have been
opened
now to open the visual core studio we
will type in code
and space period
and this will open visual code studio in
this project
we will open program.cs from this place
and here it is our basic program
let's change some text
hello world
i am
web
let's run this code
there's a possibility for the first time
working you might have to build some
assets
so you will you may be prompted by this
so you will click yes
let's try and run it again
as you can see it is printing it
correctly
now
let's get back to our slide now let's
start with what is entity framework
an entity framework is a free and open
source object relational mapper that is
orm that allows dotnet developers to
interact with databases using dotnet
objects
it allows developers to deal with data
using domain specific objects rather
than the underlying
database tables and columns where the
data is kept
when working with data developers may
work at a higher level of abstraction
with the entity framework allowing them
to construct and manage data oriented
systems with less code than a
traditional program
it also eliminates the requirement for
most data access layers
that developers typically have to write
now after understanding c-sharp entity
framework let's discuss what is the need
for an entity framework
first an orm is an entity framework and
the goal for the orm is to boost
developers efficiency by minimizing the
number of duplicate tasks in the program
next
if you are inquiring
we may use link to entity to specify our
queries against the domain of the object
then entity framework will run the
required query in the database and then
materialize the results into domain
object instances for use with the app
at last we have entity framework that
can construct and execute the
appropriate database commands for
reading or writing data in their
database
now let's go over the features
of c sharp entity framework
first we have cross platform
an entity framework core is a
cross-platform framework that may be
used on windows linux and mac
next we have modeling
an entity framework generates an edm
that is entity data model based on plain
old clr object entities with get set
data types attribute
it employs the paradigm querying and
saving entity data to the underlying
database
after that we have query
an entity data framework
enables us to get data from the database
using link queries these link queries
will be translated
by the database provider into the
database specific query language that is
sql for the relational database
an entity framework also enables us to
run row sql queries on the database
then we have change tracking
an entity framework maintains track of
changes to instances of entities
property values that must be published
to the database
then we have
saving
when we call synxchanges function an
entity framework performs the insert
update and delete commands to the
database based on the changes that
occurred to the entities
the
asynchronous save changes async function
is also available in an entity framework
after that we got concurrency
entity framework by default employs
optimistic concurrency to prevent
another user from overwriting
modifications
made when data is retrieved from the
database
next we have transaction
an entity framework streamlines
transaction management when requesting
or storing a data
it also allows you to personalize the
transaction management
after that we have caching
an entity framework comes with first
level of caching
by default as a result repeated queries
will return data from the cache rather
than the database
then we have built-in conventions
an entity framework adheres to the
standards of configuration programming
pattern and contains a set of default
rules that set up the entity framework
model automatically
next we have configuration
an entity framework allows us to
configure the entity framework model by
overriding the default conventions with
the data annotation property or the
fluent api
at last we have migration
to establish or manage the database
schema entity framework provides a set
of migration commands that can be
invoked on the enu date package manager
console or the command line interface
next let's discuss the entity framework
architecture
now let's go over the entity data model
we have conceptual models we have
storage model
and mapping
let's discuss them one by one
first up conceptual model
the model classes and their connections
are represented in the conceptual model
the database design table has no bearing
on the conceptual model
next we have storage model
the database design model
contains the storage model which can
include
tables views store procedures
their associations and keys
at last we have mapping
mapping the information describes how
the conceptual model is transferred to
the storage model
next
let's try to implement this individual
studio
now let's try to create a new project
we will use asp.net web application
we will click on next
then we will name this
as
simply
learn
ef
then we will click on create
make sure you are using dotnet framework
4.7.2 and we will click empty
and create
will wait for it to create the project
now
we will
right click
on this and click on manage and you get
packages
we will go to browse
and search
entity
framework
work
and we will take this first one this
entity framework
we will install
the 5.0.0 version
so click on install
you click on ok
and i accept
and it is installed
now let's close this
now let's connect to a database
so for the server we will use
local db
then we will have
ms sql
local
tv
and for the database name
we will have
simply
learn
ef
db
and we will click on ok
we will wait for it to make the
connection to the database
it is asking us
to
create it because it does not exist or
maybe it exists but we don't have
permission to say it so let's create our
own
just click on yes
let's open it here we have table let's
try to expand but there are none
so right click on it
and
we will have a new
query let's write the query
so first we will go and write create
table
departments
first one we will have an id
and in parameter
which is also primary key so we will
have primary key
here
we will give it identity as attribute
then we will click comma
then we will have nam
and
for its
data type we will use and where care
of size 50
then we will also have a location
this will also be
an n where
a location
of size 15
next we will also create a table called
student
student
this will also have
an id as a primary key so let's copy
some of this
since we will be using the same kind of
thing so we will have id
we can have
the first name
ctrl c
ctrl v
then we can have
last name
make sure to add table here i forgot to
add it
that's right it was giving us those red
lines
then we can have a gender
this will also be an
of 50
then we will have a fees
and
then we will have a foreign key that
will be a department
id
[Music]
this will be an end
and
a foreign
key
[Music]
which references
departments
id
now let's try to insert details in these
queries i've already prepared some of
these details let's cop let me copy them
and here
we have our queries
let's go over them
one by one
so first we are inserting into
departments a value of engineer
and a location of block b as you can see
we have
we have already named these two
properties this id will be automatically
assigned
and if you look closely since we only
have 3 so it will go from 1 2 and 3.
now we have entries for the student
table
so now we will have first name
last name
gender the fees
and which department id it is given
so
for one we have this
engineering for three we have
love
oh sorry commerce then
for
two we have law
so let's run these
and as you can see one row is affected
one row
that means it has created the two tables
so let's refresh that and here you can
see two tables
so show data
we have this
for student show data
and we have these
let's close them
and
once build this solution
now we will right click here
and add
a new item
we will go to data
and select ado.net entity data model
we will name this one
as
student
model
then we will click add
we will select the first option from
database
we will click next
our database is already created because
we have already created so it is already
selected here otherwise you can
come here again and select on this new
connection
then we have we will we need to click on
yes
to save the connection settings in
web.config
let's change this
we will have it as
student
tv context
then we will click next
we are using entity framework 5.0
so we will select this and click next
here
we can expand on to this and we will
select both of these
then for the model
namespace
we can have something as simple as
student
models
then we'll click on finish
it will take some time to create it and
here we have
it is created
and this is
a student model this is what we call an
entity
data model
our entity is department
then in properties we have different
things as id name and location then in
navigation properties we have
a student which is also called
mapping of some sort
these properties are what we have as a
storage models
now
let's try to create a platform so we
will right click here we will click on
add a new item
we will go to web and select platform
we can leave the name as is we'll click
on next
let's close this references to make our
lives easier
now this is our
form
let's go ahead
and
go to view
and open
our toolbox
here's our toolbox
we will add something called grid view
that's right it is the decision part
and we also need
an
entity
data source
let's add this one also here
now
we will click on this design button
first let's build it
now we will go to design button
now
we will right click on entry data source
and click on show smart tag
we can either do that or we can just
simply click on this button
we will go to configure data source
we will choose student db context
default container as studentdb contacts
click on next
then we will select department
use this and then finish
then we will have this
and we'll click on auto format
we can choose any of these colors
i will go for the professional
and click ok
next we will choose our data source
and here we will click on
add new column select template field
and add it
for the header text we will name it
students
then click on ok
now we will add a template
and we will add something called
grid view
now we will click on edit bindings
we will go to custom bindings
we will write it as eval
and we will
put it as do that
and we will click ok
now
we will go to this
and we will end
template editing
now what we will do is we will right
click on this and go to properties
let me change the camera position
and here
if you go down here
then we have include
here we will put it as students
we will save it
now let's try and run it
it is opening on chrome
and here as you can see we have
each department by name then we have
location then we have a student tab
which will have
the different entries according to
the work
now let's close this and get back to our
slides further ado let's get started
with the discussion on what is asp.net
mvc
microsoft's asp.net mvc is essentially a
web design framework
and asp.net mvc integrates mvc design
elements the most recent agile
development principles
and methodologies and the greatest
component of the existing asp.net
platform
because it is built on top of asp.net
then developers may use practically all
of the asp.net capabilities
while developing the mvc application
asp.net npc is not something that was
created from the ground up it is a full
replacement for the regular asp.net web
forms
next let's discuss the need for asp.net
mvc
so when developing a web application
using asp.net mvc there will be no
illusions of state no page reload and no
page life cycle
another design aim for asp.net mvc was
to be extendable throughout the whole
framework so when we discuss views they
must be displayed by the specific sort
of view engine
the whole point of employing model view
controller design pattern is to keep
things separate
an mvc component
instantiate controllers so if you don't
like how mvc instantiate your controller
you can do it yourself
next let's try to implement crude
operations on asp.net mvc let me open my
visual studio
let's create a new project
we will make
an asp.net
web application
with the dotnet framework
so we will click next
then we will name this
mvc
group
make sure you choose dot net frame box
4.7.2
then we will hit clear
next we are asked which type of
template we want to use
so we will use mbc
next we will hit create
we will wait for it to create
and here we have
our first project
now let's try and connect to a database
we will connect to
our same local db
ms sql
local
tv server
we will name this
mvc crude
db
we'll click ok
it will take some time to create it
and now it is asking us
to
create it so let's create it yes
we go here
we check tables and there is none
so we will right click
and add a new table
we are waiting for its design to load up
first
we will name this one as student id
student id
then
next
we will have
student name
we will give this one
never card care50
then
we will have
student fees
this will be
int
then we will have
student city
and again we'll name it nav bearcat 50
we will also name this table
so we will copy this and name it student
now we will update this
to prepare for database
now this will create this table
so we will update database
and as you can see here the table is
created
we can refresh here
and as you can see here's the table
so table data
and there's none
let's close this
now what we want to do is apply crude
operations to this table
so it will automat when we enter it in
the forms it will automatically register
it to this table
now
we'll go ahead and right click here
and we will click on manage and you get
package
here we will install
entity framework
we will click on browse here it will be
searching
here the first one
will click on this and we will install
the five point open top version
click on install
click ok then i accept
and it's installed now
so now
we will right click here
and we will add
a new item
we will go to data and we will install
ado.net and creator model
we will click on add
we will select ef designer from database
if you click next it is already selected
let's make it
as tp context
next
we will choose 5.0
we will go ahead here
and select
the student table
and we will hit finish
it will take some time to create files
here
as you can see it has created an entity
data model
as
if you look at look here closely it has
created several files
let's see this one
and this is the file it has
automatically created its student.cs
which has the complete structure for the
class of all of this taken from directly
from the table
next
let's also check
our controller
this is our home controller this is a
default controller so as you might see
there are several
functions already here let's delete the
old functions
we'll click keep index so we because
we'll be making one of them anyway
delete these we don't need them
and for the index let's write them
so we will have the
list
of
data
equals to
underscore
context
dot student
dot
to list
then we will return
list
of
data
now to solve this
we will need to add a context file here
we see crew db context
underscore
context
equals to new
mbc
true db context
and that's it
you'll save this
next
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's create
an http
get
function
this will be
public
action
result
create
for this
we will only return
view
now
we will also create
let me make some space here
okay
now we will also create
an http
post method
and this method
will be again public
action
result
and this will also have
the same name
create
but
student
model
we will have
context
dot
student
[Music]
dot
add
model
then
we will have
underscore contacts
dot
save changes
and
view that
dot
message
is equals to
data
insert
successfully
then
we will return it
return
view
let's save it
let's add
all of the pro functions as well then we
will look at them together
and here
now
we have already created the create
function
now i added some more functions so first
we have edit function
this is an http get more and then we
have http post
here i basically
what i'm doing for the get part i'm just
asking for the student id
to recognize for which student i will be
updating the data
then
in the http post method i am basically
copying
what i am going to put in
the text box
of student city through the name student
fees
next we have detail function
this will basically give us the
information for that id
then we have delete function
this will be able to delete the site
record
now let's add
the view for each of these functions so
we will click on action result for index
we will right click on it and click on
add view
we will select mvc5 view we will click
add then we have this option for the
temp index mode
we will
put list because
we are trying to create list for the
index
for the model class
we will have student
db context s
and we will click on add
it's ask us
this file is already existing
let me show you why
let me cancel this we will do it again
if you go into the view folder
you will see
these view files these are the ones
which were already created earlier so
what we will do now when i will create
to replace it it will just simply
replace this index dot cs html
so
again we click on add view
we'll select this we'll click on add
we'll select list
for the model class we will use student
and for the context class this and we
will click on add
and yes we want to replace it
and it will be creating the new view for
us
let's try rebuilding it first i guess
there are some errors
we will rebuild this solution
and it succeeded
let's enable it
let's try it again
let's add view
mvc5 add
list
student
mvc chrome
then click on add then yes
and this is the view for the index
folder
now
let's go back to the home function
and let's create view for the create
we will right click on this create
we are going to add mvc5 and
now we will select create mode
for the model class we will use student
then we have db context for this one
let's add
and this is
for the
create function
now
let's go and make
one for edit
detail and delete
so i'll go add this
and
for edit we will use edit
model
student
and we will add
next
we will go for detail
we will add view
select add
for detail we will have details
student
there is an ad
at last we have delete
so we will add view for this
we will click on this add
then we will add delete here
then we have student then we will click
on add
now we have successfully created
a separate view for each of these
now
let's try and run it
it will open it in the chrome
let's wait for it to load up
and here is our
table
as you can see we have a create new
function button now let's click on this
and it's ask us
for details
let's give it 291
student name as
let's say my name thereby
student fees as around 20 000
and for the
city as
new york
let's hit click
and it has created
let's go back to our list and as you can
see
it is already here
let's create few more few more
so let's mark it as mark
on
id2
mark
student fee as
30 grand
39 grand
student city as
vegas
and hit create again
let's go back to list
and here we are
let's try hitting on edit
now let's try
to change this to 40 grand
and this
new
orleans
let's add it
and it has changed
we can also delete this
now let's get back to our slides
finally let's look at the final
takeaways to conclude this session
first up we have asp.net mvc that makes
it easier to add interactivity and
responsiveness to existing project
next we have asp.net mvc which gives you
complete control over produce html and a
clear separation of responsibility
following that we have direct html
control also implies improved
accessibility for established
conformance
and
developing web standards after that we
have asp.net mdc
is ideal for web applications that
require
assistance of large streams of developer
as well as web designer that require
high level of control over the
application's behavior
then
asp.net mvc simplifies complexity
management by splitting an application
into the model
the view and the controller
at last
asp.net mvc
improves
test driven development support that is
tdd
what are c sharp web services
a web service is a web-based feature
that is accessed by a web protocols and
used by online applications
web services aren't only for the dot-net
framework platform
these standards were created before the
debut of dot-net
and they are exposed utilized and
supported by companies other than
microsoft
web services across platform
which means that a service developed in
one language may be invoked by another
language written in an application
the sole prerequisite for using a
service is an internet connection to
send an http request
web services are triggered by other
programs
when html pages are displayed in a
browser for the end user
now after understanding the c sharp web
services
let's discuss the technologies that
support web services
first we have xml
then we have so
then we have wsdl then at last we have
uddi
now let's discuss each of them in detail
first
xml
web services just
specify the data
as a result the application that
understands the xml
in terms of programming language or a
platform can format the xml in many ways
next we have soap
soap establishes a communication between
services and the application
the wsdl provides a consistent
technology
for specifying web services to other
applications
at last we have uddi
utdi message the web service
registration using uddi
next let's try implement this individual
studio
now let's start by creating a new
project
we will go ahead and use asp.net web
application with the dot minute
framework in brackets
here if you come next
we will name this as
simply learn
web
services
then we will hit click
we will choose empty
and hit create
make sure you use the dotnet framework
4.7.2
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now let's create a web service
so i will right click on project name
i will add a new item
here we will search for a web service
asmx
that is this is
we will name this one
as
simply
learn
service
i will click on add
and here we have our first
web service
so to start with we have to allow a web
service to be called from a script using
asp.net as x
so to do that we need to uncomment the
following line so we will go ahead and
uncomment this line
next
we will go ahead and make our own web
method
so for the first method
let's make a public
sum
then in bracket i will have int
x
comma
int
y
then we will have
return
x
plus
y
now we have to make sure that we are not
using the same variables or the methods
again and again
so to make sure that we will add
something called a message name
so
and the brackets we will have
sum of
numbers
i forgot to add end here
now this is a complete web method
since a web service does not allow
method overloading so we need to use
message names
in case if we want to re-utilize these
variables
so let's create few more functions so i
will just copy this one
and paste
next i will have
difference
between
numbers
i will change this function name to
difference
and i will change it here
to minus
let's make a product
and a division as well
copy this
so for this one i will have
product
of numbers
i will change this
here
as
product
and here i will have
for this one i will have division
for the message name
we will again have
division
name
then
here
now let's save it and run it
here wait for it to run
now we are waiting for chrome to load up
this service
and here we have
first web service page
if you look closely we are using
temporary.org
as its default name space
we can change the different name space
using xml web services if it is made
public
so now let's check our service
description it is basically a formal
description
which has a complete web-based data
now let's go back and work on our
function
these are the functions which are auto
ordered according to the names
if you check its message name we have
different
this
part is basically to specify we have
made spaces between these words
so if we don't make spaces
this will not show
now let's run one
each of them one by one so we will go
with difference
here let's add
23
then we can have 13
let's invoke it
and as you can see we are getting 10.
next
let's close this one and go back to our
complete list we'll go to division
let's make it
30
and divided by 3
we'll invoke it we are again getting 10.
then we can go
to product
we can go for
200
multiplied by 20. this value was 4000
as you can see we are getting 4000
we can go for sum
we can add any random number here
for the sum
so let's select for x so any number
then for the y we can choose any number
and we will click and go
and as you can see we are getting this
number
so now let's get back to our slides and
continue with our slides
now let's go over the advantages of c
sharp web services
first we have the open text-based
standard is always used by web services
all of those components are used by web
services
even if they are built in different
languages for different platforms
the web services are simple to develop
yet closely since they rely on existing
infrastructures and we can repackage
most of the applications as web services
web services is an interoperable
organization with hundred suppliers that
prefer
interoperability
web service encourage a modular approach
to development so that the various web
businesses can connect with the same web
service
web services lower the cost of
enterprise application integration and
business to business interaction
now let's discuss the disadvantages of c
sharp debt services
if we employ a web service for high
performance situation then the web
service will get sluggish
to describe the quality of certain
online services we use a consistent
process the vendor's ability to keep the
intellectual property of a given
standard is also a restriction of the
web service
finally let's conclude this session with
a few pointers on web services
first web service isn't really reliant
on any one language
next a web service a protocol agnostic
that is it does not rely on any protocol
then we have a web service is a platform
agnostic as well that is it does not
rely on any platform
finally we have stateless architecture
which refers to web services
these services rely only on the
information provided
now without any further ado let's get
started with the first topic and try to
understand what a web api is
an application programming interface is
a set of sub-routine definitions
protocols and tools
for developing software and applications
in computer programming
api is an interface with a set of
functions that allow programmers to
access specific features or data on an
application operating system or other
services
as the name implies web api is a
web-based api that can be accessed via
the http
protocol
it is a concept rather than a technology
we can create web apis using various
technologies such as java dot net and
others
for example twitter's rest api
provides programmatic access to read and
write data allowing us to integrate
twitter's capabilities into our
applications
we will now look at asp.net web api and
after understanding what a web api is
the asp.net web api is an extensible
framework for creating http based
services that can be accessed in various
applications on various platforms such
as web windows or mobile etc
it functions similarly to an asp.net mvc
web application
except it sends data as a response
instead of an html view
it functions similarly to a web or wcf
services
except it only supports the http
protocol
we will now look at some of the
characteristics of a c-sharp web api
after understanding what it is
the first feature of asp.web api
is the asp.net web api platform is ideal
for developing restful services
second
the asp.net web api is based on asp.net
and supports the asp.net request
response pipeline http verbs are
translated into method names by asp.net
web api
the following features of asp.net web
api are the asp.net web api accepts a
wide range of response data formats
json
xml and bs on
format support is pre-installed
the fourth characteristic is iis
self-hosted or any other web server that
supports dotnet 4.0 or higher can host
asp.net web api
finally the last characteristic is the
asp.net web api framework includes a new
http client for communicating with the
web api server
http client can be used on the server
side of asp.net
mvc and windows form console labs and
other apps
next we will discuss
c-sharp web api
versions
the first version of web api is web api
1.0
it supports dotnet framework 4.0
then it coincides with asp.net mvc4 and
finally it supported the 2010 visual
studio version
the second version of asp.net web api is
the web api 2.0
which we are currently using
the dotnet framework it supports is
dotted framework 4.5 and it is
compatible with asp.net mvc5 and the
visual studio 2012 and 13.
following that we will look at the
differences between asp.net web api and
wcf which stands for windows
communication foundation
the windows communication foundation wcf
formerly indigo
is a free and open source runtime and
set of apis in dotnet framework for
developing connected service oriented
application
the first difference between web api and
wcf is that web api is open source and
includes the dotnet framework whereas
wcf does not
the second distinction is in web api
the http protocol is supported whereas
the wcf support the http tcp udp and
custom transport protocol
the following distinction
that
web api supported the mapping of http
verbs of methods whereas wcf did not it
is attribute based programming model
that is being used
the fourth distinction is that with
asp.net mvc
asp.net use a routing and a controller
concept and wcf contracts for service
operation and data
the next difference is that the baby pi
does not support reliable messaging or
transaction whereas wcf supports
reliable messaging and transition
the next distinction is in web api
the html configuration class can
configure web apis but not web
whereas in wcf use of web to set as of
service configuration and attributes
the final difference is that wave api is
ideal for
creating restful services whereas
restful services are supported in wcf
but with limitation
next we will look at when to use windows
communication foundation
the first reason is that if you are
using dotnet framework 3.5 then we use
wcf web api is not compatible with
dotnet 3.5 or lower
next
we select wcf when using wcf if your
service needs to support multiple
protocols such as http tcp and named
pipes
following that we choose wcf if we want
to build services that adhere to ws star
standards like reliable messaging
transaction and message security
finally if you want to use the request
reply one way or duplex message exchange
patterns then we go with wcf
following that we will look at when to
use asp.net web api in this tutorial
so the first reason to use web api when
selecting web api is if you are using
dotnet framework 4.0 or higher
the second reason to use web api is when
web api is the way to go is if
you only want to build a service
that supports http protocol
when creating restful or http based
services we choose asp.net web api
the final reason to use asp.net web api
is when we are choosing web
api which is similar to asp.net mvc
now
we will look at the practical
demonstration of c-sharp web api
we will start by creating a new project
we will use
asp.net core wave api
we will name it
emp
api
next
we will use dotnet 5.0
and create
then we will install a new get package
called microsoft dot entity framework
core dot sql lite package
so we will go to manage and you get
package we will browse
microsoft and td framework for
sqlite
we will install the latest version which
is compatible with our 5.0
and install
we'll press ok
i accept
and here the package install we can
check it in the dependency framework
and packages
now let's get started with the coding
first we will create a models folder to
store the schema for this project
so we will right click on emp api
and then we will add
a new folder
called
models
then first we will create a class file
so add
class
it will be a class and we will name it
employee
add
we will start by creating different
properties
first we will create
a public
and
emp
id
and we will get
space
set
this will be a unique identifier so we
will decorate it
with key
this key
needs
a special directory
we will add
system dot component model dot data
annotations then we will add
other properties
such as
public
string
name
get
and
set
then another one public
string
department
and that
set
and
another one
for the address so public friend
address
okay
and set
now the entity framework core also
requires a contest object class
a context object allows querying and
saving data so we will make another
class in models folder
so we will add class
and we will name it
employee
context
trailer
we will first
inherit the db
context
now
we will write an object which will be
the configuration for this context
so
public
employee
context
db
context
options
employee
context
options
this will inherit the base class
options
we will write database
dot
ensure
created
this will ensure that the database is
created through db context
now we will acknowledge the db set so
public
db set
employee
employees
get
and set
now we will update the configure
services in startup.cs
so we will go startup cs but first of
all we will delete this by the
broadcast files
and
this weather forecast controller
since they might interfere with our
project later on
so in the startup.cs
we will go to the configure services
here we will add
services
dot
add
db
context
employee
context
then in bracket
oh
equals to greater than
o dot sqlite
data
source
equals to
employees.baby
with this the entity framework is done
now we will make a repository a
repository is an abstraction layer
between our application and data access
layer which is in our case the employee
context
so now
we will create
a new folder
and name it repositories
we will add
an interface in this
we'll name this interface as i
emp
repository
and add
this interface will represent the
operations which we will be performing
on the database
so we will start with
task
i
inaudible
employee
okay
this task will retrieve all the employee
entries in the system
now another task
employee
get
with an argument
and
emp
id
this will retrieve a particular employee
entry
now let's write a task to create an
entry
so
task
employee
create
with argument
as employee
employee
this will create the entries
now task
employee
now
update
employee
this will update the current
entries
and at the last we will add task
delete
and an argument
and
emp
id
now we will create a class employee
repository to add implementation to
these approaches
so add
a class
and we will name it
employee
repository
now this employee repository will
inherit
interface
i
e and p
repository
we will implement this interface
we will write
a public
employee
repository
employee context
context
and we will have
underscore context
equals to
context
now
we will write implementation
for the create method
so underscore
context
dot
employees
dot
add
employee
and then
we will add a bet method
so await
context
dot save
changes pressing
and we will add
a same keyword here
now
and now we will return
employee
now
let's write code for delete
first we will use find sync method or db
set to find the entry
so
var
employee
to
delete
well equals to
await
underscore
context dot employee
dot
find
a sink
for emp
id
now we will use remove method of db set
to delete this entry
so
context
dot
employees
dot remove
employee to delete
then we will update
underscore context
dot
save
changes async
and we will add
async keyword
to this
now we will write
get function
here we will use two list assigned
method of db set to show all the entries
so we will just write return
await
underscore context
dot employees
dot
to list
async
and we will add async keyword
now we will write get method with an
argument
so now we will use find sync method to
find the specific entry
so we will write return
await
underscore context
dot employees
dot
find async
with an argument
emp
id
and we will add sn keyword in this task
as well
now we will write update function
so
context
dot entry
of
employee
dot state
is equals to
entity
state
dot modifier
then i will avoid
context
dot
save
changes async
and we will add
async
here now let's update the configure
services in startup cs again
so here
i will write
services dot
add
scope
i
e
mp repository
coma
employee
repository
and with this the repositories are also
finished now we will create a web api
controller
an api controller is a class that is
responsible for handling requests at
endpoints
so
let's close all these files
now
let's go to controllers
and add a controller
this will be an api controller
which will be empty
and we will add
api controller empty
and we will name it
employees controller.cs
and
here
this root method
defines the path where this program will
end
and
a controller is inherited from
controller base
so now
since this controller will need an
instance of book repository to interact
with database
so we will write
public
employees
controller
and give it the i
emp repository
ap repository
we will also add
the repositories
now we will create
a repository
now we will inject the book repository
in this constructor
now let's write methods which will
handle specific http request
and these methods are called action
methods
we will start with
a decoration tag
http
cat
public
async
task
hi innumerable
employee
that
employee
and i will return
await
underscore
emp repository
dot
cat
here we are using get method to get
employee data from employee repository
now let's create new method also called
getbox
we will decorate it
with
an http tag
yet
but this time
with an argument in curly braces
which is our emp id
so public
async
task
action result
employees
and new method
get
employees
with the argument as
and
emp
id
and we will return
await
underscore
emp repository
let's implement a posting method for an
employee entry
this will create
an employee entry in the database
so
we will have
an http
post
decoration to it
this means it will handle all post
related http request
so we will start with public
async
task
action result
employees
post
employees
which will take
from body
which will be employee
employee
so now
we are
new
employee
will equals to
await
dot underscore
emp repository
dot
create
in bracket employee
now we will use the create method to add
the employee entry
so we will return
with
created
at action
in bracket
name of
cat employees
comma
new
amp
id
equals to
new
employee
dot
emp
id
comma
new
employee
now let's write a method to update an
existing employee entry
so this time
we will decorate
the http
with post
repeat
now let's write a method to update an
existing employee entry
so
we will have
an http tag
for put
now public
async
task
action result
and
put
employees
with argument as
emp id
comma
then from body
it will take
the data set
employee
now
we will have to make sure that argument
emp id is the same as the one in payload
otherwise it will return a bad request
so we will check it by if
emp
id
is not equals to
the employee
dot
empid
then
we will return
a bad
request
otherwise
we will avoid
underscore
emp repository
dot
update
employee
and we will return
no
content
now
let's write a method to delete the
employee entry
so this time we will decorate it
with http delete
this decoration will also have
an argument
in curly braces
it will has
an emp
id
so now
public
async
with action result
delete
argument
and
emp id
first we will check
if the employee entry is existing in the
database or not so var
employee
to
delete
is equals to
update
underscore
emp repository
dot
get
emp id
now if
it is not found then we will return not
found
so if
employee to delete
is equals to
null
then
we will return
not
found
otherwise we will delete that entry
so
await
underscore empld
dot delete
with argument
as employee to lead
dot
emp id
and then
we will return
no
content
let's try and execute this
as you can see here are all the
functions
now let's try to run get
so we will try it out and execute
as you can see it has no set
so now let's try and insert something
let's try out
we will give it
the one
for the name
we will try
josh
for department
we will use it
and for address
let's use
las vegas
let's execute it
it is working right
now let's try
to again check
and here it is
it has been recorded
now let's try to
to add another value
so now we will change this emp
to two
name
to rahul
department
engineering
and address
to be india
let's execute this
now let's try
to get this
and here it is we have two entries now
let's try the put method
this will update
the values
so let's try
here
let's
update the entry number two
we will copy
this data
from here
and
replace it
with this
now let's change
the address from india
and write it more defined as new
delhi
now let's execute this
and let's try
the get method
for
this particular number
so number
two
and execute
and here it is it has changed we can
also try it in our initial get method
will execute it and here it is also
changed
now let's try
to use
a delete method
we will use try it out and we can delete
number two
now let's execute
and it has worked success now let's try
to access
these entries so execute
and here it is we are only getting the
first emp id equals to one
and that's all for this demo
let's get back to our slide now let's
start with what is c sharp rest api rest
is an acronym that stands for
representational state transfer
rest is architecturally styled for
distributed system based on ideas
refining and addressing network
resources
http is used to communicate between
restful services where http stands for
hyper tax transfer protocol
the rest systems communicate with
external systems using uri identified
web resources where uri stands for
uniform resource identifiers
after understanding the c sharp rest api
let's discuss http verbs
the restful web api relies heavily on
http verbs
post get
put and delete are the most typical http
verbs used for crude that is create read
and delete
and update activities
now let's discuss each of them in detail
first we have post
if we need to insert data into the
database then method
the method
must be defined as the post method we
decorate this method with http post
method
next we have get
retrieving data or information is
possible through get work
we decorate a method with http get to
define a get method
then we have put
if we need to update or modify the data
in the database then the method must be
defined as the put method we decorate
method with http port to define a put
method
at last we have delete
if we need to delete the data in the
database then the method must be defined
as the delete method
we decorate method with http delete tag
to define as the delete method
next let's have a look at some http
status codes
there are five types of status quo
series
first the hundred series
this represents the information status
codes
after that we have 200 series this
represents success status codes
fine after that we have 300 series
that represents the that redirecting
status codes
then we have the 400 series which
represent the client side error status
scores
at last we have
the 500 series will represent the server
side error status code
now our main focus will be on success
client and server error only
so let's have a look at three of them
first up 200 series
at number 200 we have ok status
then at 201 we have created
at 202 we have accepted at 204 we have
no content
next we have 400 series which is client
side error status code so at 400 we have
bad request letters
at 401 we get unauthorized status
at 403 we get forbidden at 404 we get
not found
next we have 500 series which is
which represent
server side error
at 500 we have internal server error
at 501 we get not implemented fiber 3 we
are getting service unavailable and at
504 we get a gate away
timeout next let's discuss the
constraints of c sharp rest api
constraints of c sharp rest api
there are five constraints for this
uniform interface
stateless client server
cache level and layered system
let's discuss each of them in detail
first up we have uniform interface
the uniform interface requirements
specify how client and server must
interact
it simplifies and decouples the design
allowing each component to evolve
independently
next we have stateless
a single client can send many requests
to the server but each request must be
independent
each request must contain all of the
essential information for the server to
interpret and process
in this situation the server must not
save any client state information
such as sessions
and only these data should only remain
on the client
then we have client server
the uniform interface separates clients
and server because of this separation of
concern
clients for example are not concerned
with data storage which stays internal
to each server improving the mobility of
client programs
then
servers do not care about the user
interface or user status allowing them
to be simpler and more scalable
after that
we have cacheable
since multiple clients visit the same
server and frequently request the same
resources these responses must be cash
to save wasteful processing and
considerably increase speed
at last layered system
normally a client cannot know whether it
is connected directly to the end server
or through an intermediary
in turn intermediary server can improve
system scalability by facilitating
load balancing and providing shared
caches
layers can also enforce security
policies
now these were the constraints for
c-sharp rest api
so now let's try to implement them with
the help of a project
this will be our end result for this
demo
now let's go to our visual studio
we will use asp.net core web api
resist nest we will name it student
rest
api
then we will click on next
make sure to remember which dotnet
framework version you are using
since we will be installing some
packages which will be only available
for certain versions
since i am using 5.0 so i will be only
installing packages which are compatible
with the 5.0 framework
let's hit the create
this will take some time to create a
project
now
let's install
some packages so we will right click
here
and
select manage and new get packages
we will go to browse and search
microsoft
entity framework dot tools
we will select this
we will use
since we are using 5.0 so we will only
be using
the version starting with 5.0
so i selected this and i hit install
click ok and accept
we'll wait for it to install
then we will go
and install
ntd framework dot co
we will also install it
as 5.0.10
here click on install
click on ok
ixr
here if i wait for it to install
we have tools installed
and
we also have
our microsoft entity framework core also
installed we also want to install
dot sql
server
we will use this
to interact with the server to make a
database
we'll click ok and i accept
and it's installed
we are closed that
we also want to make one folder
so we will go to add
and click
on folder
we'll name it models
now
now let's start by creating a class file
we will go to this we will go to add and
click on class
we will name this class
as students
if you click on add
now we will write
the members for the student class
we will start with public
and
student
id
we will give it get
set
as the method functions
then we will have public
string
as
first
name
we will give a chat
and set
similarly we will create
public
string
last
name
we will give it get
set
then we have
public
string
email
will give it get
set
then we have
public
we will also use
an enum called gender
we will be defining this later on
so gender
get
set
so now public
and
we have a department id as well
this will also have get
and set functions
then
we will have one last member
as public
string
photo part
we have
cat
and set
we will save this
now let's create the enum gender
so we will right click here we'll go on
add
and select class
we will name it
as
gender
now add
we will remove class from here and make
it enum
then we will go here and type in
members as male
then we also want females
and we can also have others
let's save this
now if we go to student class
you can see gender is now green which
means it is representing an enum
as you can see
so now let's create
and db context file
so we will go to models right click here
add
a class
we will name this one as app
db
context
we will add
now to save up some time i will add in
the pre-bake code
here's some pre-bread code
as you can see we are getting some
errors so let's rectify them first
first let's consider db contacts
we'll press ctrl period to check
what we can what's the problem
since we didn't include the
microsoft entity framework code so it's
giving us this error so we will include
it
and it's it removed db context error
we are not getting any other error
anymore now
so let's save it now let me go over the
different
so at start we are using
we are inheriting this appdb context
class from db context
which is the part of entry framework
core
what this lets us is use db set
which will help us in creating the on
model builders to create a table
so
now
let's start with our table
for the first member we have a student
id we have given it a student id 1
first name last name email database
gender
department id and photo path
similarly we are also giving using the
model builder we are giving
to student 2 sam matthews then model 3
christina frost then model 4 racial
stone
now next we have to create an entity
framework layer which we can create
using repository but before that we need
to include this db context in our
startup file
so we will go to startup file
we will go to services configure
services
we will type in services
dot add
db
context
then we will add f
db
context
then we will have
here has
options
equals to
options
dot
use
sql server
then
you will have
configuration dot
get connection string
then in bracket we will have
db connection
now we will rectify this error so for
fdb context we will include student rest
reply models
and for use sql server we will include
microsoft entity framework core
we also need to
go to our app settings jazz json
and add
a connection string
so
we will add
connection string
db
connection
then we have server
to
local
db
then mss
ql
local
db
database
equals to student db
trusted
connection
equals to
true
let's save this
let's go to our student.cs
now our entity framework is now complete
now we will create a repository an
abstraction layer
between our application and data access
layer
which in our instance is app.tb context
but before that let's create a server
so we will go
to
view
and open other windows and select
package manager console
here
we will type in
add
dash migration
initial
create
this will build up our server
and build succeeded
we can
enable it
now
we will update
now we will update a database
so we will type in update dash data
and hit enter
this will initiate build starter and
will succeed
as you can see we have got a new folder
as migration here
let's close intellicode
and we can close the package now
now let's go ahead and create
an interface
so we will go
new item
interface
we will name it
i
student
repository
and we will add
will make it public
we will start
with task
i
innumerable
in that we will have students
and
then we can have search
with arguments as
string
name
comma
gender
within question mark
small gender
then let's have some more
functions as task
students
get
student
and
student id
then we have
task
as
i in a miracle
student
get student
we also have
a task
student
cat
student
by
email
with the argument as
string
email
then we have task
student
as ad students
next we will add
task by the name update student
and we will pass in
student
student
at last we have task
as
delete
student
we'll pass on
an argument as student id
so that when we will pass
and student id in this release student
function that will delete that entry
let's save it
and see if there are any error
they are not
so now let's make an class
called
student repository
now to save up some time i will add some
pre-bid code
here's our code for a student repository
let's go over
let's go over each function
first we have add student this function
is responsible for creating as entry
in
the database
then we have delete student
it is getting an error so let's rectify
it first
we will click on control period
it's asking us to include ntd framework
let's add it
and it has removed
in the first statement it is requesting
student id from us
when we provide the student id it will
compare it
if it's not null then it will find the
student id
and remove that result
and then it will save the changes
then we have get student by id
so we will provide the id then it will
basically
print that student
then we have student
get student by email where it is email
so it will just
take the email from us
and compare the database with the email
and provide us
the result for the same
then we have get student
this will
basically list
each and every entry in the database
then we have search
this will ask for us ask us for the name
and the gender
then it will basically search
if those two things are available
the entry which have both of these
common
it will list out all of them
here we have
search
which will ask us for the name and the
gender
it will basically compare each and every
entry for both of them
and give us
the common
common list between them
next we have update student
this function is responsible for
updating entries in a function
however this will not be able to change
the student id of a person
and that's it let's save it
we also want to add scope
of these in the startup so let's go to
startup
we will go here we will go services
dot add
scored
i
student
repository
comma
student
repository
let's save it and with that the student
repository part is over
now we will construct a rest api
controller
so we will go to controller we will
right click here we will add a
controller
we will select an empty
we will name this controller
as
students
controller
let's add it
now to save up some time i will add the
pre-baked code
now let's start
with this code
first we will remove some error so we
will control period
it's asking us to include these models
then we have
an error here so we will add some http
now let's go over
each function one by one
so first we have search
http
so for the search it is asking us
for a name and a gender as argument
if you look closely we are using try and
catch functions
so that
we will be handling the exception
easily so that if any error occur the
whole database don't go corrupt
so in the try we are getting result for
each entry which have
the name and the gender given in the
argument
if result if any then we will give an ok
status and print out the result
otherwise it will print out not form
now in case of any x exception like
internal server error
it will print out the error retrieving
data from the database
as you can see the status 500 internal
server error is simply http status code
500
then we have another http get function
it is get students
this will basically
return ok
and get
and print out all the students
or else if it encounters a 500 internal
server error then it will print out
error retrieving data from the database
then we have an http gate which will
basically ask us for an id and only
show us the entry representing that id
now
if the result is null then it will
return us not found
now in case an exception it will print
out error retrieving data from the
database
next we have an http post request this
is and create student request so it will
be responsible for creating new entries
so let's say if student is null
basically the end we didn't provide any
entry
in the
during the time of creation so it will
just give us a bad request
now in case if we are providing
a valid entry but
we have
the email already stored
in our database
so it will say student email already in
use and it will give a bad request again
now in case everything it goes by
smoothly then it will create the student
and it will automatically provide an id
to that student
now there could be an exception so then
it will give us 500
internal server error
which will return as error creating new
student record
now
as you can see we are already giving the
bad request so when will this occur so
basically if none of the criteria for
the above matches
and it still gives us an error then it
will automatically redirect it
to an error creating new student record
next week we have http report this will
be
responsible for updating student data
so first it will ask us for an id it
will compare this id if student id
is
does not match with the data we are
trying to
update
then it will give us a bad request
if it gives us the right request but
the id does not exist then it will give
the student with this id does not found
if everything goes right then it will
just update the
method in case if still some error
occurs then it will print out error
updating student record and it will give
us 500 internal server error status
then we have delete
for this it will always request an id so
that it doesn't go and delete whole
database
now if
an id doesn't is not present then it
will say id not found
otherwise it will delete that id
and if we print out student with this id
is deleted
now in case
some error occur otherwise then it will
gives us a 500 internal server error and
gives us error deleting world record
now let's go ahead
and save it
and run this
as you can see we are using a swagger
interpreter
so let's
use this function first
let's try it out and execute
and as you can see it is printing out
every entry
from student id one akash
is zoom in
sunday one one akash guptas simply
run.com and all that
then we have sam matthews and have we
have christina first then we have racial
stone
now let's say
we want to add
a new entry
let's copy this
such a sample
let's try it out
we don't need student id here because
the system will give it its own
for the first name
let's add my entry so let's add that
then we have for the last name
kendall
then for the email
let's get a web hub
at the right simplylearn.com
then for the
date
let's add 1998
let's leave everything else as it is
for the gender it should be 0 0 for the
meal
then we have department id as 2
and for the photo path
we can give it as images
slash
webhub
dot png
now let's execute
and it has basically worked so to check
that
we will again go
and use our getting
we have executed and as you can see it
has our fifth entry student id five
bravo hundred wall
so we have tried our post we have tried
our get
let's use our search one as well
so to try it out
we need to give it a name so let's
search the latest entry we created so
wherever
for the gender we have zero
and for the path
we can give it
let's give it email id so where the
at the right
simply learn
so let's execute
and as you can see it is giving us this
entry
so
we have used get that we have used post
now we have this get method with the id
let's write this one as well
uh let's search for the third one
and it is giving us the christina that's
the fifth one which we just made and it
is giving us the weather
so after that let's try update an entry
let's try it out
let's do
one which is was mine
we can remove the student id
for the first name
let's change it to
let's make it simpler
simply then for the last name
we can have
learn
as email
it can have
simply learn
at the rate
simply learn
dot net
we can
let the data part be same
let's give it two
cents for others
department id
for
photo part
images
slash
simply
dot png
let's execute this
if a success
it says student id mismatch
i
maybe we have to
give the student id
copy here
let's give it
an execute
and it works right
so to check it
we can simply go
to get api with id and execute
and as you can see it has changed the
first name is simply last name learn and
email date of birth and everything
now
let's go ahead and delete an entry
to delete an entry we need to just give
it an id let's try it with the three
let's execute
student id with three is deleted
so to check that they can go here and
execute
now if you look closely
we have with akash then sam then we have
student id 4 ratio
we have lost the christina for first id
let's also try
for the fifth one which we made so five
execute
so indexed id5 is deleted
let's execute this
and it has lost the r as well
let's try to execute the 5 again
and it says not found
let's go back to our slides
now let's look at some of the takeaways
from this session
first
we have
rest api with serve as the interface and
communication between the client and the
server which takes place over http
then
we have
the rest api which also let's discuss
what is a gui
the graphical user interface gui is a
user interface that allows users to
interact with technologies by using
graphical icons rather than a heavy code
the graphical user interface invented by
xerox palo alto research lab in late
1970s and is commercially available in
apple's macintosh and microsoft's
windows operating system
the gui design pattern is based on the
model view controller software
architecture which separates the
internal information representation from
how information is displayed to the user
now let's get started with the demo
we will open the visual studio and
discuss various ui features available to
demonstrate gui
let's create a project gui demo
we will create the windows form
application project
so
windows
form app
dot net framework
we will click next
we will name it
gui demo
and create
it will take some time to be created
let's name this
as gui demo
let's start with the button
we will name it as
here
let's increase its size to 11.
let's run it
as you can see here is the button
right now it's it doesn't do anything
when we click it
let's close this and write up the code
for it
we will double click on it
and here the form one dot cs is
displayed
now we will write a code for it so we
will write message
box
dot
show
and we will type like welcome
to
[Music]
simply learn
and we will close it by semicolon
now let's run this
now when i click this button it shows
this box
with the ok button let's click the ok
button
and close it
now suppose i want to give it more
interactivity
so now
i will create a dialog box
dialog result
dr
equals to message box dot show
welcome to simply learn
let's change this text as well
and write it as
like
do you
want
to close
this
window
we can give it a confirm dialog box as
well
now we will use an enum which will be
the message
box
button
buttons dot
yes no
button
we will
and we will also use
message box
icon
dot questions to give it more icons
now we will make an if statement
to ask if we press yes then we will
cross this form so we will write
if
dr equals to dialog box dot result
is equals to yes
then
we will
write this dot
close
now let's run this
now when i click this button it will
show this box
now if i press no then it doesn't do
anything but just close that message box
now if i press yes
then it will close that form as well
now let's use more functions from this
toolbox
let's take some labels and textbox and
another button
so i will take a label
and name is a
username
i will increase its size
by 11.
let's copy and paste this
now i will change the name to
password
now let's add
now let's add a button
repeat
repeat
repeat
repeat
now
let's add some text box
we will increase their size
and
a button
i will name it
as sign up
and its size as 11.
now by default this text box takes
the text value
but in case of password text box we can
change it
we can change its password care as
anything we want
let's make it star
now when i run this code
here let me write like webhub
and for the password whenever i type
anything
it will show star
now
we can also change it
to a default
according to our
system so we will keep it simple and we
will use use system password care
and make it true
now when we run this
since my system is a windows operating
system so whenever write anything
in this password it will be typed as
a bold dot symbol
let's rename this click here as well to
close
since it performs a close operation
now let's add some more features
let's add some radio button
and a label
let this label be
gender
and its size
as 11
and we will change its size as well to
11
and its name
to
male
and this one to female
now let's run this
as you can see we can only select one of
these so it will give us the opportunity
to select either one of the option
now let's add a checkbox as well
i will increase its size to 11
and for the text
we will use
like
i understand
and
i
accept
terms
and
conditions
now
let's run this
as you can see we can write any username
here
and
password as well as we can choose either
male or female
and we can also click on this
now let's suppose i want
this button to be only a bill available
when
i click on this checkbox
so i will write i will go to this button
and
change the enabled
function
from true to false
now when i run this code
it shows as not enabled
now i want the functionality when i
click this check button it gets enabled
so
we will write the code for this checkbox
so button
to
[Music]
dot
enabled
is equals to
checkbox.chat
now
let's run this
so web hub
any password
i like i can select pl if you will and
when i click this this button gets
available
now let's suppose i have more radio
buttons
instead of the only these two
let's make space for that
let's add another
label
and i will name it as
payment
method
and size to be as 11.
and i will add
some radio buttons
i will increase its size to 11
same with this one
this one as well
now i will name this one
as
credit
slash
debit
card
this one
has net banking
and this one
as
paper
now let's run this code
now whenever i
make this code so let's let me write a
username and a password and let me
select mail
now whenever i go to select this payment
method it unselects the gender so
basically we can only create one of
these five radio button
now
to make them separate we need to use
containers
so
we will use
group box container
so group box
i can increase its size
i will remove the name group box format
and we will select these buttons and put
it in this group box
i will drag it here
same with this one so i will add another
group box
and add these in it
and also remove the name of
this group box
and
i will drag it to this one
now let's run this code again
let me save it and run
now
we have her
the password
then
i can now select male or female
and i can also select any of these
payment methods and when i click this
then i can select this sign up button
now for the sign up buttons
code
i will write as a message
box
dot show
and write
account
is
created
and
i will make this
dot close
let's run this
so now
i make
an account
password
then i select mail
and then in networking then click then
azure now account is created and it will
close this function
now let's get back to our slides one of
the fascinating topics of c programming
that is c-sharp applications
but first let me tell you that we have
daily updates on multiple technologies
so if you are a tech geek looking for a
latest technological advancement then
consider subscribing to our youtube
channel
and don't forget to hit the bell icon so
you never miss an update from simply
launch youtube channel
now to understand this topic we will be
creating a scientific calculator
but before we get into the code for the
scientific calculator we should first
understand what it is and why is it
essential
a scientific calculator is a calculator
that is designed to assist you in
calculating problems in science
engineering and mathematics
it has far more buttons than a standard
calculator which only allows you to
perform the four basic arithmetic
operations like addition subtraction
multiplication and divisor
all these extra buttons enable you to
work with variety of numbers and
problems
such as trigonometric problems
scientific numbers which can be divided
by 10 to the power of 10
pi problems
problems involving logarithmics
the fractional functions
and the probability functions
your scientific calculator has some
special buttons that will assist you in
writing your equations for example you
have a special button for scientific
number that automatically adds
multiplication by 10 to a specific
exponent
the exp button is one you are looking
for
you enter your scientific number first
then press the button and enter your
exponent value
you can use these buttons to calculate
the number to any exponent
and find the square root or cube root or
any other root when working with
engineering problems
you also have trigonometric buttons like
sine edge sine cos edge
so now without any further ado let's
open visual studio and begin with
scientific calculator code
first let's start with the code we have
added all the necessary namespaces for
this program initially
we are utilizing a system library in our
project
as indicated by using the system
statement
this includes classes functions
such as console class and rightline
functions and method
following that we have added
system.collection.generic
which contains
the interfaces classes that define
generic groups allowing users to create
strongly typed calculations
with higher type safety and performance
than non-generic strongly typed arrays
then we have added system dot component
model
which provides interfaces for
implementing component runtime and
design time behavior types
that are frequently used to include
system and component model
then we have system.data a dotnet course
namespace is the data namespace
all data providers use these classes
standard classes from this namespace are
dataview dataview manager dataset data
table data row data column and data
relation
next is the system drawing
this class contains methods for drawing
to a display device
then there is system dot link
it enables link queries by providing
various types of classes and methods
following that we have incorporated the
system dot text
this contains ascii and unicord
character encodings abstract base
classes for converting blocks of
characters to and from blocks of wide
a helper class for manipulating and
formatting the string objects without
generating intermediate string instances
next we have included a
system.threading.tasks
that provides types that simplify
writing concurrent and asynchronous code
finally we have included
system.windows.form library
windows form is a graphical user
interface class library that comes with
dotnet framework
and its primary goal is to provide a
more straightforward interface for
developing desktop tablet or pc
applications
it is also called known as winforms
then there is form1 a partial class with
the public access specifier
c-sharp has a unique feature called
partial classes it has a unique
capability of implementing the
functionality of a single class in
multiple files
which are then combined into a single
class file when the application is
combined
finally a partial keyword is used to
create a partial class
first we have initialized the component
function
in form1 class
in
visualstudio.net c sharp or vb.net the
initialize component method is a method
that is automatically created and
managed by the windows form designer and
defines everything you see on the form
then we have declared four more
variables
first of output and the first number of
double data types
then we have created a choice string
and a calc ptr
of bool data type
which is initially set to false
so for 0 to 9 digits we have event name
as button 1 click
then there is a condition that states
that if a text is equal to 0 or calcium
ptr is false then we clear the text box
then we use variable button of class
button there is another condition if a
text box does not contain a decimal
point then we can text any digit other
than 0 to 9 except the decimal point
otherwise we will add the decimal point
to our text
next we have a backspace button
namely the button 22
which which we use when we had end
integer variable which contains the
length of the text and we decrement end
by one and one removing all the text
written in the text box
if no no text is entered into the text
box the value 0 will be displayed
next
in a scientific calculator we have event
name button21 which adds the text as
zero
then we have an event for plus minus
button name button23
in which we have output variable which
converted double to a string as output
is declared double
initially then if the output is equal to
output multiplication to minus 1 which
means if the output is positive
then it will be negative and if the
output is negative then it will be
positive
then we have event button 24
click
where we convert the first number to
string
then we have choice assigned as a
operator button
and finally calc pdr is set to true
next we have a button 39 click event
where we have switch case for doing
button operations for plus minus
multiplication and division
where the first case adds the number
case 2 defines subtraction which
subtracts the value then multiplication
multiplies the value and divides and
divides the given
number following that we have a one
click event for the off button which is
used to exit the application
after that we have a button click event
for the logarithmic operation in which
we use the math library to convert our
outputs to log base 10.
following that we have button two three
and four click events for performing
signage course edge and 10 h operations
in our scientific calculator with the
math library
the specified angles of hyperbolic sine
cosine and tangent are then written
similarly we have even names as buttons
7 8 and 9.
these will perform the sine
cosine and tangent operations
the sine cosine and tan of the specified
angles are then written
the button 10 has a math click event pi
and it represents the circumference to
diameter ratio of a circle
as specified by constant pi
the next button five click event
contains the math dot power
which returns e raised to the power
to a specified number
then we have button 12 click
which has a math dot power of 2
which will give us the square of the
given number
following that
we have a click button 14 to reduce the
given output by one
then we have button 13 which has the
math tau of 3 which give us the cube of
the given number
following that we use the button 15
click event to perform the modulo
operator which returns the remainder or
signed reminder of the division after
one number is divided by another called
the modulus of the operation
then we have button 17 click event
this event uses the math.log library to
return the logarithmic of a given number
for like that we have button 18 click
which will give us the percentile of the
given output divided by the given output
multiplied by 100
and the last but not the least we have
event as button 19 and 20
click
which has match dot ceiling and math dot
floor library where mat dot ceiling
returns the smallest integral value that
is greater than or equal to the
specified number and math math.floor
which returns the most significant
essential value that is less than or
equal to the limited number is returned
now that we are ready to run this code
here is our scientific calculator which
includes the textbook
labels and buttons
now
let's run this code
here's our calculator
let's try to do some calculation
let's add 5 with 4
equals to which is 9
then let's take square root which is 3
then a cube which is 27.
now
let's try the off button if it will exit
us out of this calculator
and yes
it does
let's get back to our slide we will
learn to create a basic calculator using
c sharp
so let's get started with the demo we
will be using a visual studio to create
it
at the end of this tutorial you can
expect a calculator to look like this
we will be programming these buttons to
give an arithmetic capabilities to this
calculator
now let's get started with the
calculator let's move on to our visual
studio
we will start by creating a new project
by creating a project we will select
windows app form and then we will get
this window
let's change the windows label from form
1 to calculator
now we will start with adding some
labels to understand the gui
so we will start by getting a toolbox
you can get that from going to view
and selecting toolbox
here on search toolbox write label
we will use these labels
let's change the text
to calculator
and let's give it some color
highlight
and some font
like mono type cursor italic bold
and of size 20.
now
we will start by adding some more labels
the toolbox
label
this label
will show
the value 1.
we will increase its size to 12 and bold
we will make similar labels
by simply copy pasting
we will get three of these labels we
will change the second label
to value two
and the third label as output
now increase
this size
now
we will add some text box
this text box will be used to get inputs
for value 1.
increase its one size
from 8
to 12.
let's give it bold
okay
now we will copy paste the same text box
for value 2.
and we will add another text box for
output to get the output for this value
now let's add some buttons to showcase
the arithmetic capabilities
so button
we will have its size at 12
to show it better
and we will change the label
from button 1 to
plus
let's resize this stack button
let's give it bold as well
now we will paste this button to get
different buttons
one for the subtraction
one for multiplication
one for division
and one for percentage
let's change the name labels as well
minus
division
multiplication
and percentage
now let's start with some coding
we will first code for the button
plus
we will start with
getting some text from the value 1 and
value 2.
so
double
val 1
is equals to
convert
dot
2 double
text box 1
dot
text
here we are taking them as double to get
them the flexibility of decimal numbers
we will do that for the same for the
value 2 as well
so double
val 2
is equals to
convert textbook to dot text
now
double
and we will have sum
equals to
as val 1
plus
val 2
since these text box only recognize the
string values so we will have to convert
this sum from double to string
so
text box 3
dot text
is equals to
sum
dot
tostring
open parenthesis
now let's code for the negative one
we can just simply copy paste the above
code
because it will be almost similar
we will do some tweaks
for the difference
so
if
here we will get minus
and here it will change to f okay
let's do the same for the multiplication
division and percentage
sort of division
ctrl v
let's give it
division
um
let's do that for multiplication
product
your product
and at last
for percentage
it will be percent
here we will
group them
division
in bracket
and then multiply it with 100
to get the percentage
we will change the step to percent
now let's compile
and see if this code works
this will take some time
and here is our calculator
let's give it some values to check if it
works fairly
let's take 5
and 10.
let's do addition yes it is giving us 15
let's do a subtraction yes 5 minus 10 is
minus 5
a division it is 0.5 a multiplication
it's 50. a percentage it is also 50 so
let's take some other example let's
change the value to 200
and see
yes it is giving us 5 percent
now let's get back to our slides
and this was all for today's session
hope you guys found it informative and
helpful if you liked this session then
like share and subscribe if you have any
question then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click
here the c-sharp interview questions
then you have come to the right place
hey everyone welcome to our simply
learns youtube channel today we'll talk
about one of the exciting topics in c
sharp that is c sharp interview
questions and answers but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple technologies
so if you're a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
this tutorial video has 50 interview
questions and all these questions are
divided into three levels beginner
intermediate and advanced levels so
without further ado let's get started
with the first topic
now before getting into any interview
questions i would like to reveal the
first type of questions that are
recording interview questions it is
obvious that in any technical interview
you will be asked to code some or the
other program so we have bought the most
frequently asked top five coding based
questions in c which are write a program
in c sharp to reverse a string write a
program in c sharp to find if a given
string is a palindrome or not write a c
program to find the substring from a
given string write a c program to find
if a positive integer is prime or not
and lastly write a singleton design
pattern and how to implement them in c
sharp
so these are the most frequently asked
coding-based interview questions based
on c-sharp and if you want we would like
to share these quotes with you please
feel free to share us your email ids in
the comment section below so that we can
share you all these codes
now let's start with the beginner level
interview questions
so our first question is how the c
programming language differs from c
sharp programming language the first
difference is that the c programming
language allows for procedural
programming whereas c programming
language provides object oriented
programming
the second difference is that c
programming language supports pointers
whereas in c sharp pointers are only
used in unsafe mode
the third difference between c and c
sharp is that garbage collection is not
supported in c whereas in c sharp
garbage collection is handled by the
common language runtime or clr
the next difference between the both is
the c programming language is cross
platform in contrast the dotnet
framework is required to run on the
c-sharp language only
fifth difference between c and c-sharp
is we can achieve a low level of
abstraction using c programming language
whereas in c sharp we can achieve a high
level abstraction
the last difference between the both is
the c programming language is primarily
used in commercial industries and
engineering whereas c sharp on the other
hand is used for software development
and other network related goals
the second question is what is an object
and a class in c sharp
the answer for this question is a class
is a collection of properties and
methods used to represent a real-time
entity it is data structure that groups
all the instances into a single unit
whereas an object of a class is defined
as an instance technically it is simply
a block of memory that can be stored as
variables arrays or collections for
example the car is working as a class on
my screen and the objects are ford and
rd which are the car manufacturers
next is what are the fundamentals of
object-oriented programming
the answer for this question is the
object-oriented programming language or
oops in c sharp is divided into four
concepts that is encapsulation
abstraction
inheritance and polymorphism
let's take a closer look at each of the
four object oriented programming
concepts first encapsulation
encapsulation is defined as when an
object's internal representation is
hidden from the view outside its
definition it is said to be encapsulated
only the necessary information is
accessible while the rest of the data
implementation is hidden
next abstraction abstraction is the
process of identifying and eliminating
irrelevant details from the object's
critical behavior and data
following the oops concept inheritance
is the ability to create new classes
from existing ones it is accomplished by
gaining access to altering and extending
the behavior of objects in the parent
class
lastly we have polymorphism polymorphism
is defined as a name that means one name
many forms it is accomplished using
several methods with the same name but
different implementations
now we have the next question that is
what is the common language runtime or
clr so the answer for this question is
the common language runtime manages the
execution of dotnet programs clr the
just-in-time compiler translates
compiled code into machine instructions
this is the program that the computer
runs clr provides memory management
exception handling type safety and other
services now let's look at the next
question
what is managed and unmanaged code
so manage code is executed by clr common
language runtime on which all
application code is based the internet
platform because of this is regarded as
managed internally the dotnet framework
uses the garbage collector to clear
unused memory whereas unmanaged code is
any code executed by an application
runtime in a framework other than dotnet
the application runtime will handle
memory security and other performance
operations
next we have
what exactly is an interface
in c-sharp an interface is a class
blueprint it is like an abstract class
and that all the methods declared within
the interface are abstract it cannot
have a method in body and cannot be
instantiated instead it can be used to
achieve multiple inheritances that can't
reach
the following example demonstrates an
odd even class has access to both the
even and odd classes
now we have the next question
what are the different types of classes
in c sharp so the answer for this
question is there are four different
types of classes in c sharp the first is
partial class which states that its
members can be divided or shared across
multiple files the keyword partial
denotes it
the second class is abstract an abstract
class is one whose object cannot be
instantiated the only way to get the
class is to inherit it must include at
least one method the keyword abstract
denotes the abstract classes the next
class is sealed class a sealed class
cannot be inherited to access a sealed
class members we must create a classes
object then the keyword seal denotes it
the last and the fourth class in c sharp
is static this class does not allow
inheritance the classes members are also
static the keyword static denotes this
type of class the keyword instructs the
compiler to look for any static class
instances created by accident
now the ninth question
what is the difference between equality
operator and equals method in c sharp
the difference between the equality
operator which is double equals to and
equals method in c sharp is the the
double equals operator and the equals
method compare two values or reference
type data items
this answer explains the fundamental
distinction between two the comparison
operator is the equality operator and
the equals method compares the contents
of the string the double equals to
operator compares the identity of
reference whereas the equals method
compares the only reference
now we have the 10th question
explain code compilation in c sharp
the answer for this question is in c
sharp code compilation consists of three
steps the c compiler compiles the source
code into managed code putting the newly
created code together into assemblies
then the common language runtime is
being loaded and clr is carrying out the
assembly
now we have the 11th question what are
the differences between a class and
struct
the answer for this question is
the first difference is class can
inherit whereas struct cannot the second
difference is a class is passed by
reference type whereas struct is passed
by value type
the next difference is
class members are private by default
whereas in struct members are public by
default
the fourth difference is class is
appropriate for large complex operations
and objects though struct is appropriate
for small isolated models the last
difference between the both is we can
use a garbage collector to manage memory
in class whereas a struct cannot use
garbage collector and thus cannot manage
memory
the next question is what is the
difference between virtual method and
abstract method
virtual method is default implementation
of virtual process is always required it
can however be overridden in the derived
class though this is not required for
example the override keyword can be used
to override it
though an abstract method has no
implementation it belongs to the
abstract clause therefore derived class
must implement the abstract form
although an override keyword is not
required in this case it can be used
now the 13th question explain namespaces
in c sharp namespaces are employed in
organization of large code projects for
example in c sharp the most common
namespace is system we can create our
namespaces and use one namespace with
another known as nested namespaces
the keyword namespace is used to
identify them
following the c-sharp interview
questions and answers the next question
is what is the using statement the
answer for this question is the using
keyword indicates the program uses the
specified namespace as an example
consider system the system is a
namespace in this
context the class console is defined in
the system module so in our program we
can use a console.writeline and readline
now the next question is explain
abstraction one of the object oriented
concepts is abstraction it is used to
display only the classes essential
features and hide unnecessary
information
let us use a car for an example
a car driver should be familiar with the
vehicle's details such as color name
mirror steering gear brake and so on he
doesn't need to know about the internal
combustion engine and an exhaust system
as a result abstraction aids in knowing
what is required and concealing internal
details from the outside internal
information can be hidden by declaring
such as parameters as private and using
the private keyword the following
question is explain polymorphism
polymorphism in programming means the
same method but different
implementations it is classified into
two types compile time polymorphism and
runtime polymorphism the compile time
polymorphism results the call in compile
time polymorphism is also referred to as
static binding early binding and
overloading
the compiler does not resolve the
runtime polymorphism call and is also
referred to as dynamic binding late
binding or overriding
for example a man acts as a father a
husband and an employee all
simultaneously the next question
how is exception handling implemented in
c sharp in c sharp exception handling is
accomplished using four keywords try
catch finally and through
in try try contains a block of code that
will be checked for exceptions in catch
a program that catches an exception with
the help of the exception handler and
finally it is a block of code written to
run regardless of whether an exception
is scored or not and finally through
throw is when a problem occurs it throws
an exception
followed by exception handling we have
another question
that is what are the c sharp input and
output classes what are commonly used
for input and output classes
the system.io namespace in c sharp
contains classes used to perform various
operations on files such as creating
deleting opening closing etc
the following are some of the examples
of commonly used input output classes
which are file stream writer stream
reader string writer string reader part
etc
file aids to with the manipulation of a
file
stream writer is the class that is used
to write characters to a string
the stream reader is used to read
characters from string the string writer
is used to write a string buffer the
string reader is used to read the string
buffer the path is used to perform
operations on path information
followed by that the next question is
what is stream reader or stream writer
class the answer for this question is
the name space system dot input output
contains the classes stream reader
stream writer which are used to read and
write character 90 reader based data
members of stream reader are close read
and read line members of stream writer
are closed right and right line
there is an example on my screen where
you have code block to read and
a code block to write using stream
reader and stream writer
now the next question what is a
destructor in seashore destructor are
used to clear memory and free resources
in c-sharp however this is handled by a
garbage collector on its own internally
system.gc.collect is used to clean up
but it may be necessary to implement
instructors in some classes manually
the following is an example of vehicle
acting as a destructor using the tide
symbol
following the 20th question we have the
21st question which says what is an
abstract class
so the answer for this question is an
abstract class is denoted by the
abstract keyword and only be used as a
base class this class should always be
inherited it is impossible to create an
instance of the class itself if we don't
want any program to create an object of
a class we can make it as categories
abstract there are no implementations of
any methods in the abstract class they
must be implemented in the child class
here's an example that shows an abstract
as abs then the child as child class
that inherits the abs abstract class and
finally an object as c is one of the
accesses
the addition function via a new process
called submission
and abstract classes methods are all
implicitly virtual as a result the
virtual keyword should not be used with
any abstract classes methods they must
however be implemented in the child
class the next question is what is the
difference between boxing and unboxing
codes
boxing is converting a value type to a
reference type at the same time unboxing
is the explicit conversion of the same
reference type back to the value type
the following is an example val 1 is 50
which is going through boxing process
and val 1 is converted into object
boxing val which is then converted back
into an unboxing variable after the
boxing process
the following question is what is the
difference between continue and break
statement the break statement terminates
the loop it causes the program control
to exit the loop in contrast the
continue statement instructs the
program's power to go only to the
current iteration however it does not
affect the loop
the following is an example for break
statement in which the break keyword is
used to terminate the loop going from 0
to 10 immediately the continue block of
code is used to skip the current
iteration of two the final question for
the beginner level is what is difference
between final finally and finalized
blocks
final is a keyword that indicates that a
variable method or a class is
unchangeable to put it simply finally
like try and catch blocks it is used for
exception handling the final block is
always executed regardless of whether an
exception is released
this block is mainly used to close
database connections input output
resources etc lastly the finalized
method in java.lang protected method
object type it is passed down to every
java class you create therefore the
garbage collector thread calls this
method before removing an object from
memory
now we have reached the intermediate
level
the 25th question on our list is what
exactly is an adding so the answer for
this question is an array is a data
structure that stores multiple variables
of the same data type it is a set of
variables stored in a single memory
location here's an example of marks
array with five integer values 10 20 30
40 and 50. a single dimensional array is
a linear array that stores variables in
a single row the preceding example is a
one-dimensional array aries can have
multiple dimensions rectangular arrays
are another name for multi-dimensional
arrays we have a multi-dimensional array
as numbers with three rows and three
columns with one two and three in the
first row three four and five in the
second row and four five and six in the
third row now the next question is what
is a jagged array
a jacked array is an array with array
elements it is also known as an array of
arrays and can have a single dimension
or multiple dimensions here's an example
of jack arry a jagged array with four
rows
in the first row we have two values one
and two the next row contains values
three four and five and six the third
row includes three values seven eight
and nine and the fourth row contains
five values that is three four five six
and seven
now the next question name some
properties of aries
an array has following properties that
is length this function returns the
total number of elements in an array
size this indicates whether the array's
length is fixed or not
read only this indicates whether the
array is read-only or not
now we have 28 question
what is an array class
arrays can be created manipulated
searched for and sorted using array
class however the array class does not
belong to the system however the
collection's namespace is still
considered because it implements the
list interface therefore the array class
serves as the foundation for array
supporting language implementations
we have an array class called colors and
we have four colors red blue green and
yellow we print those colors in this
array class example
now the next question is what exactly is
a string what are the characters of
string class a string is the grouped
character object's string variables that
can be declared in c sharp a string
class in c represents a string in the
following example we have a string
called name that is inserted by c sharp
interview questions and answers the
string class has the following
properties
character returns the current strings
character object the length function
returns the number of objects in this
current string
another 30th question
what is an escape sequence name some
strings escape sequences in c sharp in c
sharp a backslash indicates the escape
sequence the backslash indicates that
the character should be
interpreted literally or unique
an escape sequence is treated as if
there were a single character first we
have backslash n which means newline
character next we have backslash b which
is used for backspace then we have two
types of backslash which represents
backslash itself after that we have a
single backslash code and lastly we have
backslash double quote now the 31st
question
what are regular expressions search a
string using regular expressions a
regular expression is a template that
can match a set of input operators
constructs and character literals can
all be used in the pattern for example
regex is used for string parsing and
character string replacement an example
occurs zero or more times before the
preceding character as a result a star b
predicts is equivalent to b comma a b
comma a a b comma a aap and so on
following is the code language program
in which we have strings as c c plus
plus and c sharp then we have cl as an
object and try to find the string c
sharp as we can see c sharp is present
in the following string so we will print
as a match as found
now the next question what are the
fundamental string operations explain
the following are some examples of basic
string operations the first operation is
concatenate a system can concatenate two
strings string concatenate or use the
plus operator the next string operation
is we have modified replace x comma y is
the function that replaces one string
with another the trim function is used
to cut a string at the end or beginning
third string operation is compare
operation system dot string comparison
is used to compare two strings either
case sensitively or not at all it
requires two parameters the original
string and the string to be compared
with the last operation is a search
operation used to find specific string
using the start with and ends with
methods
following question is what exactly is
passing how do you pass a date and time
string the answer with this question is
passing is a process of converting a
string into another data type for
example consider the string value 100
which we are attempting to convert into
a number variable of integer data type
using parse function
as a result the pass method
converts string 100 into its base type
that is integer
following the same method to convert
date time string string date time is
equals to date july 24 2011.
datetime past while is equals to
datetime and pass method
date time
we will now move into the advanced level
interview questions
now the first one in advanced level
interview question is what is a delegate
explain
a delegate is a variable that holds the
reference to a method hence it is a
function pointer or reference type all
delegates are derived from
system.delegate namespace both delegate
and the technique that it refers can
have the same signature
declaring a delegate public delegate
void some numbers end number following a
delegate's declaration the
representative must create the object
using new keyword
some numbers sn1 is equals to some new
numbers of number the delegate acts as
an encapsulation for the reference
method which is called internally when a
delegate is called now the next question
how to use delegates with events
delegated authority is used to initiate
and manage events a delegate must always
particular at first following by the
events
this diagram gives three functions to
delete and the delegate to generate an
event that is an event generator
the next question is what are events
events are user actions that cause the
application to receive notifications to
which it must respond user actions can
include mouse movements keypress and so
on
a class that raises an event is known as
the publisher and the class that
responds or receives the event is known
as a subscriber
if an event does not have one subscriber
it is never raised events are declared
using delegates
in this example we have delegates as
print and os and event names as my event
1.
now the next question is what are the
different types of delegates and
there are three types of delegates the
first one is single delegate a single
delegate is a delegate that can only
call one method
the second type of delicate is the
multicast delegate a delegate that can
call multiple methods is known as a
multicast delegate the plus and minus
operators are used to subscribe and
unsubscribe the third type of delegate
is the generic delegate it does not
require a definition of an instance and
it is classified into three types that
is action function and predicate
so the action is in the preceding
example of delegates the events we can
use the action keyword to replace the
definitions of delegate and even
function a function delegate defines a
method that can take arguments and
results and lastly we have predicate a
method that can be called with arguments
and always returns a bool
now followed by that we have the 38th
question
what do multicast delegates mean
so the answer for this question is in c
sharp multicast delegate is a delegate
that holds the references to a multiple
functions when we invoke the multicast
delegate we gather all the tasks that
the delegate prefers for example if you
want to use a delegate to call multiple
methods all the method signatures must
be seen let's see a code example to
multicast delegate
this program uses a namespace delegate
and then declares delegate as a
multi-delegate with formal arguments a
and b
we define the addition and subtraction
functions in the class program which we
declare and calculate as class b and a
minus b respectively then in the main
function we create a class program
object p1 then we declare md1 and md2
objects for addition and subtraction
operations
then we assign md1 to md1 and md2 giving
a value of 100 to a and a value of 200
to b
now let's try to execute the program and
see the output
now the next question is what are
synchronous and asynchronous operations
so the answer for this question is
synchronization is a technique for
writing thread safe code in which only
one thread can access a resource at any
given time before continuing with the
program flow the asynchronous call waits
for the method to complete in
asynchronous mode the method calls
return immediately so that the program
can perform other operations while the
called method completes its work the
async and await keywords are used to
achieve asynchronous programming in c
sharp
our next question is what exactly is
reflection in c-sharp reflection is the
ability of a code to access the
assemblies metadata during runtime a
program reflects itself and uses
metadata to inform or change its
behavior
system of namespace reflection includes
methods and classes for managing the
information of all loaded types and
techniques it is primarily used in
windows applications such as viewing the
properties of a button in a windows form
the class reflection members inform
object is used to discover the
attributes associated with the class
following that we have reached the next
question that is the 41st question what
is the generic class
generics is also known as gender classes
create courses or objects with no
specific data type for example the data
type can be assigned in runtime that is
the program uses it let's see a simple
code for generic class
in this program we have namespace as
generic class public class test class
and g to represent the generic class
after that we define an array namely
object 1 of generic type with length 5
then we have int variable as count 1
then we have a function as some adding
items mechanism into a generic type next
we have to keep adding items to an array
until the count plus 1 is less than 6
then we have to keep increasing the
count value by one following that we
have an index variable for each
statement iteration in which we have to
get and set properties the get property
is used to return the index value and
the set property is used to set a value
with the same name as the index value
finally we instantiate a generic with an
integer with the object name int obj in
the main method then we add integer
values to the array and finally we
multiply all the values in the array
now let's try to execute this code and
see the output
now the program got successfully
executed and you can see the output
right on my screen
now the next question explain get and
set access properties
get and set are referred to accesses
properties make to use these the
property implements a mechanism for
reading and writing the value of a
private field these accesses are used to
gain access to a private field the get
property method is used to retrieve the
value of a property to change the value
use set property accessor and let's see
an example to understand this in a much
better way
we have a class name as a person name in
this program followed by two variants
firstly we have a private variable as n
for the person's name then we have
public variable
as name one we have get property that
returns variable n and finally we have a
set property that assigns variable m to
the variable value next the value
keyword denotes the value that we
transfer to the property n next in the
main function we have an object name as
my name where we give the name as abc
and finally we display the person's name
as abc
now the output is on my screen right
over here
now let's get back to the ppt
the next question is what exactly is a
thread
and what is multi-threading a thread is
a collection of instructions that can be
executed to allow our program to perform
concurrent processing conference
processing will enable us to perform
multiple operations at the same time
c-sharp has a thread by default however
the other threads can be created to run
code in parallel with the original code
this is accomplished by having different
threats handle different process
referred to as multi-threading to handle
multi-threaded operations several thread
methods are used start sleep about
suspend resume and join are all options
the next question is name some
properties of thread class
some of the properties of thread class
are first we have is a live property
it has word then when a thread is active
this value is actual
the following property is name which
returns the thread's name also can set a
name for the thread following that we
have the next property as priority which
returns the prioritized value of this
task set by the operating system the
background is the following property of
thread class it gets offsets the value
that indicates whether a thread should
be
a background process or a foreground
process last property is we have thread
state which describes the thread state
on the next question we have what are
the different states of a thread so the
different states of thread are
unstarted state which means a threat has
been created
next we have running state which means
that the threat begins execution weight
sleep joint is the third stage
in which a threat calls sleep another
thread calls weight and another thread
calls join next we have suspense state
the thread has been halted about it is
the next state which the thread has died
but not being changed to the state
stopped
last is we have stop state which means
that this thread has come to a halt
followed by this we have the next
question which is what is a deadlock
a deadlock occurs when a process cannot
complete its execution because two or
more methods are awaiting the completion
of another this is common in
multi-threading
followed by that we have another
question explain lock monitors and mutex
object in multi-threading
a lock keyword ensures that only one
thread can enter a specific code section
at a time the preceding example lock ob
jx indicates that a lock placed on obx
until this process releases it at which
no point no other thread will be able to
access obj
mutex is like lock but it can work
across multiple processes simultaneously
for example
weight one method is used to lock the
lock and release mutex is used to unlock
it on the other hand mutex is slower
than lock because it takes time to
acquire and release it monitor enter and
observe internally exits implements a
lock a lock is monitor shortcut
internally and lock objects is called
you can see an example right on my
screen
the next question on the list is what is
race condition
a race condition occurs when two threads
access the same resource and attempt to
change it simultaneously it is
impossible to predict which thread will
be the first to access the resource if
we have two threads t1 and t2 both
attempt to access a shared resource
called x if both threads try to access
or write a value to x the last value
returned to x is saved
49th question in the list is what is
serialization and dc realization the
answer for this question is converting
code to binary format is known as
serialization once converted to budget
is simple to store and write to a disk
or other storage devices serialization
is most valuable when we don't want to
lose the original form of the code and
want to retrieve it at any time in the
future
dc realization refers to recovering c
sharp code from binary form now the 50th
question
what are the different types of
serialization now there are various
types of serialization which are as
follows
the first type of serialization is the
xml serialization the second one is soap
and the last and the third one is the
binary serialization
another 51st question what is an xsd
file
so an xsd file is an abbreviation for
xml schema definition it defines the
structure of an xml file it determines
which element should be represented in
the form of xml and in what order and
which property should be current
during serialization of c sharp code and
x sd.exe converts the classes into xsd
compiler form
now as discussed initially we will go
through some coding based interview
questions
the document of code will be sent to you
feel free to write your emails in the
comment section below so that we can
respond to you at the earliest
now program one is string reverse
so you can see that it is converting
simply learn into the reverse string
which is here
now let us go through the second program
real quick
now on my screen you can see the second
program the second program is based on
converting or checking if the string is
palindrome or not let's quickly execute
this
you can see that it is asking for enter
string
let us enter
p op pop
and it is saying as the string is the
palindrome now let us quickly execute
the third
now the third one is based on substring
operations let's quickly execute the
code
let's enter a string here simply learn
so here you can see the substrings that
can be created using simply learn
now let's execute the fourth code so
this program is based on if checking the
number is prime or not so now let's
enter a number let's enter 7 which is a
prime number which says number is prime
now the fifth question is based on
singleton now let's try to execute this
code and see the output
now you can see the code got
successfully executed and the output is
over here hello and hi
now don't you worry about the code
please feel free to let us know your
email ids in the comment section below
and we will have this code sent over to
you at the earliest
with this the session for today is over
if you like this session then hit that
like button if you haven't subscribed
yet then you can hit that subscribe
button down below and don't forget to
hit the bell icon below so you never
miss an update from simplylands youtube
channel thank you and we will see you on
our next live session
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you